Cole Medin: Alright, so welcome, everyone, to the big Second Brain Mini Course workshop. I have been putting so much prep into this.
Cole Medin: I have a ton of resources available for you guys that we'll get right into. We are going to be building a second brain completely from scratch today. So I've been working on my second brain over the past 3 months at this point.
Cole Medin: And it has gotten to the point where it legitimately saves me at least 20 hours of work every single week.
Cole Medin: And trust me, I've been running a very similar business for the last year and a half. Like, I have a good sense of how long different things take me that I've started to automate with my second brain, either fully automated or partially automated. So I'm not just exaggerating for the sake of this workshop. That is, like, measurable outcomes for me that I have with my second brain. So I've packaged it all up together.
Cole Medin: And I'm giving it all the way to you guys right now.
Cole Medin: And so, going to the browser here.
Cole Medin: First of all, for our workshop here, we have the event with the description. I have a single link in there right now. The recording of this workshop will also be available here in the description after, but right now, I have the repository, which is our reference for everything for today. So my entire second brain.
Cole Medin: I have packaged it up, and I've taken out some of, like, the sensitive stuff and things that are, like, really specific to me. So, what we're looking at right here is a more general implementation of my second brain.
Cole Medin: But it still has everything, like, all of the core architecture, everything that we'll talk about today, this is all in the resource for you guys.
Cole Medin: The point is not for you to take my second brain and run it as is. The point is for you to use this for inspiration, and even point your coding agent to look at what we've built here, to take ideas from my second brain.
Cole Medin: And so another really big thing that I want to be clear on here in this workshop is even if you already have a second brain, like you built your own on top of Claude Code, or you're running an open claw second brain, or a Hermes, whatever it is, you can still take a lot of ideas from what I'm going to show you here in the workshops. This is not just if you want to build completely from scratch.
Cole Medin: Though, if you are, then you're definitely the luckiest out of everyone, because I'm gonna get you such a good starting point in this workshop here.
Cole Medin: I use my second brain for so many different things. I'll give you just, like, a little sneak peek of some of the things I do with it. So, I have my Slack interface where I can talk to it remotely. I have my second brain even deployed in a VPS, just in the cloud, so I'll talk about that at the end of the workshop as well. I have it help me with task planning, using Archon for coding, I have it help me do, like, research for content, YouTube videos.
Cole Medin: videos, managing my inbox, it drafts replies to everything in my inbox. Obviously, there's some things I can't show super clearly here, because it's just really, you know, personal information. Like, I'm not just gonna show my entire Gmail inbox in our workshop today, but just giving you some examples of, like, conversations at a high level that I have with my second brain. I have it help me with thumbnail generation, PowerPoint generation, diagram generation.
Cole Medin: like this diagram that you're looking at right here, of course, I put a lot of my own touch into it, but I used an ExcalDraw diagram skill that I've shared with you guys before. I used it very heavily to build the entire diagram, so the second brain understands itself, so I was able to build this diagram really well.
Cole Medin: Which, that's part of the important thing with our second brain, is it evolves itself over time. We'll talk about what that looks like with the memory system and the daily reflection, how we have our different capabilities through skills, and there's a lot of resources that I have
Cole Medin: for you guys there as well. A lot of the skills that I have in the resources for you here, this is the folder that I linked to in the description, a lot of these you can just take directly as is, and use them immediately. Like, this is one of the biggest value adds out of everything in our workshop today. Like, the ExcalDraw diagram skill that I was talking about just a little bit ago, PowerPoint Generator, this is probably the most elaborate out of all of them. So.
Cole Medin: About halfway through the workshop, that's when we're going to get into skills.
Cole Medin: So I have things broken up by modules here.
Cole Medin: So, like, Module 2's gonna be, like, our memory layer, getting into how we use Claude hooks for the life cycle of our second brain.
Cole Medin: And then we'll get into, you know, like, our direct integrations in Module 4. Module 5 will be skills. I wanted to split it up in this way, because when you're watching this right now, you might be in the course version of our workshop, because after this 4-hour live event here, I am planning on editing things, splicing it up, and making it so that we have 8 distinct modules for this course. So, a lot of structure that I put
Cole Medin: into a lot of planning that I put into this up front.
Cole Medin: to make it as smooth as possible for you guys, because there is a lot that we're building here. So I put a lot of effort into making sure that it's really easy to follow along and grasp the core different components. I don't want everything to just kind of mush together and feel like this massive build that we're doing, but I want it to really be like, if you already have your second brain, and you're just really interested in the skills part, or you're really interested in the daily reflection that I build.
Cole Medin: then there'll be, like, a really distinct part of the workshop where we focus on that, and we build it, because we are building the second brain from scratch. So, I hope that makes sense to you guys, and sounds good.
Cole Medin: Let me go back to my browser here.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, for our workshop here, I wanna say that…
Cole Medin: If you want to create your second brain completely from scratch.
Cole Medin: You can just point your Cloud code over to the repo here and say, like, hey, I want to build this for myself, go and do it.
Cole Medin: But you might not get the best results from doing that. And so I have created a Claude Code skill that'll walk you through creating an entire PRD
Cole Medin: for creating your own second brain. And so, it'll give you a full document, like, full scope of work, here's everything that we have to do to build out the second brain in phases.
Cole Medin: And this, Create Second Brain PRD skill, this is the first thing that we're gonna dive into today. And then we're gonna use the PRD that we generate today, and I'll talk about how we can customize it to our own applications and integrations. We're going to take that, and we're gonna use it to build the entire Second Brain from scratch.
Cole Medin: And so, the way this workshop is gonna go.
Cole Medin: And don't worry, we'll get into the meat of it, like, really quick here, is I want to first talk about why we care about building our own second brain in the first place, so I'll compare to things like Open Claw and Hermes, then we'll cover the structure of the second brain at a high level.
Cole Medin: So, just really high level at first.
Cole Medin: Because then we're gonna get right into creating the PRD. So I have a repository that has nothing in it besides some of the commands from the Agentic coding course. Like, that's it. So I have our commands for, like, priming and implementing and validating all these things that we have for our core piv loops. We're gonna be using everything that I teach in the Agentic Coding course to build this today. And then I have the Create Second Brain PRD skill.
Cole Medin: So, I'm gonna go through live what it looks like.
Cole Medin: to fill out the template. This is a resource that I have for you guys to get started with your own second brain. So there's different questions that you can answer, like how you want your second brain to help, how much autonomy you want it to have. We'll fill this out, we'll create the PRD, and then the rest of the workshop is just going to be building in phases. So breaking it down nice and simple, and then as we wait for Claude Code to build each of the phases, I'll have a lot of time for Q&A.
Cole Medin: So it's going to be built in throughout the workshop. I always say that it's really convenient when these workshops are relying on live coding, because then there's time for questions built right in, and I know that you guys are going to have a lot of questions, because you guys are always so good in the community at just being really engaged and asking the right questions, so we'll have time for that, for sure.
Cole Medin: And you don't have to use quad code.
Cole Medin: It is really, you know, generally considered the best AI coding assistant right now, and so that's what I'm using, like, personally, and what I'll showcase in our workshop today. But if you wanted to use something like Codex or OpenCode to drive the entire system, you definitely can use that as well. So, you're not limited to the coding agent that I use.
Cole Medin: you're not limited to the tools that I use. Like, if you don't want to use Obsidian, or you want to use Telegram instead of Slack, or if you want to deploy to, you know, Hostinger instead of DigitalOcean, you can easily do that, and we'll talk about what it looks like to
Cole Medin: you know, customize the PRD here, so that your coding agent knows exactly, you know, how you want to integrate your second brain into your life.
Cole Medin: I always say that your second brain, you want it to work where you already work. That's why there aren't really, you know, prerequisites for our workshop today. As long as you have a coding agent and you have all these platforms where you already do your task management and file storage and things like that, you're already good to go.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so let's go ahead and kick things off right away.
Cole Medin: with why should you build your own AI second brain? I want to address the elephant in the room here, because when I, you know, talk about building my own second brain on my YouTube channel, or just to people in person, wherever it is, a lot of people say, well, you know, I like OpenClaw. I just have my open claw running.
Cole Medin: And that is really legitimate. Like, OpenClaw is genuinely an impressive application. Like, it blew my socks off when I first saw it, you know, despite of all of the security issues that we'll talk about in just a second here. So, when I built my own second brain, I did take a lot of inspiration from OpenClaw.
Cole Medin: I'll be totally transparent with you guys. I literally, you know, took my Claude code when I was first building my second brain.
Cole Medin: or at least, like, when I was still evolving it quite heavily. I pointed it to the open source repository for OpenClaw, and I said, this repo is genius, what are the takeaways we can have from this to build something like their memory system, or the proactive nature of their agent?
Cole Medin: And that worked really, really well. In fact, what I did for OpenClaw, you guys can literally do for the implementation that I have as the reference. You can point your Clawed code to reference a lot of things that I have here. So you can go through the whole PRD process that we'll cover in a bit, plus point it to my implementation. It's going to save you dozens and dozens of hours building your second brain. You don't have to build it from scratch, but you can still build something
Cole Medin: that you control.
Cole Medin: And so, the reason we care about building our own second brain in the first place is because of something called the lethal trifecta. I've covered this once before in the community.
Cole Medin: But this is what makes personal agents very dangerous. And so, the lethal trifecta, it applies to more than just second brains, or personal agents. This applies to all agents.
Cole Medin: there are 3 parts to the trifecta here. Obviously, that's why it's called a trifecta. We have private data access, we have untrusted content, so there are other people that are able to give inputs into our agent, and then we have what is called an exfiltration vector.
Cole Medin: An exfiltration vector, it's kind of a fancy phrase. All it means is there's some way for the agent to send information back to a malicious attacker through, you know, making an API request or sending a message on Telegram, something like that.
Cole Medin: The thought process behind the lethal trifecta is your agent is at most risk of being compromised if it meets all three of these criteria.
Cole Medin: So if it can access private data, receive untrusted inputs, and have some way to send information back out. Because think about it this way. If your AI agent is able to access things in your email, you know, access private data, and it can receive incoming emails, so theoretically, there could be a prompt injection attack that comes in through an email.
Cole Medin: But if there's no way for it to send private data back out to the attacker, your agent is a lot harder to compromise if it only matches two out of the three criteria in the lethal trifecta.
Cole Medin: And just to give you another example here, let's say that there is an exfiltration vector. Your agent is allowed to make arbitrary API requests so it can send data out to the internet, and it could theoretically have a prompt injection attack.
Cole Medin: but there's no access to private data, then it doesn't really matter if there is a prompt injection attack, because what is it really going to access, even if it could send something to an attacker? Not that your agent is fully secure at this point, but just saying that, like, we really need to hit on all three of these points.
Cole Medin: In order for there to really be a big, big security concern with our agent.
Cole Medin: And the thing is, in order for a second brain to be useful for us, it really has to have all three of these criteria met by default.
Cole Medin: Like, if there's no exfiltration vector, it means that it's not possible for my agent to make any kind of API request. It can't even build Python scripts for me, like, it'd be very limiting.
Cole Medin: And obviously, we want our agent to deal with our inbox, and deal with, you know, searching the web, so pulling in other information from the web. We want it to help us manage our life, so it's gonna have access to our tasks, and our calendar, and our email, and I'll show you what it looks like to set up all of that. And so, all this means that, like, we have to be very, very careful about bringing an AI agent as a second brain into our life.
Cole Medin: And to me, this is where I make the connection here, so bear with me. To me, when you bring in an application like OpenClaw, it isn't being very careful.
Cole Medin: Unless you spend a ton of time auditing and customizing, and I would argue at that point it would be easier to just build it yourself anyway. And I think you'll agree with me, after we go through this workshop, I have the foundation laid for you so much that it is going to be easy to build it and then evolve it over time.
Cole Medin: So, OpenClaw, they've been doing a pretty good job improving a lot of their security issues over the past couple of months, but it's still not perfect. And, okay, this is the craziest part. Did you guys know, I think OpenClaw fixed this at this point, but did you know that when OpenClaw first came out, whenever you wanted to set new integrations.
Cole Medin: the agent would literally ask you to paste API keys into the prompt for the large language model. So you would just be giving your keys in plain text to OpenClaw, which is just one of the most ridiculous things I've ever heard, and so many people were doing that. And people were installing malicious skills from the open marketplace that they had called ClawHub. There were so many crazy problems with OpenClaw, and a lot of them still exist.
Cole Medin: So many security vulnerabilities. Companies like Cisco calling it a nightmare, like, hey, you should never even install this.
Cole Medin: I think that's exaggerated to an extent, but you get the idea here. The main thing is, when you build your own second brain.
Cole Medin: you have full control. You actually understand the codebase, and you can use Claude Code to help you understand what you're building, even if you're not quite as technical while you build it. You get to define every permission, so we start more with a zero-trust policy.
Cole Medin: And if you come from the software engineering industry, you know what I mean by that. If you think of something like you're working in AWS, and you're setting up your IAM policies or your firewalls, like, you start with zero trust, and you build permission over time as you trust your system, and you set up the guardrails and the other things for security. And so OpenClaw is the opposite of that. There's so much power. OpenClaw literally has its own computer.
Cole Medin: And there is a lot of risk that comes with that. Like, it has computer access, it can pretty much do
Cole Medin: anything it wants to, and you can't just rely on your prompting to give it guardrails. Like, you might say, like, never delete an email in my inbox. Well, it might not always listen to that. So just because you prompt it doesn't mean that won't end up happening.
Cole Medin: We've heard of cases, horror stories on the internet where people have literally had their entire inbox or Google Drive just wiped off the face of the earth from OpenClaw, even though there were explicit instructions to not do that. And so when we build our own second brain, that is our opportunity to build in guardrails and have more strict permissions around what our integrations can actually do, so that, for example, we can draft emails into
Cole Medin: email, if we want to, you know, automatically draft replies and help us handle our inbox, but we can never send an email, or delete an email, or mark it as spam, because we might not want to give power to our agent to do that like OpenClaw. I mean, maybe you do, and that's great, and you can add that in, but the point is we start with no trust, and we build that in over time. That is why we want to build our own second brain. Your system, your rules, and your data
Cole Medin: actually stays yours. That is very important.
Cole Medin: And in the end, our codebase is going to be a lot simpler than OpenClaw. I don't know exactly where it's at now, but when OpenClaw was first released, there was 175,000 lines of code in the OpenClaw codebase.
Cole Medin: pretty crazy. It's gonna be very hard to maintain that, and really, as a user of OpenClaw, actually understand it. So we're gonna build something a lot simpler, but still just as capable for our own needs.
Cole Medin: And so, it goes with the advice of Anthropic, when building AI agents, this really applies to all agents, but especially second brains, it's good to just build with simple.
Cole Medin: composable patterns. We're going to be using Claude Code, we're going to use the Cloud Agent SDK for all of the autonomous tasks our second brain will be doing. I'll show you how to build all of that. And then most of the capabilities that we give to our agent is simply through Cloud Code skills.
Cole Medin: And so, as we go through the architecture of the second brain here.
Cole Medin: I think you guys will, like, really see quickly and grasp quickly how simple this actually is under the hood. I mean, there's a reason that I'm going to be able to build most of this second brain with you guys in just 4 hours. We might go a little bit over because of questions, and I'm totally good for that, by the way.
Cole Medin: And it's not like in 4 hours we're gonna get something that's just as good as my second brain that I use for myself, but the point is more that, like, we're gonna have a foundation that would be good enough to call a second brain, and it would immediately be useful to you guys.
Cole Medin: And then, kind of how I see it is, like, after this 4-hour workshop, you guys have a starting point, or you've taken inspiration from certain components here, and then over the next couple of weeks or a couple of months, you just continue to evolve it. And we're creating the foundation here where it's very easy to evolve our second brain. That's another thing that I'll be sure to hit on with you guys quite a bit as we're building things here. And I'd love to answer questions on that as well.
Cole Medin: Because, one of the things that I'm really gonna have you guys guide in our workshop here is, by asking questions about, like, how do we actually evolve this for ourself? Or how do we make this even more personal to us? I want to hear from you guys during the Q&A time, like.
Cole Medin: what do you guys want your second brain to do for yourself? And I'd love to give you suggestions, and we can talk about that together. I'm sure there's ways that you guys want to use a second brain for yourself that I haven't even thought of for myself before, so I would love to just have time for that, at least a few times throughout our four hours here, to just talk about use cases, right? Like, I shared at the start some of the ways that I like using my second brain, but
Cole Medin: There are certainly a million ways that we can use it. Even just some random things. For example.
Cole Medin: I don't show it here in the core layer, because this I wanted to keep more general, but I actually use my second brain to help me, it keeps me accountable for my habits. There are 5 core habits that I want to, you know, kind of check off every single day.
Cole Medin: And it keeps me accountable. I have it, like, help me manage my investments and, like, things that I have to take care of at home, so it does things for my personal life, not just my business. Like, over time, I've just built more and more capability over time, and it's very easy to do so, because
Cole Medin: I have things created in a very general way, where it's easy to add new skills, it's very easy to add new integrations, I'll talk about the templates that I have for that as well. And so, yeah, just, I want to talk to you guys about use cases for second brains as well.
Cole Medin: So, alright, that's an overview of why you should build your own, what we're going to get into today. So, yeah, like I said, I want to really just cover the infrastructure at a high level, and then we're going to immediately get into using that PRD skill.
Cole Medin: And so, we'll fill out this template, and then we're just gonna start building. It's gonna be a blast.
Cole Medin: Alright, and so before we do that, I'm just gonna take a pause here and see what kinds of comments and questions we have. So, mostly, I'm going to be doing that while Cloud Code is running, but just because we're not getting into that quite yet, I want to make sure that we have a chance for this here.
Cole Medin: And then one other thing that I'll say…
Cole Medin: is that, on my right monitor here, so I have the chat on the left monitor, that's what I'm looking there, and then on my right monitor, I have some notes here.
Cole Medin: Just to make sure that I hit on everything during the 4 hours, because trust me, guys, 4 hours is a lot of content to prepare. I want to make sure that I don't miss anything. In fact, there is… there is one important thing that I wanted to say, and, that is…
Cole Medin: this whole process of building the second brain from scratch, I actually already did it. So I did a dry run of the entire workshop yesterday. I built my entire second brain, and then I had Claude Code compare what I just built to what I have, like, running for myself, and make sure that it's not missing anything.
Cole Medin: So, like, what we're doing today is the real deal. Like, I literally built it from scratch and made sure that the whole, like, Cloud Code PRD skill that we're gonna walk through, like, doesn't actually miss anything.
Cole Medin: From what I built for myself, so, yeah. A lot of work I put into it.
Cole Medin: Alright, so let's see what we got in the chat here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Funny, Cole, I just built a massive PRD generator for helping people become full-stack builders. Very cool. Including a PRD generator from code for older projects, where the PMs have disappeared, or the PRD was not kept up to date. That is very cool.
Cole Medin: That's awesome.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Jeffrey said, open claw is just hype. I mean, to an extent, it is. I will say, though, that, like, a lot of my second brain, like I mentioned earlier, is taking inspiration from Open Claw, so I would not recommend running it yourself.
Cole Medin: But taking ideas from it is totally valid, and taking ideas from Hermes, and NanoClaw and Ironclaw and all these other agents out there, it definitely is a good idea.
Cole Medin: Also, Sean, I love the memes. Keep them coming. Let me address the elephant in the room. Man, I don't know how you do it, they're always so good.
Cole Medin: And yes, OpenClaw is definitely vibe-coded.
Cole Medin: I mean, we know that, what's… what's the guy's name? Peter? Peter Steinfeld? Is that the name of the creator of OpenClaw? The guy that got brought into OpenAI. He has, like, 13 codecs instances running in parallel at, like, any given time. He is pushing PR after PR, which is… it's cool to see in one sense, but in another sense, it… it is, when you look into the codebase, it's pretty clear that there's a lot of over-engineering.
Cole Medin: It's one of the things that I try to avoid when I'm using AI coding assistants, and it's a big part of, like, what I talk about in the Agenta coding course as well. It's like, here's how we build a system for not just, like, reliability, but avoiding some of the common pitfalls of coding agents like over-engineering.
Cole Medin: Lost some respect for Jensen when I saw him pedaling open claw and GTC.
Cole Medin: And comparing it to the Linux kernel, oh, I know, yeah, I cringed a little bit when I saw that too, Sameet.
Cole Medin: It's unfortunate, because, like, from a marketing standpoint, like, I get it, I get it, but there has to be, like, a fine line of, like, how far you'll go to just, like, jump on whatever's gonna get the most attention. And, I try to respect that line in my content a lot, which is why I never shared anything for, like, you know, open clause, amazing, let's run it, you know?
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Jason said, Cloud Code deleted my entire program data folder on a Windows 10 system. Oh, when I was using it to help clean up
Cole Medin: an old Windows installation after telling it to explicitly never touch that folder. Rules are one thing, but enforcing specific file permissions, exactly, that's what we'll talk about with hooks in this workshop. And configuring Cloud to use a specific user based on the terminal login
Cole Medin: is the safest thing I've found to protect after that. Yeah, that's a good lesson, Jason. I'm sorry… I'm really sorry you had to learn that the hard way. But yeah, when we talk about how we use hooks.
Cole Medin: Especially when we get into the security layer that I have towards the end of our workshop, we'll talk about how we can, enforce deterministic checks to prevent Claude from accessing folders outside of its working directory and, you know, reading environment variable files. We'll get into all that. That's a really, really important part of a second brain, is…
Cole Medin: Making sure that we enforce things through rules, deterministic rules, not just prompting, because prompting is not enough
Cole Medin: Like, the unfortunate example that Jason just gave us here.
Cole Medin: Roman said, can this second brain agent work with local LLMs instead of Cloud code? And the answer is 100%, because actually, you can run Cloud code with local models, because you, Olama actually has a direct integration with Cloud Code.
Cole Medin: I don't want to dive into this right now, just for the sake of time, but if you just do a little bit of Google searching or ask Claude about the Ollama integration, you can run your models through OLAMA and then have Claude Code use that instead of going out to the frontier anthropic models.
Cole Medin: And then, I believe there are ways to use other providers. If you want to use, you know, like Llama CPP or LiteLLM or something instead of Olama directly, then you definitely can as well.
Cole Medin: And so, everything that I cover here for building a second brain, I, I mean, security is important to me. I'm okay, personally, just having everything go out to the Anthropic API.
Cole Medin: But if you do want to…
Cole Medin: be really careful about, you know, working with your private information. I totally respect that, and so it's not going to be a big focus of our workshop here, especially because I knew that people would be asking questions like you are right now, and I appreciate that. And so, I just want to address it more briefly and say, like, it is 100% possible, because even Cloud Code itself can be used with local models, so if you want to keep your entire second brain running locally.
Cole Medin: There is absolutely nothing stopping you from doing that. It's very easy to make those changes. That's one of the things that you can even customize in the PRD that we'll go through in a bit.
Cole Medin: Carsten said, I'm having my second brain agent suggest my most valuable next to-do. That is right. That's the beauty of a second brain, is not only does it save you time right when you first build it, but it saves you more time over time, because it can literally tell you
Cole Medin: like, based on what I see you doing day-to-day, here's how I think I can help even more.
Cole Medin: And we can build a proactive part of the agent that will, like, literally self-evolve itself. Be like, oh, I noticed that I could, like, help you draft a lot of emails here, and you don't have that built in yet. Like, let me go ahead and just build that in, validate it, and now, going forward, I'll help you draft emails. It's really cool what you can do for just the self-evolution.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Very cool. So, yeah, there's a lot of questions.
Cole Medin: That, that we got in the chat here. I do want to make sure…
Cole Medin: I want to make sure that I get through things at a good pace, so I don't know if I'll be able to ask all questions.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, I will say that, like, going forward, when you guys have a question, make sure, what I want to do for this workshop here is make sure that you ask it in the Q&A part of Zoom.
Cole Medin: So, I'll show what it looks like, well, actually, I'll just explain it really quick. So, if you click on the More, the three dots that says More in your bottom middle in Zoom.
Cole Medin: Then you can open up the Q&A,
Cole Medin: And, this is just gonna be easier for me to organize all the questions, so that, like, you guys can still chat with each other, just, like, directly in the Zoom chat, and then it doesn't have to, like, convolute with all the questions as well.
Cole Medin: So, like, one example here, we actually do have a question from, JG. Can we use the second brain? So I can click, like, answer live here… can we use the second brain in a team? In your opinion, what should we change so that several users in an organization can use it safely and effectively?
Cole Medin: So, that is a really good question. I'd love to address that before we get into things here. So, I use my second brain just for myself, but there's nothing stopping you from having multiple people with access to it, and I…
Cole Medin: kind of done that to an extent. It's a bit different because she's my wife, and so I kind of want to give her access to everything. But Sydney, my wife, she can talk to my second brain through her own Slack account as well.
Cole Medin: So one of the things that I built into my second brain is, there's, like, an environment variable, like a configuration option, that just has, like, a comma-separated list of the Slack user IDs, the people that are allowed to converse with my agent.
Cole Medin: So if my second brain receives a message in Slack, it's gonna check it against that list, and only if it matches in that list will it, you know, give a response.
Cole Medin: Now, when she talks to it, it doesn't really know that it's her versus me, and that's okay, because I kind of just want her to use it as an extension, like, kind of like she using it just like I use it. But if you wanted to make it so the second brain would, like, actually recognize, like.
Cole Medin: you know, this is team member A, here are the things they're working on, this is team member B, here are the things they're working on. Then you'd have to have some kind of separation of memories between users. That's outside of the scope for our second brain here, but it would be pretty easy to extend everything that I built right now
Cole Medin: to make that possible. Like, when we create the PRD together, you'll… you'll see how you can, like, talk to Clawko and say, like, hey, I actually want, like, a whole team to use this, and I want to be able to, like, have the second brain understand, like, this is Jeremy talking, or, you know, like, this is Pavel talking, like, it is different people.
Cole Medin: And so then they maybe could even have, like, separate memories, because it could basically be, like, your database could have a filter, based on the Slack user ID, so you'd only search through those memories, or access these folders in your Obsidian Vault, or Notion, or wherever you're storing information for your team.
Cole Medin: So, definitely possible.
Cole Medin: And then, for the starter repo, Bart asked about the repo. Yeah, so in the description, and Rasmus asked about this as well, so in the description for our event, I'll put a link to this in the Zoom chat right here.
Cole Medin: I have a link to the full implementation of my second brain for your reference. This is a more general implementation, but it has, like I said, literally everything that I have in my second brain. I even verified it when I built it fully from scratch. And so, this is something you can reference if you want.
Cole Medin: But also, I am going to show you how to build it fully from scratch, with the whole PRD process we'll get into. So, yeah, alright.
Cole Medin: And, if the link doesn't work for you for whatever reason.
Cole Medin: then there is a form that you have to fill out to get access to the GitHub repository. So I just saw your comment there, Ben. I'm gonna go ahead and paste in the link. So you have to fill out this form in order to get access to the GitHub organization for Dynamis.
Cole Medin: And then all the links will work for you. So, if it says 404 not found, it doesn't mean the link's broken, it means you don't have access. I don't know why GitHub doesn't just give you an access error, it's a little annoying, but just make sure you fill that out. Yep, you're welcome.
Cole Medin: Yeah, and so once you do that, fill that out, you're going to get an invite sent to your email, and then also, if you go to the homepage of the GitHub organization, it should auto-direct you there. Then there's a banner for you to accept the invite, and if something doesn't work, you enter in the wrong
Cole Medin: GitHub email or something for… by accident, you can just feel free to message me, and I'll take care of it for you after.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, a lot of questions that I'll get into once Claude Code is working for us here, but let me go back to the diagram, and we'll dive into a brief overview of everything that we have. I just want to give you guys an introduction to the different components.
Cole Medin: And then, obviously, we'll expand on things a lot when we actually build it. And so, while we're waiting for Cloud code.
Cole Medin: to finish.
Cole Medin: I'll be answering questions, but then also, like, getting into some of the nitty-gritty details that I think are really, really important. There are so many, even, like, smaller lessons that I learned that made a huge difference for me that I want to pass on to you guys. Like, for example, how we do the whole, memory promotion process. So, if you guys have heard of the Cloud Code Dream feature, and, like, the auto-dreaming, we actually have that built into the second brand. It's one of the things we'll build, so…
Cole Medin: I'll, talk about what that looks like as well.
Cole Medin: So, the first thing, and this is actually heavily inspired by OpenClaw, we have our memory layer. This is one of the things that we're going to cover first. I store all of my memory layer within an obsidian vault.
Cole Medin: So, Obsidian, this is the platform that we're looking at right here. It's my local, note-taking, second-brain application. It's very similar to Notion.
Cole Medin: You don't have to be using Obsidian for this workshop.
Cole Medin: You probably already have someplace where you're storing documents, like Notion, or Google Drive, whatever that might be. You can certainly integrate your agent to work anywhere. The reason that I use and recommend Obsidian is because everything is simply stored as markdown documents in our local system, which makes it very fast to access and easy for us to manage, and Obsidian gives me the canvas
Cole Medin: to view things really easily, like my diagrams and research and everything that I'm producing with my second brain, PDF documents, PowerPoints, I can view it all right in Obsidian.
Cole Medin: So that's my recommendation. But the larger point here is regardless of where you're storing your memory layer, we have core files that dictate how our agent operates. And this is the biggest thing that we evolve over time, because we want our agent to remember all of our interactions, we want it to extract lessons automatically from tasks that we assign to it, or things that we did with it. That's what we're going to be…
Cole Medin: Building at the start of our workshop here, or the start of, like, the live build part.
Cole Medin: And so we have our soul.md, this is the core identity file for our second brain. And so we're going to actually use a Claude Code hook, a session start hook.
Cole Medin: So that whenever we begin a new session with Cloud Code, either on our computer or even remotely in Slack, it's going to automatically inject these core Markdown documents. It's core memory, the soul.md that speaks to its nature, we get to, like, kind of describe its nature.
Cole Medin: And then also all the core information about us.
Cole Medin: And so the user.md is also very important, because it's essentially our user profile. So it knows our name, our time zone, our email, core IDs for our platforms, like here's my project ID in Asana, or here's my folder ID in Google Drive, where I store all my YouTube videos, like, whatever that might be. We get to store that core information here.
Cole Medin: And we could just shove all of this into a clod.md. It could just all be global rules. You can think of a lot of this like global rules, but it's useful for us to keep things more organized into files that have a very clear purpose, right? So that's why we have this separation here.
Cole Medin: And then the memory.md, this is a really cool file.
Cole Medin: Because we're going to automatically build this over time. Every single conversation we have with Claude Code, or with whatever coding agent for your second brain.
Cole Medin: We're going to extract the key lessons and things into a daily logs file. So we build up this log over time. I'll even show you guys what this looks like. Like, for every single day, all of my conversations, we have a daily log where it remembers the key decisions that we made in our different conversations.
Cole Medin: The problem is the daily log gets very, very large, so we don't want to just, like, dump everything into the memory.md, because this is loaded into the coding agent up front, so this
Cole Medin: Is where we only store our most important memories, the really crucial decisions that we've made and lessons that we've learned.
Cole Medin: And so this is where I have something set up very similarly to the Cloud Code Dream feature.
Cole Medin: Where we have this daily reflection process that runs. So I run it once a day. You could run this overnight, so it's literally dreaming, but what it does is it looks through the raw daily logs. This has, like, all of the information from our conversations, and it figures out what's worth keeping. What are the super
Cole Medin: critical decisions or lessons or important facts, and then it puts that in the memory.md.
Cole Medin: And so, over time, we build up the very key information. But then, the other thing is we can still search through our daily logs if we want. So there's a little bit of reg that happens in our second brain. This is how open claw actually works as well. So we have a hybrid search, it's both semantic search through a vector database, and then also keyword search
Cole Medin: That is how we're able to still look through all of our daily logs. So, it gets very informationally dense over time as you're using this day in and day out, and so that's why we want RAG and not just having it look through all the files, because it's going to be hundreds of thousands, millions of tokens as you're using your agent for months and weeks.
Cole Medin: And so, with the search, it is able to access everything that we've done in the past, but then it still has very quick recall for core decisions. That's the distinction that we are making here.
Cole Medin: And then, what we are also doing with Cloud Code hooks is, every time we're about to compact a conversation, or right after a session ends, and again, we're doing this both when we talk to our agent on our computer and also remotely through Slack or wherever you want to hook it up.
Cole Medin: What we do at session end and memory compact is we're going to send the conversation into a separate Cloud Code instance using the Cloud Agent SDK.
Cole Medin: So, right here.
Cole Medin: We, we gather the conversation history, right? Like, we read the transcript, and then we have what I call the memory flush system. We take our summaries of the conversations, that's what we put in the daily logs. So we're not just dumping the entire conversation, because that'd be way too much even for daily logs. So that's one of the things we'll build together. Like, I'll show you what that actually looks like.
Cole Medin: And then we have our direct integrations.
Cole Medin: So this is Module 4, we'll get into that towards the end of the first half of our workshop here. This is how we give our agent the eyes into our life, right? Like, being able to access our email, our calendar, task management, whatever you want. We'll talk about what it looks like to build any integration into our second brain, and there's even, like, a template that I have in the repository.
Cole Medin: to give you guys a starting point, like a template for Claude to build any integration for itself. So the second brain, you can just say, like, I want to add this new integration, and it can just do the web research, do the implementation, do the validation, and add in any integration without you really having to lift a finger at all. You probably just have to handle the authentication.
Cole Medin: And that's about it.
Cole Medin: And then, through the integrations, it's kind of tied closely to the skills, because the skills are how we give capabilities to our agents. So the integrations is connecting it to the platforms. Now, the skills is defining our workflows. How do we want it to help us research, or create YouTube scripts, or build diagrams, right? And there's a lot of examples that I have for you guys for skills. So, getting into the second half of the workshop.
Cole Medin: That's when we'll talk about adding in skills, and we'll even have a skill that tells our second brain how to work with our integrations, right? So that's how we make that connection there.
Cole Medin: And skills are very common in Cloud Code, so I'm going to assume that you guys in general understand the basics of Clod Code skills.
Cole Medin: If anyone has any questions for how that works when we get to it, we definitely can, but I more just want you guys to, like, use the references that I have, the starting points that I have for all of my skills, and then build your own on top of that, just taking inspiration from these ideas. Again, I want you to really personalize this as much as you want, if you're building live with me here, or just taking ideas. Everything here
Cole Medin: Is… is really for your inspiration.
Cole Medin: And so, as far as the memory search pipeline goes, we'll talk about that when we build the whole searching functionality. So, I'm gonna keep the rag pretty basic. We're literally just using SQLite, so you don't have to go set up some other database or anything. There's no prerequisite for that. I'm keeping things as simple as possible. OpenClaw actually also works the same way, where they just use SQLite.
Cole Medin: There's no need to overcomplicate things with…
Cole Medin: setting up, you know, like, Quadrant, or Pinecone, or Postgres, or something like that. You definitely can if you want, but you don't have to.
Cole Medin: And then, we also have the chat interface, so this is gonna be in the second half of our workshop as well, where we'll create the chat interface. I use Slack, but it's gonna be very easy for you to adapt this to use something else like WhatsApp or Telegram, if you would like.
Cole Medin: And then the last, like, really big part of our second brain here
Cole Medin: is the heartbeat. This is the proactive part of our agent.
Cole Medin: And so, you can do whatever you want with your heartbeat, but mine, it checks all of my platforms every half hour. So it looks at my…
Cole Medin: email, my calendar, it looks at our community here in Dynamis, and it alerts me for anything that really, really needs my attention. I'm generally good at being on top of things, even without my second brain, but man, this has made it even easier to manage things, and help me sift through, especially with my inbox, like, things that I don't necessarily want to pay attention to.
Cole Medin: And it even will do things like draft replies to my emails.
Cole Medin: And I haven't done this yet, you could if you want, but you could, like, create issues in a GitHub repository, and then have your agent, like, proactively create pull requests for those issues. Like, you could have it so your second brain handles that automatically, maybe even using the Archon CLI. So, talking about Archon with the second brain, that is outside of the scope of our workshop here, but I will be doing follow-up workshops talking more about how
Cole Medin: We can integrate our second brain with Archon to handle coding tasks proactively.
Cole Medin: And you could, of course, build that without Archon as well, just trying to give some examples here.
Cole Medin: But the cool part about the Heartbeat is I actually load context from my integrations deterministically. It's very token efficient, because as much of the process as I can take away from the agent, I actually do.
Cole Medin: And so it finds my latest emails that I haven't replied to, the latest posts in our community, things like that. It gathers all that context, and then it sends it in as a large prompt to the Cloud Agent SDK.
Cole Medin: So you can see that I color-coded everything in the diagram, like, this is in purple, because it is using the Clod Agent SDK. We're not talking to Claude code directly, because this is running as a background task, as a cron job.
Cole Medin: So we gather information from the APIs, and we have Claude reason about that, performing actions on our behalf, and then I always have it send me a notification in Slack. And so I call that my heartbeat, because it's giving me a pulse on my business, and on my life, and helping me know, like, things that it just took care of, and things that need my attention. And I've made it very, very efficient.
Cole Medin: I've actually tracked the cost of things. However, I am also using my Anthropic subscription, so it's not like this is really costing me anything beyond what I just pay normally monthly to Cloud Code in the first place, but I have done a lot for my second brain to optimize the cost of things as well.
Cole Medin: And then we also have the Vault Sync, so when I get into the remote deployment of the second brain at the very end of our workshop, we'll talk about this.
Cole Medin: And, so that way, I don't even have to, like, pay for the Obsidian Sync subscription or anything, I just have it use Git.
Cole Medin: to sync the changes to my vaults remotely, like whenever I'm talking to my second brain in Slack and changing things there, it automatically syncs to the vault that I have running locally, like what we are looking at right here. Like, this is my vault, these are all my memories running on my local machine.
Cole Medin: So yeah, and then we'll get into the security as well. I'm going to actually knock out the security and infrastructure in parallel at the end of our workshop here, just for the sake of time, and both of them are actually pretty simple overall to implement, following the PRD.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool. So, that is an overview of everything that we're gonna build here. And hopefully, like, even just seeing the different components here, like, already gives you guys some inspiration and some ideas for things you can do, like how I've built in the whole
Cole Medin: dream thing automatically, and how I'm using integrations and skills, and even using skills to tell my second brain how to use my integrations.
Cole Medin: and the whole, like, rag thing for the daily logs, like, I hope you guys can see a lot of good stuff there. But, obviously throughout our workshop here, I'm gonna make it extremely concrete for you guys, because you get to see it built live, and ask all the questions that you need.
Cole Medin: And so, the last thing that I want to cover Before we get into our… Prd here.
Cole Medin: is I want to cover the… I guess, like, a second elephant in the room. So I talked about OpenClaw, but I also want to talk about using your Anthropic subscription, just really quickly here, because I know that people are going to have questions on this.
Cole Medin: So, within the last couple of months, there have… there's been a lot of controversy around using your Anthropic subscription with the Cloud Agent SDK.
Cole Medin: This is how we invoke Cloud Code programmatically.
Cole Medin: for the more autonomous parts of our second brain, like our heartbeat and our memory reflection. So this is a core part of what we're building today.
Cole Medin: And the Anthropic docs, they had some update that made it seem really clear that we were banned from using our Anthropic subscription with the Cloud Agent SDK. As in, we had to use an Anthropic API key and pay per token, which is a lot more expensive. We don't want to have to do that if we don't have to.
Cole Medin: So it looked a little doom and gloom. But then Tariq, he's on the team from Anthropic.
Cole Medin: he made a clarifying statement through X, and I'm kind of just taking his word for it here. I think we really can, though, and I'll talk about that in a… talk about why in a second here, but…
Cole Medin: He said that nothing is changing how you can use the Agent SDK and Mac subscription. We want to encourage local development and experimentation with the Agent SDK and Claude-P.
Cole Medin: And building a second brain, it is a personal application, it falls under local development. And so I am very confident, and this is what I do for myself, you are allowed to use your Anthropic subscription with the agent SDK, as long as other people aren't using your second brain.
Cole Medin: So if you have a team member that wants to start using your second brain, or you're building it for a team, then I would actually argue that you do have to use the API key instead. Like they say here, if you're building a business on top of the agent SDK, then you should use an API key instead.
Cole Medin: Because at that point, what they mean by building a business on top is, like, this is a product, now you have other people using your subscription, they don't want that kind of abuse. And they have left their documentation very, vague.
Cole Medin: and kind of contradictory, and I think that's more just so they have an excuse to ban people that are using their subscription through OpenClaw and OpenCode and those things that they're not allowing.
Cole Medin: But I've been using my subscription with the Cloud Asian SDK for the last 3 months now, and even beyond that, before my second brain, with Archon and other applications, and as long as it's running on your own machine, and it's local development, or running in a machine in the cloud that you control, and it's your codebase, then you are good. And there is certainly some gray area with that.
Cole Medin: But…
Cole Medin: To my knowledge, everything that I have in the second brain, you're 100% good to use. And if there's anything really specific that maybe you would have to use your API key instead, or you have other people using your brain, it's certainly going to be easy to use your API key instead. That's just a configuration change. There's nothing you have to change in your code itself.
Cole Medin: And I did, like I said, do… I did a lot of work to make sure that things are quite token efficient, especially, like, with the heartbeat system.
Cole Medin: A lot of work I put into that over the last couple of months. It used to cost, like, a dollar per run instead of 5 cents, because I used to have it actually, like, do all the gathering of information through the agent instead of deterministically. So, a lot of optimizations there.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Very cool. So I'm gonna take a pause for some questions here, again, and then we're gonna get right into creating our PRD, and this is where you guys can really start to follow along, and we're gonna be building things from scratch. So just give me a moment to look through the chat here, and we'll do a little bit of time for Q&A.
Cole Medin: Kaushik said, if you use a hook, you need to use the agent SDK, so is it okay to use the SDK programmatically? For that aspect, I think we should be good. Yep, so if you're calling Claude through a hook, like we'll actually do for our whole memory flush thing, I… again, I use my subscription, I don't have to use the Anthropic API key for that.
Cole Medin: Okay, so Ivo asked, when do you expect to publish the video from this workshop? You said you'd be taking snippets for a new course, but is the unedited workshop video going to be available like the others?
Cole Medin: Yep, so our recording here, the unedited version, I'll have that within 24 hours, just posted in the description for the event. It's only gonna be the more edited one that would be probably, like, sometime next week. It'll be a good amount of effort to edit it down, but I'll try to get that pretty soon as well. But yeah, the recording, the full 4-hour recording, if you guys are only here for part of the workshop or whatever, will be available.
Cole Medin: Later today.
Cole Medin: It takes a while to pro- for Zoom to process four-hour meetings, I've learned. So it won't… definitely won't be for a bit today, but it'll be, like, before tomorrow morning, basically.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Oh, okay, Danny asks, is there any connection from this second brain with Tiago Forte's second brain? So, I have… I've heard a lot about Tiago Forte.
Cole Medin: But I have not actually studied his content, or his second brain, so I would not say there's really a connection. But this is a cool opportunity to say something. Thiago Forte, he actually just started a cohort.
Cole Medin: Teaching people how to build a second brain.
Cole Medin: But believe it or not, in order to join that cohort, it is $3,000. I'm sure that it's very, very comprehensive, and so maybe it's not, like, totally fair to just, like, say this, but it's like, you guys get to build your own second brain.
Cole Medin: with me right now, and all you have to do is be a part of the Dynamist community. And I'm giving you guys something that saves me 20 hours a week. I don't know if, like, Tiago Fortes would save, like, 40 hours a week, but I really doubt it, right? So he's charging 3 grand to be a part of the cohort. It's kind of crazy.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, I mean, I've heard good things about
Cole Medin: Thiago Forte, I've never met him, but I met, like, his… actually, kind of funny, in Jan… or February, I met his, like, personal assistant.
Cole Medin: In person, which is kind of cool. So, I'm sure he's a very respectful guy, but, like, man, $3,000 for a cohort is, like…
Cole Medin: Really? Like, come on. So, yeah, it's funny that you bring that up, Danny. So, yeah, not really any connection here, but, yeah, I mean, there are probably good ideas to take from that as well, honestly. And that's the thing that I'm really trying to, like.
Cole Medin: bring home for you guys here is that, building a second brain is all about just, like, taking ideas from how other people are using it. Like, that's what I'm trying to give a ton to you guys right now, even if you already have your second brain, just more and more ideas.
Cole Medin: excuse me, and, like, taking inspiration from, you know, Thiago Forte's Second Brain, if you follow his YouTube content, or if you do actually join the cohort and pay the $3,000.
Cole Medin: Or if you're, like, looking at Open Claw, or Nemo Claw, or whatever.
Cole Medin: So, just so many different ideas, and your second brain can handle more integrations and more skills. We're gonna be building something that's very scalable, so you don't have to be worried about, like, if I add this integration, am I gonna start overwhelming my second brain? It's really not going to work like that, so the world is your oyster for what you're able to build into it.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Josh asked, what options would you recommend for something more private than Slack? Will this work with Matrix? Claude code natively doesn't work well with Matrix.
Cole Medin: So, the kind of easy answer to your question, Josh, is that any platform is going to work.
Cole Medin: Because we're not relying on Claude Code working with the platform.
Cole Medin: And this is, like, really important to specify. We'll talk about this more when I build the chat platform towards the end of our workshop, but the chat platform is just the entry point into the Cloud Agent SDK.
Cole Medin: So, all Slack does for me is it gives me a way to send a message into Cloud Code. So, within my Python code, I receive the message from Slack.
Cole Medin: And then I prompt it… I prompt the Cloud Agent SDK with it. And so, my second brain, it doesn't actually really know that I'm using Slack. It literally doesn't care. That's just my…
Cole Medin: kind of way to get to it, right? Like, when I'm on my phone, and I don't want to use the Cloud Code CLI directly like I'm doing on my desktop, because on my phone, I don't really have that, right? So there's a clear delineation there, where there's not, like, some MCP server or some kind of, like, integration or connection that we're doing between our chat platform
Cole Medin: and the Cloud Agent SDK. So, you should be able to use Matrix.
Cole Medin: You should… you can use Microsoft Teams, WhatsApp, Telegram, GitHub, I mean, the world is your oyster for… yeah, like Danny said, Discord, you could definitely do Discord to talk to your second brain as well. I have not set up my second brain with anything except for Slack, but I have set up Archon with Discord.
Cole Medin: and other platforms, and so it's similar for… because they both use the Cloud Asian SDK under the hood. So, certainly, you'll be able to do whatever you want.
Cole Medin: So when we create our PRD in a little bit here, that would just be one of the things that you specify. And actually, if I go into the template here.
Cole Medin: there is a place where you specify, like, exactly the integrations that you want, and, like, this is where you can say, like, I want to use Microsoft Teams in order to talk.
Cole Medin: like, for chat messaging, I want to use Discord, I want to use Teams, I want to use Slack, like, you can specify that, and then my skill is going to, like, automatically customize the PRD. So, like, that will be your remote entry point into the Cloud Agent SDK, or whatever SDK you're using. Again, you could use, like, Codex or OpenCode or something if you wanted to.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Okay, so…
Cole Medin: let's see, someone mentioned the master.env. So the master.env, that's something a bit more specific to me.
Cole Medin: That's, so he's talking about this master.env.example. This is, like, super specific to me.
Cole Medin: One of the things that maybe I shouldn't have included in… it's not like this, because this is just the .env.example.
Cole Medin: So, it's not like I have my secrets in here or anything, but this is, like, really specific to my setup.
Cole Medin: I don't think that it's worth covering this too much right now, because as you build out your own second brain, it'll let you know, like, okay, we need to set up these environment variables for Slack, and it can guide you through that, and then you'll build up your own environment variables over time.
Cole Medin: So, I don't necessarily need to, like, cover this whole thing.
Cole Medin: So yeah, definitely, like, with the template that I have for you guys, I probably went, like, a little overboard with what I'm including, where it's like, yeah, that's a little specific to Cole, like, I probably don't need to care about that part, and that's one of those things.
Cole Medin: So yeah, let me say, like, trust me guys, it was really, really hard to take my entire second brain
Cole Medin: And, take out all the parts that are, like, really awkwardly specific to me. Like, this is a good example where it's like.
Cole Medin: Cole, what the heck is this? Like, this is, like, awkwardly specific to me, with all of my different environment variables for things like circle, and… and I have, like… like, what… I have, like, some things prefixed with CE, that's short for Content Engine, and then I have some things that it's short for, or where is it?
Cole Medin: Where's my video processor?
Cole Medin: I don't know, I'm… see, I get lost in this myself sometimes.
Cole Medin: But, yeah, so don't worry about some of those, like, really specific things. And you can always, like, ask Claude Code to explain the setup workspace script. This is, like, another thing that's really specific to me. You can see that, like, I tried to make it general so it doesn't, like, call out just my username, but, like, you don't have this repository, right?
Cole Medin: So again, this whole repo is meant to be a reference for you, not something that you're gonna set up directly, and that's why we're gonna go through and create things from scratch with a PRD here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: David said, how can I share my brain on two computers? I have 5 on the network with tail scale, okay, 3 for me, 2 for my remote team members. Currently, my brain's on a Git repo, and there's a bit of a push-pull going on, but I want an improved system.
Cole Medin: Gotcha, yeah. So, I have two computers accessing my second brain, because I have it running locally, and then I also have it deployed to a VPS on DigitalOcean.
Cole Medin: And, I think for the most part, David, I will answer your question when I get to the whole VPS deployment and a vault sync.
Cole Medin: So I don't want to get, like, too deep into the question right now, because I think that, like, it'll just be much easier to explain things, like, as I'm actually building it.
Cole Medin: But, really, it's like, wherever you store your information, you just need to make sure that there's a sync process, or a way for, both computers or, like, multiple computers to not override each other.
Cole Medin: Otherwise, though, it's just gonna be the same as using Claude code across multiple devices. Like, they can work on the same repository, or the same Notion, or the same Obsidian, if you have Vault Sync set up.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so you just want to make sure that, like, wherever you're storing your memories and managing all that, like, you have some sort of real-time sync set up between your different devices, because you don't want them to feel like they're working in isolation. So, all of my memory files and daily logs and everything.
Cole Medin: I have that all, synced in Obsidian, so when I'm… when I, you know, tell my second brain, like, hey, I want you to remember this important thing about me.
Cole Medin: and it goes and updates the user.md. Within, I believe, 2 minutes is, like, the timer that I have, where it runs the get sync. Within 2 minutes, my user.md will be updated, you know, here locally as well.
Cole Medin: So… Yeah, oh, I got rid of the diagram on accident. Let me open that back up here.
Cole Medin: There we go.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so this is… this is my user.md.
Cole Medin: I'm not really, worried about, like, showing it here, because it doesn't have, like… this is, the business address for Dynamis, that's not my address. I don't live in Texas, you guys know that I live in Minnesota.
Cole Medin: But yeah, I'm just showing you, like, a little bit of what it looks like here. So, like, key points, like, or key projects, like, these are the things that I'm working on. Here's my, you know, current role within my business, right? Like, your user on MD, you can track whatever information you want to.
Cole Medin: very flexible for how you use these memory documents. So, definitely you can take inspiration from how I do it, or you can just, you know, tell in your PRD, like, I want it to remember these things, and these things, and ask me about these things.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Okay, so I'll answer a couple more questions here, and then we will get right into creating our PRD.
Cole Medin: So, Sunil said, I just joined Dynamis Community a few days back. Well, welcome to Dynamis, by the way. I'm planning my app with a localhost LLM model. Want to power off my computer every night and start back again. Is it possible to do that by remembering what was discussed before powering off?
Cole Medin: I did the same on ChatGBT, but at the end, it forgot lots of stuff.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so this is where conversation history comes in.
Cole Medin: So whenever you're talking to your agent through Cloud Code, or the Olama chat, or if you built your own, whatever it is, you want to, like, store the conversation somewhere. Like, Cloud Code is going to handle that for you, or if you're building your own agent, then you'll store the short-term memory in a database, so you can resume the conversation.
Cole Medin: So, Sunil, I don't know if this is, like, a second brain question exactly. It might be something that's better fit for our office hours that I have every single week.
Cole Medin: Because if you're using Claude Code, then you don't really have to worry about the conversation tracking yourself, because they store the messages in their own database. So it sounds like you're building something kind of different, like a separate AI agent. So I'd be happy to, like, answer more questions, or even, like, dive into that with you in next week's Office Hours. That's definitely what the Office Hours are for.
Cole Medin: Yeah.
Cole Medin: Alright, Jason said, which repo are you starting from? Can you share the link?
Cole Medin: Yeah, I'll put the link… well, actually, Brandon sent the right link, so yeah, thank you, Brandon.
Cole Medin: And then, Locke, what you shared, that's a… that's a good link as well, but that's for the public YouTube video that I put out. Now, it is, like, a very, very similar, Claude Second Brain PRD skill.
Cole Medin: And so, yeah, I'll just go to my browser here.
Cole Medin: So, within the link that Brandon sent, we have the Claude code second brain, and then within .clawed.
Cole Medin: skills, we have the Create Second Brain PRD. This is what I'm about to use right now, to build it from scratch.
Cole Medin: So, if you guys want to follow along with me, you can clone the repository, and then you can copy this Create Second Brain PRD skill, and you can bring it into a new folder that you create on your system.
Cole Medin: And, that is exactly what I have here. So, what you're looking at right here…
Cole Medin: This is where we're going to be working in for the rest of our workshop, when we build it from scratch.
Cole Medin: I have my .claw folder, and then within it, I have all of the commands from the Agentic coding course, because we're going to go through piv loops to build this in phases, and then I have the CreateSecondbrain PRD skill in the .clawed skills directory. So if you want to start from scratch like me.
Cole Medin: I'd recommend having exactly this setup as well.
Cole Medin: And, by the way, all of the commands are also here in the commands folder. So everything that you need to copy, and if you want to follow along exactly with me, that is all available in the link that Brandon sent, the Cloud Code Second Brain folder in our workshop repo here.
Cole Medin: All right.
Cole Medin: Cool. So, yeah, I'm gonna go ahead and continue here. Let's go ahead and create our PRD, and I'll keep getting to more questions as we have time, as we wait for Cloud Code.
Cole Medin: So, I'm here in a brand new session with Claude Code. If you have copied over the skill here.
Cole Medin: then what you want to do is open up the My Second Brain Requirements Markdown document, and just fill this out. This is your starting point to tell Cloud Code, or your whatever coding agent you're using, what customizations you want. How do you want the Second Brain to act? What integrations do you want? You can fill that out however.
Cole Medin: And so, just for the sake of brevity, because it's hard to, like, type things out and explain at the same time, I have actually already filled out a template that I'm going to use today.
Cole Medin: So, I'm going to fill this out, or I did fill this out, in exactly how I would have for my own second brain. So I'm gonna build, like, pretty much the same second brain I use for myself, same integrations, using Obsidian, but you can answer however you need to.
Cole Medin: So I'll just kind of, like, go through this quickly, and you guys can fill this out at the same time if you want, or if you just want to follow along with me, definitely feel free.
Cole Medin: So, I just gave some information about me. You can kind of just, like, specify whatever you want here. It's totally up to you. If you wanted to add more things, you could. So, my name, I'm the, you know, founder of Dynamis. What I do daily, I build agents and automations for AI coding and teach others how to do the same.
Cole Medin: That's a little bit of an elevator pitch for me. So, as far as, like, the vault folder name, let's just call this,
Cole Medin: Dynamis Workshop. Alright. I actually want to change that from the dry run that I did, because I want to make sure I don't have an overlap for my Obsidian vault.
Cole Medin: And then you can specify the platforms that you're using, so you can say, like, you know, X, I'm using email, and then I filled out and saying that I'm using Gmail specifically. So you could use Outlook, or maybe you're not using email at all, whatever it is. I'm using Google Calendar.
Cole Medin: Asana is where I do my task management. I'm sure a lot of you guys are using, like, Linear, or Jira, or something, or Notion instead.
Cole Medin: for my chat platform, this is where I'm using Slack, and so this is where, like, if you want to have a totally different setup than me, you can just specify these things here, and the PRD will automatically be custom when we run the skill command to actually create our PRD. So fill this out, then I'll show you what it looks like to run it.
Cole Medin: I'm gonna be using Obsidian to store my knowledge.
Cole Medin: Google Drive for my cloud storage, so whenever I need to, you know, like, create a script for a sponsor and, like, share it with them.
Cole Medin: or share something with a team member, then I'll create it in Google Drive instead of Obsidian, right? So I can, like, share it through a URL. Or if I have, like, a Google Form that I need to create for one of our mini hackathon submissions or something like that.
Cole Medin: And then I'm using GitHub for my code, my community is Circle, and then I don't actually use a CRM for anything. So I put that there because a lot of you probably would be, but you can also feel free to add any other kinds of platforms to this list if you'd want.
Cole Medin: And then just to start to give an overview for our second brain, for, like, what we want to
Cole Medin: what we want to actually do. I have a section here to list out, you know, 3 to 5 tasks that you'd want your second brain to handle proactively. Like, for me, I wanted to draft emails to help me manage my inbox. This alone saves me so much time every single week. It's crazy how busy my inbox gets.
Cole Medin: help me track deadlines, remind me of things before they're due, so I don't always have to be, like, super, super on top of my Asana, summarize what happened in Slack.
Cole Medin: monitor my community to, you know, what we guys have here at Dynamis to make sure there aren't any things that slip through. Because, like, as much as I am in Dynamis with you guys every single day, there are, once in a while, those posts where it's like, I thought I had replied, or, like, I looked at it at a bad time, so I moved on, or something, like, this will catch it for me. It's really, really nice.
Cole Medin: And then also helping me keep my meeting notes organized and searchable.
Cole Medin: So, the really important thing here is, like, for my second brain, and honestly, I probably should have said this, at the very beginning, is I am never using it to fully automate something that, like, you guys would ever see.
Cole Medin: Right? Like, I'm not using an AI avatar, I'm not posting AI slop on LinkedIn, I'm not doing any of that. It's not replacing me, but it's augmenting me. I use my second brain to research.
Cole Medin: organize and ideate. Those three things. So it's gonna help me with drafting emails, but I still send the email. It's gonna help me organize my meeting notes, but it's not attending the meetings for me. I'm not doing anything crazy like that. But it still saves me a lot of time just by helping me organize, ideate, and research.
Cole Medin: Alright, and then we have the proactivity level, so how bold you want your agent to be. This is pretty important, because some of you guys might want to start with it just kind of notifying you of things. Or what I like is the advisor level, so it drafts things for my review, but it's never going to, like, do something end-to-end that's going to be sent out to the world.
Cole Medin: Or, if you wanted to, you could go as far as the partner. You could create an agent, and, like, a lot of people do this with their open claw. You could certainly build this for yourself. A lot of people want it to, like, actually do something end-to-end, like fully send emails, or have an AI avatar, join meetings, or make cold calls, or whatever it is.
Cole Medin: You can build that if you want, so I wanted to put that in there because then you can customize the PRD for that specifically.
Cole Medin: And then security boundaries. Obviously, security is something very important that we'll cover a lot more at the end of the workshop as well. What do you want the agent to never do without explicit permission? So, you know, send emails on my behalf, post to social media, kind of going in line with proactivity level, but just being more explicit here, I think really helps with the PRD.
Cole Medin: And then the memory categories, what types of knowledge matters to you most?
Cole Medin: infrastructure, so, like, I'm running this on Windows, and then I'm going to also deploy it to a cloud server, and I'll show you what that looks like at the very end of the workshop here, deploying to DigitalOcean.
Cole Medin: And then, just integration priorities, just to help you… it'll kind of help create the phases of work in the PRD, so ranking the top 3 integrations, like, I care most about Gmail, Asana, and Slack to start, and then definitely all the other ones will come soon after.
Cole Medin: So, that is all you have to fill out here as your starting point. And again, that is just this file that I have, so within the link here, and I'll just link to this one more time.
Cole Medin: So within the… so I put that in the Zoom chat just now. So within the .klon.
Cole Medin: we have the skills directory, and you can just copy over the Create Second Brain PRD. Hopefully, for those of you following along, you've already done that, and you have the template filled out here.
Cole Medin: So, once you have your template filled out, now all you have to do
Cole Medin: is go into your terminal, and open up Claude Code, and you want to open up Claude Code in this directory, right? So it has access to the CreateSecondbrain PRD skill. So now I can do slash.
Cole Medin: create Second Brain PRD, and then you just have to give it a path to the template that you just filled out, the requirements.
Cole Medin: And so that is my cold second brain requirement, so I'll just copy the full path here, so I just right-click in VS Code, copy path, and then paste it in. So again, open up Cloud Code, where we have our skill, slash create second brain PRD, give it the path, and then we let it whirl.
Cole Medin: There we go. So it's not going to build anything right now, but it's going to create the full PRD. It's going to lay out all of the phases for us to build literally everything that I covered in the diagram here.
Cole Medin: And the best part about this is I have this whole, like, architecture reference document. You guys don't have to care about this, but I'm just showing you behind the scenes how it works a little bit. And this has, like, all of the core components, and even some of the gotchas and lessons that I had to learn along the way as I was building my own second brain.
Cole Medin: So this PRD, it has a lot of things built in that'll save you time, right? Like, I went through it the hard way, now I'm making it easier for you guys to build, because this PRD has the lessons built right in.
Cole Medin: And so when we have our coding agent go and build this phase by phase, it's going to know about those things that, you know, caused me a world of hurt before. So you guys get to go on the fast track here. That's the point of what I'm building for you guys here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, I'll keep knocking out some questions, while it builds the PRD here.
Cole Medin: Danny said, can you have more than one option in the platforms? 100%. Yep, this is flexible enough where you could say, like, I want to talk to it in Slack and Telegram, and it can certainly build that for you.
Cole Medin: Yeah, cool.
Cole Medin: And then, Sean, I saw that you had your hand raised, but just for workshops, I usually don't, like, have anyone come off mute, just to keep things chugging along nicely, so if you have a question, you can feel free to put it in the chat as well. I'll get to it for sure.
Cole Medin: Alright, so, question from Chris here, are we okay to work on a VPS today, or is local better?
Cole Medin: So, it's easier to build your second brain locally at first. You definitely can create it right away on a VPS. I'm not discouraging you from doing so, but it would probably be a bit easier for you to follow along and just, like, in general work on it if it's, you know, just something that's on your computer.
Cole Medin: Brandon said, can you share the links again for where we can download the latest skills? I'm in the workshop tree, but I'm unsure which one I should be downloading that is the most current and up-to-date.
Cole Medin: Yes, so, good question, Brandon. I'll go ahead and put a link to the skills in the Zoom chat again. Everything that we have here is up-to-date. This has my Excal Draw Diagram skill, my skill for, like, helping me ideate for LinkedIn posts, and creating PowerPoints and PDFs. All of this is up-to-date right now.
Cole Medin: And I do want to, like, actually manage these and, like, keep them up-to-date over time as I evolve them for you guys as well. And I think I will… I might do it here, or I might actually create a separate repository in the Dynamis community, so that it's not just within the workshops repo. I'm gonna figure out how I want to organize that to maintain it for y'all going forward, but I'd love for that to be a resource for everyone in the community.
Cole Medin: So that you guys can constantly evolve your second brain with me as well.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, Steve asked, what are the best practices for running multiple second brains on a hybrid of cloud and local models? So we just have two different obsidian vaults.
Cole Medin: Yeah, Steve, it really depends on if you want both second brains to access the same information, but if you're, you know.
Cole Medin: working, on a company, or for a company, or whatever, where there's multiple team members that all want to have their own second brains, I would recommend having separate Obsidian vaults. I think it makes sense to have complete isolation for each team member.
Cole Medin: Like, for me and my wife, we… I mean, I only have one vault, because she's just using the second brain basically as me.
Cole Medin: But yeah, if you want people to have their own instance, basically, I would keep it fully separate. Like, you can host all of them on one machine in the cloud, but, like, separate vaults would be good.
Cole Medin: Yeah.
Cole Medin: Carson said, can I pin the comment of the URL? You know, I don't think you can pin in Zoom, unfortunately.
Cole Medin: I'm looking at the options here, and I don't see it.
Cole Medin: Yeah, I wish I could. Just know, though, that I linked to it here in the description of the workshop, so I'll put this link in the Zoom chat as well, if you guys want to just have this popped up. It's always available for you guys to go here, and this is also where the recording is going to be posted after as well.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: And then, let me go back here, so we've still got some agents running. Sandeep said, can I type the command you used to create the PRD? Yep, so it is, slash create PRD.
Cole Medin: Oops, let me copy that. Slash create PRD, and then path to your template.
Cole Medin: That is the command that I used here. And, also, it does…
Cole Medin: show… it does say at the end of the template, it gives you the exact command, so after filling it out, you run slash create PRD path to this file, where you just filled out the template.
Cole Medin: And also, I did Ctrl-C, so I accidentally cut it off, so let me just tell it to continue here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, a question from Mike. Any thoughts on using the Anthropic Autodream concept to reconcile your MD? dedupe, organize, standardize, formatter, cross-linking?
Cole Medin: So, that is a really good question. So, Cloud Code has built something quite similar to my whole memory flush and daily reflection system, because they have auto-dream, where it, like, looks through your conversations over time, and then it dreams, as in, like, consolidates information down into a smaller file.
Cole Medin: Kind of like my memory.md. And the cool thing is, this is how humans actually work.
Cole Medin: Because humans, they process a ton of information throughout the day, and then your brain, while you're sleeping, this is one of the reasons sleep is so important, it takes this onslaught of information from your day while you're awake, and it stores the important stuff deeper into your brain, so that you can recall it later on more easily.
Cole Medin: And so that's why Claude Code calls it Dream.
Cole Medin: Now, Mike, to answer your question, I'm not really thinking about integrating it, because I feel like I've already built everything that Claude Code has with AutoDream. So when I show you guys building the memory layer, and how we have this, like, promotion process from the daily logs into the memory.md, and then we're always loading the memory.md into the agent, like, that has the exact same effect.
Cole Medin: maybe there are some cool things I can learn from AutoDream.
Cole Medin: like, the way that it organizes or standardizes, but anything that they do, we could build very easily into the whole daily reflection system that we have here. Like, if we want to, like, automatically do research based on things in the log, or like, you know, sort of, like, enhance the information, you could build all that so easily.
Cole Medin: Because one of the things that we'll talk about here as we're building is anytime you see room for improvement in your second brain, you don't have to spend a lot of time building that in. Like, you can just tell your second brain, like, hey, I noticed that you didn't do this very well.
Cole Medin: or I thought you were able to do this, but you're clearly not. Like, what can we do to make that happen? And it is just gonna be able to knock it out so easily, because
Cole Medin: In building our memory layer.
Cole Medin: like, as we are building on our second brain, it's going to remember how we've evolved it. Like, it builds such a good, like, meta understanding, as I call it. Like, it knows how it works, its own internal working, so well.
Cole Medin: that, you don't really have to do much context curation when you go into building an improvement. Like, it just can kind of immediately dive into the implementation.
Cole Medin: So, we're definitely gonna be using the piv loop.
Cole Medin: in order to build our second brain initially, like, I'll go through the priming process, and then planning, and then building, and validating, like, we'll go through that, but I will be honest, like, at this point with my second brain, whenever I want to build something new, I kind of just vibe code it.
Cole Medin: Like, I just say, like, hey, I want this new integration, or I want to talk in Telegram instead of Slack, and it can just knock it out so easily. I don't even have to…
Cole Medin: do very much planning, because the memory layer… and, you know, the whole dreaming process, it literally just takes care of that. It's really cool.
Cole Medin: And yes, Renata, so… so I know you… I'm kind of behind on questions, so I'm… this is a question Renata sent at 11.37 a.m. my time, but yes, that is the right URL. So, yeah, the Cloud code second brain within the workshops directory in Dynamis, yep.
Cole Medin: Bob asks, are you hosting the CouchDB locally, or just local storage?
Cole Medin: So, I'm just hosting everything locally as Markdown documents in Obsidian. I don't think I'm using CouchDB. I've heard that, like, Obsidian uses CouchDB under the hood, but, I mean, really all this is just…
Cole Medin: markdown documents stored on my computer in a folder, and then I am using SQLite for the RAG part that we'll talk about when we get to that part of the memory layer.
Cole Medin: And then, when I… I guess there's one caveat there. I have started to use Postgres, because I want my remote instance and my local instance to manage the same database, and using SQLite synced between two devices is a big pain.
Cole Medin: So, what we're gonna build today is using SQLite, but I have evolved it to using Postgres.
Cole Medin: so that I can have one database across different devices. So that is one caveat that's really important to mention, but it's very easy to transition from SQLite to Postgres. So again, it's just one of those things where it's like, when you're ready to take your second brain and move it to the cloud, or start having other devices access it.
Cole Medin: you can just one-shot that. Like, so many of these things just start to become one-shotable, and, like, that's what I want to give you permission to do right here, is, like, just start… just start one-shotting stuff once you have the foundation laid out.
Cole Medin: And I think that's actually a really good way to put it for our workshop here. Like, the 8 modules that we're gonna go through, and what we're gonna build here in our 4 hours right now, that's gonna be the foundation.
Cole Medin: Where the agent's not really ready to self-evolve yet. Like, we're still gonna be kind of hand-holding, going through piv loops here, but then after our workshop, like, if you follow along with what I have right now, after the workshop, you're gonna be able to start one-shotting things so quickly, because you're gonna have a standard for your skills.
Cole Medin: and the proactive nature, and you're gonna have a standard for your adapters and where you're talking to your agent, so it can reference itself to build on top. It's really, really cool.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Sean said, since you are using Obsidian, can you suggest how we can diverge and use Agentic rag, for example? What would a prompt look like?
Cole Medin: Sean, I think you might have to elaborate there what you mean by agentic rag.
Cole Medin: Can you suggest how we can diverge and use a gentic rag?
Cole Medin: So, one thing I will say here is I am already using Agentic Rag.
Cole Medin: Because hybrid search is an example of a Gentic Craig.
Cole Medin: So…
Cole Medin: And part of the reason I asked for elaboration is because agentic rag, it can mean a lot of different things. The general idea is that you're giving your AI agent, or in this case our second brain, the ability to search through knowledge in multiple different ways. So it can kind of figure out, like, what is ideal
Cole Medin: based on the user's question. So we have both semantic search and keyword search. That's agentic red, because it has two search strategies, and we can even use them together, because keyword search
Cole Medin: Works really well when you have, like, a very specific word or ID or phrase that you want to find across your memories and your daily logs. And then semantic similarity search is going to work better when
Cole Medin: we, are trying to, like, relate things conceptually in the question we have for our second brain. So, it's good to have both. That is agentic rag, and it's performing agentic rag over everything we have stored in
Cole Medin: our Obsidian Volt.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool, so let's go back to Claude here.
Cole Medin: And of course, I'll keep going through questions as I can.
Cole Medin: But we have our plan now. We have our PRD, it just created. So, 922 lines in total. It's gonna be pretty comprehensive, because this is outlining all phases that we have here. So, it says 9 phases, but that's because I'm going to do the last 2 in parallel. So, there really are 8 modules that I have, because I'm going to knock out the deployment and the
Cole Medin: security at the same time. So…
Cole Medin: If you just had it go with the default path, it's going to create your PRD in the .agent slash plans folder. So right here, this is where we have our full scope of work for our document. What we have right now, this is going to guide the entire implementation, the entire foundation.
Cole Medin: And then the sort of promise here is once you build everything here, that's when you're going to be able to just start one-shotting things in your second brain, like, add this integration, add this adapter, whatever it is.
Cole Medin: So we have our Phase 1, this is the memory layer here.
Cole Medin: Phase 2 is we're going to be adding in the hooks, and so, again, everything here is going to correspond directly to the sections that we have in the diagram here. And by the way, this diagram, as well as the other one for why we want to build our own second brain, these are also both available in the workshop folder here. So I got those diagrams available.
Cole Medin: So anyway, going back here, Phase 3 is going to be our memory searching, so this is where we're going to have our hybrid or agentic rag, if you will. And then, Phase 4 is going to be building in integrations, so adding in, like, Gmail and Asana and Slack, and you guys can customize this to be whatever you want.
Cole Medin: And then, let's see, Phase 5 is adding in skills.
Cole Medin: So that's gonna be a nice and quick one.
Cole Medin: Phase 6 is going to be, proactive systems, so this is where we add in our heartbeat and reflection, and the whole, dreaming, memory promotion process. It gets very exciting with Phase 6, because that's when the agent starts to do things autonomously.
Cole Medin: And then, phase 7 is gonna be the chat interface. So I'll be adding in Slack. This is where you would add in Teams or Discord or whatever you're doing. Maybe even multiple platforms, like someone asked about earlier.
Cole Medin: And then Phase 8 is our security hardening, and then we're gonna do that at the same time as our deployment here.
Cole Medin: So, alright, that is the plan. So we're gonna take this PRD, and we're just gonna shoot it off one phase at a time, going through piv loops. We're gonna be following the exact same process that we have with the Agentic coding course. Like, we're gonna build this just like I built the examples in the Agentic coding course.
Cole Medin: Also, Sean, I see… so this happened, but, I'm in the browser for Zoom, so I can't actually see the image, if you sent an image.
Cole Medin: So, sorry, I'm not sure what you're referring to. Sumit said same here, so I hope it's not, like, an issue you guys are dealing with.
Cole Medin: block script, can't… yeah, API keys and credentials must never enter the context window. Yep, so if you're using…
Cole Medin: If you're using my template, like, that is one of the protections I have for a pre-tool use, which is a good thing.
Cole Medin: Oh, wait. Oh, it wasn't actually able to read your PRD?
Cole Medin: The security hook blocked the write because the PRD contains literal patterns like cat.env.
Cole Medin: Oh, okay, I got you, Sumit. Yeah, okay, so guys, if you are trying to run the command to create the PRD,
Cole Medin: make sure you don't have the clawed hooks yet. You don't want to have those yet, because we'll build them as a part of phase number 2 anyway.
Cole Medin: So, you just want to take that out of where you're currently running the createPRD command. That's… that's why I was being specific here, like, you don't…
Cole Medin: necessarily want to, or I wouldn't recommend running it in the repo. Like, if you guys cloned my repository here with my template, even though, yes, I have the skill right here and you can run it right here, that's why I recommend copying it out to a new folder, like I did for our example here, because that way, you really are starting from a blank slate.
Cole Medin: Because yeah, you guys ran into one of the very important hooks that I have for the second brain. We force Cloud code to not read from a .env, because we never want our API keys to go into the context window of the LLM. That's one of the big no-no's with OpenClaw, where they really suffer from that.
Cole Medin: So I have a hook to enforce that, but it just makes it kind of inconvenient when sometimes it, like, blocks something that you don't want it to, but it's just a… it's a give and take, right? Like, it's one of the things we have to put up with, because we want it to be secure.
Cole Medin: Jason, you can have the other skills if you want, you could bring those in right away, but we're also going to do that as a part of Phase 5, so we'll bring them in when it comes time to, like, integrate that with the rest of our second brain.
Cole Medin: Renata, the .agent folder is created automatically.
Cole Medin: So, when you… whenever you run… if you fill out the template for the PRD, and then you run slash create secondbrain PRD, it makes this automatically, because that's the default place it puts the PRD.
Cole Medin: So if you go through this process… this whole process, it'll be there automatically.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool.
Cole Medin: So, Dom, credentials will come, throughout the phases.
Cole Medin: So, like, the first time we'll deal with credentials will be Phase 4, when we do our direct integrations.
Cole Medin: Alright, and then, Danny asks, can I please share all of my Obsidian plugins? Yes, I'd love to. So, let me go to that really quick. So, settings, plugins… there's not too many that I use, because I actually like to keep it quite simple.
Cole Medin: These are… so, okay, actually, quite a few of these I don't even use. The main one that I use is the Excalodraw. Like, actually, I really don't use any of the other ones. The Excalodraw Obsidian plugin is the only one I'm really using. I've experimented with a couple of other ones. I guess Iconize is really good as well.
Cole Medin: Because that gives me the nice icons here, like, more than what you can do by default in Obsidian. So I guess those are the main two that I'm using, these two. But otherwise, I've tried experimenting with other ones, and like, they just aren't that necessary for the way that I work.
Cole Medin: A lot of them, like the, Commander and Quick Add and Tasks, like.
Cole Medin: my second brain is managing so much for me, and Obsidian is just where, like, I'm storing and connecting info that I just, like, don't need the UI to be very verbose for me, or very robust, if you will.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, those are the two that I use.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool.
Cole Medin: So, without further ado, let's get into building the first phase, and I'll really start to have more time for questions as we do that. So, I know we've gone pretty far in the workshop here, but it's important for me to, like, really set the stage for everything for you guys before we build.
Cole Medin: Because now, at this point, we're gonna get into building it from scratch, but you guys already have an understanding of, like, why do we care about building this ourself?
Cole Medin: What are the different components that we're building? What does it actually look like?
Cole Medin: And so, we're gonna be able to move pretty quickly here, and then, you know, answer questions as they come up, but we've got the core down of, like, what we're actually doing here. What's the purpose of our brain? Let's get the PRD created. Let's understand how the different components work together. So now that we have all that, we're just gonna start building.
Cole Medin: So, what I'm gonna do here is I'm going to open up a brand new Cloud Code instance.
Cole Medin: And I'm gonna start with my classic piv loop.
Cole Medin: And if you guys have gone through the Agenta coding course.
Cole Medin: You know that I always begin my planning sessions with the prime command.
Cole Medin: Not that there is much context to gather right now.
Cole Medin: But it will at least know to read the PRD here, and it'll recognize that we've just started, we're gonna be on phase one, let's build out the memory layer for our second brain.
Cole Medin: And then once we actually have things built out in future phases, it'll be good for our agent to explore what we already have built right now, and get a sense of what our codebase looks like before we plan the next phase.
Cole Medin: Alright, so it'll just take a little bit of time to prime, and then we'll get into the planning here. So I'll answer another question.
Cole Medin: So Raphael said, how do you decide when to use Claude code and when to use the, Claude's second brain? Or is it just always just a skill in Claude code?
Cole Medin: So, Raphael, for pretty much everything that I'm doing, I'm just using my second brain. I think what you're asking here is, like, when do I, you know, use my second brain to perform work, versus when do I just, like, open up Claude code in my codebase?
Cole Medin: I just use my second brain all the time.
Cole Medin: Because I also have the Archon skill built right in, so it can invoke my Archon workflows to handle GitHub issues, or review pull requests, or whatever I needed to do.
Cole Medin: So, it can get to the point with your second brain where it's just, like, you're only ever opening up your Cloud Code CLI in your second brain, so it's loading in all your contacts, and you're just pointing it at other repos that you want to work on.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool, so our prime finished here, and it understands that at this point, we haven't really built anything, but these are the phases that are outlined in our PRD.
Cole Medin: And so, generally, right after the priming, when I get into the planning process for a phase, I go into my speech-to-text tool. I'm just using Aquavoice here. I love Aquavoice. There are a lot of other good options, like WhisperFlow or Epicenter Whispering, but I recommend using some kind of speech-to-text tool. Makes it so much easier, especially during the brainstorming part of the planning session. So I go in and I say.
Cole Medin: Alright, fantastic. So we're gonna go ahead and start with phase number one here. So I want you to do a little bit of research and, help me plan out what we should be building for phase number one. Give me some ideas here.
Cole Medin: And then another thing that I recommend doing, I probably won't do it here, because it's only Phase 1, but it's good to have Claude Code ask you questions. The number one
Cole Medin: thing that you want to be doing in planning is you want to reduce the number of assumptions that your coding agent is making. So if you have it asked you questions, you guys are really getting aligned on even the nitty-gritty details, that is really important up front.
Cole Medin: And, so I'll show that more in future phases. Right now, I'm going to start really simple, because Phase 1 is very, very basic. So you can see it even says here that the complexity for Phase 1 is low, and then for getting into, like, hooks and memory search and integrations, it's medium.
Cole Medin: And then, towards the end here, that's where we're gonna get into the more complicated stuff. Definitely Phases 6 and 7,
Cole Medin: are the most complicated. But we're still going to be able to basically one-shot everything here, because, like I said, I put a lot of effort into how I split everything out into phases, and the context that I'm giving through the PRD. Like, this PRD is such a good starting point.
Cole Medin: So, alright, we'll let it do some exploration here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Jeffrey asked, what command did I use to prime? Yeah, I simply used the slash prime command.
Cole Medin: So, within the .cloud commands folder, I have the prime command right here.
Cole Medin: I just took all of these directly from the Agentic coding course, and so I'll show this one more time. In our main repository for today, I have all of these commands right here in the dot clause. You can copy these over, along with all the skills for the second brain.
Cole Medin: Not that we're gonna need the piv loop commands and everything, like, once you have the foundation of your second brain, like I said, but, like, when we're building it at first, it's definitely useful, like I'm showing right here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool. So, looks like the sub-agents are almost done here. Or, actually, they did finish, so now Claude Code is just reasoning. Okay, there we go, now we got the final answer.
Cole Medin: So, alright. Phase 1 is the foundation. This is what we're building here. So, we're going to set up the initial vault structure. So, this is where we're going to create our soul.md and user.md, all of the core Markdown documents that drive our second brain. This is what we're building in phase number one.
Cole Medin: And, we're also creating a claw.md. So, generally, for my second brain, and this is, of course, very, very flexible, but usually for my second brain, my claw.md is where I describe the technical details. Like, here are the commands that you need to be able to run for memory searching, things like that. So, again, it's soul.md describes the behavior of our agent.
Cole Medin: User.md is our profile. Memory.md is, like, core memories about, things we're working on, or decisions that we've made.
Cole Medin: And then the claw.md is the technical details. Like, here's how we work with our integrations or our memory searching.
Cole Medin: And then we also have the bootstrap.md. So this is another idea that I took directly from OpenClaw. When you first have a conversation with your agent, it's going to guide us through a conversation of just getting details about us, so it can start to fill out these files. So we'll see that after we implement the first phase as well.
Cole Medin: And so it has a couple of questions for me. Again, questions are very important to make sure we're aligned on everything. So I'm going to go into my speech-to-text tool and just start answering them.
Cole Medin: So, a vault route, Dynamis Workshop as the Obsidian Vault, or a different name. Yes, Dynamis-workshop is the correct vault route.
Cole Medin: Link styles, yeah, WikiLinks is good, I think that works well.
Cole Medin: Yeah, for the Soul.md, feel free to draft
Cole Medin: the agent personality, but also the bootstrap markdown should specify the questions we need to ask here, at least to add on to what we have specified in the PRD.
Cole Medin: And then, for question 4, nope, I think what we have here is great.
Cole Medin: Alright, so I'll send that in, and I'll just say, just acknowledge.
Cole Medin: Because, right after this, I'm going to run the next command. I'm going to run the plan feature command, like I've covered in the Agentic coding course. So, alright, summarize, looks like we're on the same page. For the sake of brevity, I'm going to move right into creating the structured plan.
Cole Medin: But if you guys really want to take your time with this, which I would recommend going a little bit slower than I am as you continue to build it out. But, like, right now, as we create the foundation, and because I'm just demoing it here, I'm gonna go kind of quickly here, but I'm gonna go right into creating our structure plan. So I'll say, alright, this is great, let's go ahead and create the plan for Phase 1.
Cole Medin: All right. I mean, you can kind of just specify whatever we want here, or not even say anything at all, because it knows to just use our short-term memory to guide creating the structure plan. That's the part of the command that we have here.
Cole Medin: Alright, so we'll let it go.
Cole Medin: And this is gonna take a little bit, so more time for Q&A.
Cole Medin: Alright, Sean asked, can user.md contain multiple users? Example, my wife and I. Does that make sense?
Cole Medin: Yes, Sean, it definitely can. The important thing to keep in mind, though, is if you want your second brain to be able to delineate who's actually talking to it, you would need some kind of way to make that distinguishment. Like, if your wife
Cole Medin: is talking to it in Slack, it would need to know that, like, okay, this Slack user ID talking to me right now is Sean's wife.
Cole Medin: So I should care more about, like, the part of the user.md that's for her. Or if it's Sean talking, then let's make sure that we're using his information in the user.md.
Cole Medin: So, it's up to you if you'd want to, like, separate it into, two user.md files, or just have it be, like, one file it reads, but it's delineated in the prompting.
Cole Medin: Either would work.
Cole Medin: Drago said, will the recording be available? I missed the first 2 hours today, a bank holiday in the UK.
Cole Medin: Yes, yep, so the recording will be available, and it'll be posted, like, later today, probably
Cole Medin: probably, like, within, like, 8 hours after, because Zoom has to process the whole thing, but yeah, it'll be available. And, yeah, so it is actually… it's a stock market holiday today in the US, I guess bank holiday in the UK. I didn't… I kind of, like, forgot about that when I scheduled this, even though I do celebrate Black Friday myself, so…
Cole Medin: Or, sorry, not Black Friday. Goodness, Good Friday. Wow, I just said Black Friday. It is not November, guys.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so for those of you who do celebrate, happy, happy Good Friday. Well, I can't believe I called it Black Friday.
Cole Medin: Oh, man, alright.
Cole Medin: So next question here from Josh.
Cole Medin: What are the pros and cons of combining the agent memory with the direct integration? I have a memory set up right now with Obsidian and Supabase, and I'm going to use this to build out my integrations and skills.
Cole Medin: Alright, let me read that last part again. I have a memory set up right now with Obsidian and Supabase, but I'm going to be using this to build out the integrations and skills.
Cole Medin: So, it's not really an either-or.
Cole Medin: Like, your direct integrations are the arms of the agent. It's how it's able to access things in your life, right? Like, it's able to see emails coming in, or see tasks in your task list.
Cole Medin: That's separate from the memories, though. The memories are more fundamental. It's more like understanding decisions that you've made, or things that you're currently working on. I mean, I guess there's a little bit of overlap there, where, like, remembering what you're working on could be in the memories or in your task list, but I would say that, like.
Cole Medin: your integrations are more ephemeral, right? Like, it's more like, here's what's happening right now. In the memory, that's what's, like, building up over time.
Cole Medin: so I wouldn't… like, I know you asked, like, pros and cons. I would say that,
Cole Medin: that it's… there's not, like, a either-or that you have to wrestle with there, if that makes sense. You can feel free to elaborate on your question as well, I hope that helps.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool. I think that Jesus guy is pretty forgiving, so no worries, right? Yep. I appreciate it, Mike.
Cole Medin: Oh, man, alright. So, yeah, next question here.
Cole Medin: Karsten said, regarding the heartbeat, How have you defined what's valuable or important for you to require immediate attention?
Cole Medin: Yes, that is a very good question. So, I'll give you a shorter answer right now, because that's one of the big things we'll cover when we get to Phase 6. But the thing that I… that it comes down to is, at first, it's not going to be perfect.
Cole Medin: You're going to describe at a high level, here's what's important to me, these kinds of emails, or these kinds of posts, in whatever forum, right?
Cole Medin: And that might not be the best prompting at first, and it might miss important things. But the important part is you catch that, and you say, like, hey, you reply… you drafted a reply to this email when I didn't even want you to waste tokens doing it. Like, this isn't the thing I care about. Or you missed this email, and I had to draft it, or I had to create the reply myself from scratch.
Cole Medin: And then you ask it to figure out, what do we change in the prompting so that you get that better next time? It's the same system evolution mindset that I cover in the Ajenta Coding course. It 100% applies to evolving the second brain as well.
Cole Medin: And so you just have to have the fair expectation that things are not going to be perfect. It's not going to have the best email drafts. It's not going to draft all the right emails at first.
Cole Medin: But you improve that over time.
Cole Medin: And there's flexibility there, because we're not trusting the agent to actually send the prompt, or, like, send the email.
Cole Medin: But it's just drafting it. So if it…
Cole Medin: if it doesn't decide to draft an email when you want it to, it's unfortunate because it saves you a little bit less time, right? Because that draft's not there, but it's not like it did something malicious, like send an email saying, like, oh yeah, I'll attend that meeting, even though you weren't planning on it, right? Like, that's why we have those protections in place, and so it gives you the flexibility to
Cole Medin: You know, have those mistakes happen at first, then you improve it over time, and then as you improve your agent and you trust it more and more, that's when you can give it more permission as well.
Cole Medin: And, yep, that's right, Fred, thank you. So, Mike, yeah, there's nothing that I run in between prime and plan. Generally, what you do in between priming and planning is you simply have a conversation with the coding agent for what you want to build. Once you're on the same page in that planning process, that is when you run the slash plan feature command.
Cole Medin: to, create that structure plan. That's what it's in the middle of writing out right now, so we're just waiting for that document to be done. Yep.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool. So, Renanda said, what if you have multiple emails? Can it go through and organize which email and all that is in there?
Cole Medin: 100%, yeah. I mean, I obviously haven't built that for myself, because I just had the whole system running on one email, but if you wanted to give information on multiple emails and have the heartbeat, like, actually check both of them and distinguish between them.
Cole Medin: you can certainly build that in. That could be one of the things that you would, you know, add into your PRD. Like, you would save for the whole,
Cole Medin: or, sorry, not the PRD, but, well, I mean, yes, the PRD, but, like, in your template here, you'd specify, like, I have…
Cole Medin: I have two Gmail accounts, actually, right? And then you can start creating the PRD around that.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Alright, there we go. So, now our plan is created.
Cole Medin: So, Phase 1 Foundation. I always recommend reviewing these plans. I want to make sure that our workshop doesn't go long, though, so I'm going to go pretty quick through these, but generally, I do like reading through these line by line, or at least skimming them with a good amount of thought behind it here.
Cole Medin: So it's gonna create all of our core memory files.
Cole Medin: Here's relevant documentation to reference. This is the core structure that I always have for my plans, like I teach in the course.
Cole Medin: This is the Obsidian vault that we're going to create here.
Cole Medin: And this is everything it's going to build.
Cole Medin: And, so task-by-task breakdown, and then we also have the validation here, so making sure that everything looks good. There's not too much to validate at this point, but there is going to be the manual validation where after this phase is implemented, I'll actually create the Obsidian Vault, so we'll do that live together as well. We're gonna set up the entire thing together here. I'm not… I'm not skipping anything. Maybe just going a little bit fast through the review.
Cole Medin: For the sake of brevity here.
Cole Medin: So, as I always recommend, it is very important to start your implementation in a different Cloud Code session.
Cole Medin: Because we run the execute command.
Cole Medin: We give the path to our plan.
Cole Medin: And this plan has all of the context that our coding agent needs to get the job done. We don't need to prime again, we don't need to do web research again, we already did all that during the planning process, we synthesized everything into this single document. Now, this is all we need to send in, because this lays out what needs to be done, the task list, the validation strategy, the success criteria, everything.
Cole Medin: Plan is clear. 10 tasks appear file directory creation.
Cole Medin: yeah, we know that this first part is going to be really basic here, so we'll rip through it quick, we will create our obsidian vaults, and then we'll already be done with phase number one, because I wanted to, like I said, break it up into really nice and manageable sections here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Rasmus said, only me building this with 5 sessions, 2 implementing, 3 reviewing. Yeah, you know, Rasmus, I could… I could rip through it really fast.
Cole Medin: like that, and that's cool that you are, but I don't think that would make for an easy-to-follow workshop, unfortunately. And I also specifically want to do everything sequentially, just so it's easy to break things up for the modules for the course after.
Cole Medin: But certainly, if you guys are power users, like Rasmus, you could do a lot of these things in parallel.
Cole Medin: So, going back to our diagram here.
Cole Medin: like, you could build the direct integrations at the same time you build the memory layer, and you could even build the hooks at the same time. Like, a lot of these things are pretty isolated from each other, because I purposely have them as quite distinct sections, so you certainly could do a lot of them at the same time.
Cole Medin: And, honestly, I… well, depending on, you know, where we're at with time when we get towards the end here, I might build some of these things in parallel. Like, I might do the heartbeat and the chat interface at the same time.
Cole Medin: in separate Cloud Code sessions, obviously, because they're both more complicated features, but yeah, I definitely have that option, just if I want to, like, prioritize your guys' questions, and make sure that we're still building everything in time that we need.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: When will the new course be released? So, I'm gonna take this workshop and make sure I put a lot of effort into editing it nicely and splitting it out, so I'm not sure exactly how long that'll take. I've never done something like that, where I've taken a live session and I've been, like, super intentional about, like, taking chunks of it for a course.
Cole Medin: Might end up being really hard. It actually probably will be a pretty hard thing. I'll use my second brain as much as possible to help me, like, call out the times to split, so I'd hope to do it within the next week.
Cole Medin: Brandon said, I'm still waiting on the PRD to generate. Oh, wow. Well, hopefully you'll be able to catch up, because I will spend time for questions, even after things are done executing. That's… that's interesting, though. I'm surprised it would take that long.
Cole Medin: I'll need 5 parallel sessions to create the course. Yeah, right. I mean, yeah, maybe I'll have them all going, parsing different sections of the course.
Cole Medin: Yeah, 12 minutes is a while to create the PRD. You must have, added a lot of customizations, Brandon. Or maybe Claude is, like, stuck or something? That's kind of strange. I don't know, it wasn't that long for me, I don't think.
Cole Medin: Interesting.
Cole Medin: Alright. Cool, so… Here we go.
Cole Medin: it completed our phase number one, and at this point, it's really just gonna be a bunch of Markdown documents. So we have the Dynamis workshop folder, and within it, we have
Cole Medin: Take a look at this. We've got our memory, so a bunch of folders that are empty for now. Well, I'll explain more of these as we build it out, because I have, like, a whole draft system where, one thing that I didn't even explain to you guys that's very cool.
Cole Medin: is it keeps track of all of my sent emails and, like, replies to you guys in the community. So it builds an understanding over time of how I actually communicate and handle certain emails and situations. And so not only does it create drafts for me.
Cole Medin: But it keeps track of what I actually sent, and it'll compare the draft to what I sent, and it'll, automatically extract lessons from that.
Cole Medin: So it's another really cool thing we'll get into when we do our integration with Gmail and the memory reflection system.
Cole Medin: We have our bootstrap.md, so the first time I talk to the agent and it does the onboarding, it's going to, go through these questions with me.
Cole Medin: And then we have the habits. These are, like, the daily pillars that I want to keep me accountable for. So this is a bit more specific to me. You guys might not necessarily need the habits part of the second brain, but I love this part for myself.
Cole Medin: We have the heartbeat. We'll obviously cover this in a later phase, but, like, here are the things that we wanted to monitor. These are all more like templates, like a starting point that we'll build out throughout the phases.
Cole Medin: We have our memory.md, which is very short right now, but we're gonna build this up over time. This starts to get quite long as you are using your second brain day in and day out, but it's cool that we even have, like, some key decisions that we made here already, so we get a little bit of an idea of what this looks like. We have our soul.md.
Cole Medin: So, I am Cole's AI second brain. I operate as an advisor, right, because that's the role level that we picked when we filled out the template. I draft, suggest, and organize, and remind, but I never send, post, or take irreversible actions without explicit approval.
Cole Medin: And the soul.md is where you guys can really customize the behavior of your agent. You can have it use a different language, you can have it use slang, you can have it actually send posts instead of just drafting. Exactly how you want it to act. This is the main file, because when we get into the next phase with hooks, we're gonna make it so this is one of the files that is loaded into the context of Claude Code and the Cloud Agent SDK every single time.
Cole Medin: As well as the user, .md.
Cole Medin: This has all of my core information, with a lot of things still being TBD, because this is what we're going to populate during our first onboarding with the bootstrap. This is how OpenClaw works as well.
Cole Medin: And so, let's actually… let's actually do this here. So, Jeffrey said he's lost. I'm sorry to hear that. I'm just kind of trying to go through the different documents here. I know there's quite a bit to digest with the initial structure, but just, the easy way to think about it is we have the core memories we build over time.
Cole Medin: Sold.md is, like, here's how we describe the behavior of our agent.
Cole Medin: And then this is our user profile. Those are the biggest files for you to understand right now. This is the core of our system.
Cole Medin: So, if you guys need me to slow down a little bit to explain things, like, feel free, let me know. I hope that makes sense, though. Basically, every part of our system is, in core, just a markdown document.
Cole Medin: And so, we can also create a new Obsidian vault here. So I'm going to open up Obsidian, and I want to connect it to this folder right here.
Cole Medin: So, I'm going to, open a folder as a vault, so I'll click Open.
Cole Medin: And then the path to this right here, I gotta actually go to this, it is…
Cole Medin: Second Brain Workshop. So, select this folder.
Cole Medin: Whoops, that is the wrong folder.
Cole Medin: Oh, man, I didn't mean to do that, because I need to click… I need to actually go into Dynamus Workshop. So, let me remove from the list…
Cole Medin: And then delete the dot obsidian here.
Cole Medin: So, you need to go into the folder that it created specifically that has the memory folder in it. So, open folder as Vault.
Cole Medin: Then click Dynamis Workshop, or at least that's what it's called for me, it's probably called something different for you. There we go. Now we have it opened up. So here's our Obsidian, we can go into the settings and customize things as well. I usually don't like the light theme.
Cole Medin: So I'll go into the appearance here. For the themes, let's do, I don't know, Obsidianite looks really cool, so we'll install and use this theme.
Cole Medin: And then for the base color scheme, we'll do dark. Okay, that looks way better, cool. Alright, so here is our initial Obsidian Vault, and we already have our memory system started in here, so I'll zoom in a little bit so it's easy to see this.
Cole Medin: So we can open up all of our documents in Obsidian, everything's really organized well, so it knows how to format things at the front matter for Obsidian, like we're seeing
Cole Medin: right here.
Cole Medin: Very, very cool. So, not much in this right now, like, we don't have any daily logs or anything, but this is our starting point. So, phase one is all about just getting the initial infrastructure set up for our memory system, and we're connecting it to Obsidian as well.
Cole Medin: And so, now, really, the last thing that I can do for Phase 1, and then I think we're kind of at, like, the halfway point for the entire workshop, so we'll take, like, a 10-minute break here. But the last thing that I want to show right now is I want to show what it looks like to have that initial conversation where we do the bootstrapping.
Cole Medin: So I'm going to start Claude Code.
Cole Medin: The important thing to keep in mind here is that the sole user and memory.md are core files. They're not loaded into Cloud Code automatically yet, because that comes in the next phase with hooks.
Cole Medin: But we do have the clod.md. This is loaded in automatically, so it understands that it is the second brain, and it has some general information. So we have this just as, like, the highest level index of our second brain.
Cole Medin: And so what I can say now is, walk me through the bootstrap.
Cole Medin: And this is the… we only have to do this once, just when we start for the first time, because this is where it's going to fill out some of those things, like in the user.md, that are left as TBD right now. So we'll try to go through these things really quickly.
Cole Medin: Can I…
Cole Medin: Can you show the Obsidian part again? Yeah, yeah, of course. So, all I did here is I opened up Obsidian for the first time, and I clicked open folder as Vault. So we can bring an existing folder that already has content as an Obsidian Vault.
Cole Medin: And then I simply selected the folder that it created for me in Phase 1. This is the folder that has the memory folder within it, right? So, like, whatever name you specified for your vault when you created the PRD, you select this folder.
Cole Medin: And then it opens it up here as a brand new Obsidian Volt. Then you just go into the settings in the bottom left, and this is where you can customize everything. Like, I added a custom theme here called Obsidian Night. I mean, you could just use a default if you want, but I'm just showing you how to make it look nice, because I don't want to deal with a light theme.
Cole Medin: And then I just changed the base color scheme to dark. That's all I did to set up things initially. And you can, of course, feel free to add in your own plugins and things, like, if you wanted to…
Cole Medin: And by the way, if you don't have Obsidian installed, but you're interested in using it after seeing it here, it is very, very easy to install Obsidian. You just go to… their website is obsidian.md.
Cole Medin: So I put a link to it in the chat right here. And it's free and open source, runs 100% locally. Actually, sorry, I don't think it's open source, but it's free and runs locally as a desktop application. Everything is 100% private, unless you enable their cloud sync, but that isn't on by default.
Cole Medin: So, very private application, that's why a lot of people love using it.
Cole Medin: And then there's plugins to extend it as well. So they have core plugins that you can toggle on and off, and then also community plugins. So I can turn this on, and then I can browse, and then, for example, I can bring in the Excalodraw plugin.
Cole Medin: So I have this one installed in my other Obsidian vault, but you actually install the community plugins at a vault level. So, like, vault by vault, I can change the plugins that I have included. So, it's very easy to… you just click install, and then click Enable, and now I have support for Excalodra diagrams directly in my Obsidian vault.
Cole Medin: So it's pretty cool.
Cole Medin: Alright, so, yeah, let's go back to our bootstrapping here.
Cole Medin: Alright, so here's what phase one bootstrapped, no, I meant go through the bootstrap.
Cole Medin: MD process. So, I didn't realize what I was referring to here, but that's because we don't have the user.md and things loaded in yet. So, maybe I should have done this process after Phase 2, so it actually, like, knew to go to bootstrap.md right away.
Cole Medin: So, but anyway, now… now it knows. Alright, let's do this. So, hi, I'm your second brain. Let's… let me get to know you so I can be the most helpful.
Cole Medin: So, you know what I'm gonna do here is I'm actually gonna say, just ask all the questions at once. I want to be kind of fast here. The bootstrap.md is set up to be more of, like, a full conversation.
Cole Medin: Which is nice, like, it feels really nice, but the thing is, if I want to go a little bit faster, just to wrap up phase one, I do want to go pretty quickly. So, here's everything I need to fill out your profile.
Cole Medin: Alright, so I'll just give, like, quick answers to everything.
Cole Medin: So what are your top 2-3 active projects or focus areas right now? I'm working on Archon and workshops for the Dynamis community. Who are key people you collaborate with regularly? You know, let's just say I'm collaborating with everyone in the Dynamis community.
Cole Medin: Yes, I create content on YouTube and LinkedIn, primarily. Brief response length, brief, medium, or detailed. Let's just go with medium. Casual tone, yeah, we can use emojis, but not too much.
Cole Medin: Any pet peeves with AI assistance that I should know about? That is a good question.
Cole Medin: My biggest pet peeve with coding agents is when they produce text that is way too obvious, that is generated by an LLM.
Cole Medin: like, really punchy staccato with a ton of periods. I really don't like it when AI agents are psychophantic. I don't want them to always agree with me. I want them to be willing to push back, so I want my second brain to be willing to push back.
Cole Medin: Typical working hours is, generally a 6am to 4pm Central Time.
Cole Medin: When should I stay quiet? Let's do no notifications after 9pm. When somebody needs my attention, you should flag it through Slack. What counts as urgent to you? Definitely, like, things that are well overdue, or that need a reply within the day.
Cole Medin: Integrations, what are the order for the rest? We'll just kind of do that all at once in a phase here, and you can see that from the PRD. Any specific Gmail labels, Asana projects, or Slack channels I should prioritize? Yes, actually. So…
Cole Medin: Let's see here, I gotta actually pull this up on my other monitor here.
Cole Medin: But I'm gonna give you my full, Asana URL that has my to-do project. I actually want you to use that specifically.
Cole Medin: And then, let's see… I also have a Slack channel.
Cole Medin: I'll give you the link to that as well. So I'm just kind of dumping my links here so that you have, like, the right IDs for things up front, because that's where I work. Like, that's the Slack channel I use, that's my Asana… my primary Asana task list.
Cole Medin: Alright, the Habits.md has 5 daily pillars. Build, teach, connect, health, and learn. Do these resonate, or would you tweak them? Actually, let's tweak them. And so, for those of you guys who are watching this with me right now, this…
Cole Medin: I'm just gonna say really quick, like, these are the 5 habits that I legitimately track myself every single day. It's a little bit personal, I'm just sharing, like, exactly my 5 habits, but my 5 habits are, I want to do something to improve Archon.
Cole Medin: My second brain itself, the Dynamis community.
Cole Medin: My relationship with God, and my marriage. Every single day, I've… it's a successful day if I have improved all 5 of those things.
Cole Medin: And then the last question here, any personal goals or habits you're currently tracking? I kind of already answered that. So yeah, there we go. That's my answer to everything. All right, so again, always recommend using speech-to-text tools to just give that brain dump there. And so, this is really helpful. I know you have to, like, kind of take your time at first.
Cole Medin: To really get through setting up your initial memory layer, and, like, going through the bootstrap process.
Cole Medin: But this… this is what it takes, at least up front, to really make your agent personal to you. Like, I'm already getting into the very specific things here, because now it's going to be building up the user, soul, and memory.md in ways that are already going to be helpful to me.
Cole Medin: not that we're gonna save ourselves a ton of time yet, but we're getting there. We're building up the foundation, and then as we get to the other phases, it'll come together very quickly here. So, we're going to… we're gonna start to, like, get through things pretty fast. I know that we're… we're halfway through the workshop, and it's phase one, but a lot of it is just setting the groundwork up front, so we'll get through things
Cole Medin: pretty quickly here. And maybe even doing a couple of things in parallel. We'll figure out what we need to do here.
Cole Medin: But there we go, so we're already getting the very specifics down.
Cole Medin: Cool.
Cole Medin: Updating all of our core files. And then, of course, we can go into our Obsidian vault here, and we can see these things if we want to view it ourself. I always like to say that, like.
Cole Medin: whenever my second brain is producing documents for me or working with me, Obsidian is my canvas, right? Like, it's my way to view things and edit things in a much better way, because we have rich Markdown formatting and the plugins we can bring in for Excaladraw, and we can render PDFs that it creates for us, and things like that. I'm creating PDFs, actually, quite a bit with my second brain, so it's nice to, like, view those
Cole Medin: And even, like, images as it generates thumbnails for me, I can just do that all right in Obsidian, so I'm not managing things through, like, clicking around in folders on my file explorer.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: I appreciate it, Ralph.
Cole Medin: Kaushik Marriage said marriage should be the first one. I agree. Yep, that is not in priority order. I'm just kind of listing them off, but 100%, like, certain ones, like marriage, would, take precedence over others.
Cole Medin: Yup.
Cole Medin: Alright, Justin said, if we have an existing second brain that we want to leverage, what I've learned about how yours is set up, should I go through setting up a new one from scratch, and then point it to existing, or do you think that I should just do the PRD, then hand that to my existing, and say, add what's missing from this PRD?
Cole Medin: Justin, I would do the latter. I would work with what you have existing, and then you can either, create the PRD,
Cole Medin: like I showed in the workshop here, and then point your agent to it, or you can just point your agent directly to the codebase here that I have shared with everyone. So this entire Claude Code Second Brain codebase.
Cole Medin: I'll just, you know, link to that in the Zoom chat again. You can just point it there and say, like, you know, take a deep dive into this. What are some, like, really cool features from Cole's Second Brain that maybe I could include that we don't have already?
Cole Medin: So you can have it spin up sub-agents to, you know, explore both your second brain codebase and mine, and just see what differences there are. Maybe it'll find things that are way better in yours, who knows, but hopefully it'll find some cool things you can bring over from this.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool, so let's go back to our Cloud code here. Alright, bootstrap is done. We are now fully done with Phase 1. So we have the core set up, and so now for the next phase, what we're going to be doing here…
Cole Medin: is we're gonna make it so that the core memory files are actually loaded into our conversation. We're gonna set up all of the Claude Code hooks. And this phase is actually gonna go by very quickly.
Cole Medin: And then, Jason, for the prompt for the bootstrap.
Cole Medin: all I did is I told it to, just read the bootstrap, and then go through the process. So, the PRD, like, when we do Phase 1,
Cole Medin: it creates that bootstrap automatically and puts it here, and so then we can just point Claude code to it and say, walk me through the bootstrap. And then it automatically deletes the file after, because we only have to do that for our first conversation with our second brain. And then, of course, we can keep, like, improving the user.md and soul.md and everything going forward, but…
Cole Medin: The initial stage has been set now.
Cole Medin: Alright, cool. So, we are at the halfway point for our workshop here.
Cole Medin: So I'm gonna take a… I'm gonna… let us all take a 10-minute break. So, get some food if it's the lunch hour for you, if you're in the States.
Cole Medin: Or if it's dinner, if you're over in Europe. Well, I guess it'd be a little bit late for dinner in Europe, but I'm gonna go and get a little bit of food myself, so I'm going to mute and turn off my camera, and I will be back at 1.20 my time. So in 10 minutes from now, 20 minutes past the hour, I'll be back, and we'll get right into phase number 2.
Cole Medin: building the rest of our second brand. So don't go anywhere, and also this is a time for you to catch up if anything's going along, like Brandon creating his PRD, so use that time if you need.
Cole Medin: Otherwise, I will be back in 10 minutes.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Alright guys, I am back.
Cole Medin: Sean, what is the, issue you're having exactly with your Cloud code?
Cole Medin: That sounds really unfortunate, I'm sorry.
Cole Medin: We'll get… we'll get rolling in just a minute here, but I wanted to ask that first. I was just looking at the chat a little bit,
Cole Medin: When I got back to my computer, It's not writing the PRD?
Cole Medin: Are you not in bypass permission mode, or…
Cole Medin: Oh, after 45 minutes, okay. So, I've had this happen before.
Cole Medin: Actually, it just happened to me twice yesterday, where Claude just gets totally stuck.
Cole Medin: You just have to double-hit escape, and then tell it to continue.
Cole Medin: Yeah, it's… it's also possible they could be having, like, a regional outage or something as well.
Cole Medin: So,
Cole Medin: There are currently… so, here, I'll pop it up on my screen. There's an outage with Sonnet 4.6, so maybe you're accidentally using Sonnet?
Cole Medin: Also, if… whenever there are outages like this, sometimes there's, like, smaller regional outages for, like, Opus as well, but they're just focusing on the more global one.
Cole Medin: So there could… there could be a problem. Actually, I hope I don't run into this during my workshop here, but that is a possibility.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, if anyone else is experiencing that, yeah, I guess Brandon,
Cole Medin: Okay, double tap, just gave in to continue to pick back up. Yeah, that's always the way to go if it's just a fluke or a temporary glitch.
Cole Medin: But, yeah, Sean, I had that happen twice yesterday, a clawed code, it was not fun.
Cole Medin: So yeah, for those of you who run into anything like that, like, you can always feel free to follow along with the recording after.
Cole Medin: Always going to be available to you guys. I know there was a couple of people that mentioned that it feels like I'm going kind of quick.
Cole Medin: And unfortunately, I… I do have to go kind of quick, just because there's so much to cover here.
Cole Medin: I want to do it as a live event for those of you who want the energy and to ask questions and to follow along as much as possible. But, like, certainly I can understand, like, this might be really valuable also as a course, where it's videos that you can pause and…
Cole Medin: wait for your claw to be done and move on, right? So you're not, like, prompting and trying to listen at the same time.
Cole Medin: Totally understand. Yeah, so I'm gonna make sure that it's a big priority for me early next week to turn this workshop into the edited recording.
Cole Medin: Yeah. And I'll try to keep answering all the questions you guys have as well.
Cole Medin: So, alright.
Cole Medin: Let's go ahead and get right into the next part of it here. So, while I was taking my break, I decided that for the sake of time, I am going to be doing some things in parallel.
Cole Medin: So, going back to our diagram here…
Cole Medin: Luckily for some of our upcoming modules here.
Cole Medin: it's gonna be quite easy to do it at the same time. So I'm gonna add in the whole, like, memory search pipeline.
Cole Medin: and the hooks, At the exact same time.
Cole Medin: And then, we'll add in the direct integrations and skills at the same time.
Cole Medin: So, now that we understand how the second brain works, and we've built the initial foundation, it should be relatively easy to follow along. Like, I can still go a bit slow.
Cole Medin: and explain things, but I do want to build it at the exact same time.
Cole Medin: So, what I'm gonna do is go back to my Claude code.
Cole Medin: And I'm going to start, 4 sessions here.
Cole Medin: Or, well, I'll start with two sessions. So I'm gonna do two planning sessions.
Cole Medin: So, I'm gonna run slash prime twice.
Cole Medin: One for Phase 2, And one for Phase 3.
Cole Medin: And so it's gonna get very procedural now, and I mean this in a good way. It'll be easier to follow, because exactly what I did for Phase 1, I'm gonna be doing for all the other phases. I do a prime, and then I create the plan, and then I go into implementation and do my validation.
Cole Medin: It's gonna be the same every single time, just very classic piv loops. Now, I should have probably actually made a commit after the first phase. Doesn't really matter, though, because it's mostly just the Markdown documents at first, but I do recommend
Cole Medin: Doing the… the commit, like, making a commit at the end of each phase.
Cole Medin: Dom asks, how do you determine which phase is primed? Well, it's doing a whole general prime of the codebase, it's not specific to a phase. So it's after it does the prime that I'm gonna say, like, let's work on phase two, I'm going to be doing phase three in parallel, and then I'll do the opposite in the other session.
Cole Medin: So, okay. Here's the prime report. We have our general structure, okay, very cool. So, we did foundations, we did phase one, next we're doing hooks.
Cole Medin: Great, so I'll just go in to my speech text and say, alright, fantastic, let's go ahead and add in the hooks. So, give me a summary here of what you plan on implementing for this according to the PRD.
Cole Medin: There we go.
Cole Medin: Cool, so there's the first one, and then for our second conversation here, I'm just gonna go past the hooks, because the other one is handling it.
Cole Medin: So, I have another conversation that's handling Phase 2. So, let's actually do some planning for Phase 3. I want to do it in parallel. So, let me know, according to the PRD, everything that we should implement now for Phase 3.
Cole Medin: There we go.
Cole Medin: Now, be careful with this. You know, you can't always do parallel development if the coding agents are going to step on each other's toes a lot. I'm just letting you know, for what we're doing right here, it's going to work.
Cole Medin: Because they're gonna be doing pretty isolated changes in our codebase here. They don't have to step on each other's toes.
Cole Medin: So, alright, here's our plan for phase number 2. We're gonna be creating our 3 hooks here. So this is where we're creating our start hook.
Cole Medin: So we are automatically injecting the core files into our session at the start.
Cole Medin: And then we have the pre-compact and end hooks. So whenever we're about to do a memory compression or end a session, we need to send the conversation to Claude Code to figure out what we want to save and store in our daily logs. And so this is how our agent is able to remember all of our interactions. We're starting to set that up now
Cole Medin: Through our hooks.
Cole Medin: And so it gives me a summary of what this looks like here. We're invoking this special memory flush Python script. This is the most important part of Phase 2. This memory flush Python script is the separate process that runs Claude code
Cole Medin: to summarize all of our conversations. And so, both of our pre-compact and session end hooks, they're actually going to invoke the separate Cloud Code session.
Cole Medin: And if you guys didn't know, all Cloud Code conversations are actually stored as JSON-L files on your local system. So, our separate Cloud Code session can read the entire conversation and summarize that, and then put that in our daily logs. And we'll see that in action after we build this as well.
Cole Medin: So I'm gonna do plan feature.
Cole Medin: And we can just say, like, alright, great, let's go ahead and create the structure plan for phase number 2.
Cole Medin: Send that off.
Cole Medin: And then, in parallel, we can take a look at what we found for our memory searching. So, yeah, let me know if I'm going a little too fast. I'm gonna try to be as slow as possible and break down what we're doing here. I'll keep referencing back the diagram.
Cole Medin: As we are, talking about what we're building here. So now, what we're gonna be building in Phase 3 is being able to search over our memories. So this is where we are adding RAG into our second brain.
Cole Medin: And so…
Cole Medin: we obviously have to deal with embeddings. I'm just gonna use a local embedding model, and if you're not super familiar with RAG and embeddings and everything, don't worry, the PRD handles all of this for us, right? So we have our SQLite database.
Cole Medin: And then we're gonna have a couple of scripts, because we need one script to be able to search through our memories, and then we need another script that handles indexing, right? We need some process to look through our daily logs.
Cole Medin: and then capture all that into our database for RAG. That is what the memory index handles. And it even gives me an explanation of this as well. So, as you're going through and building your own second brain, or taking ideas from what I have here, if there's anything you don't understand, you can always ask Claude Code.
Cole Medin: And it can give you an overview of everything we're doing here.
Cole Medin: So, honestly, Phase 3 is where it starts to get a little bit technical under the hood, talking about the embedding model, and the database, and how we are handling the tables in the database. But you can ask as many questions as you need to understand
Cole Medin: what we have going on under the hood. And like I said, one of the main advantages of building our own second brain is we do get to actually understand the codebase, because we're building it along with Cloud Code, and we can ask questions along the way. So even if you aren't as technical.
Cole Medin: you can raise yourself to a level of understanding where you really feel like you have a grasp of your codebase. That's what I want for you here.
Cole Medin: And so, for me, I already understand all this because I built it already, so it's quite helpful right now. But, if you wanted to dive deeper into everything that we're building here, you can definitely have a conversation with Claude Code before you just go into, you know, planning the feature here, so…
Cole Medin: Yes, this all makes sense. Let's go ahead and create the structure plan for Phase 3.
Cole Medin: There we go.
Cole Medin: So, we're just going through the motions here of the piv loop.
Cole Medin: Nice and easy.
Cole Medin: Alright, so both of these are in the middle of running here.
Cole Medin: Alright, so I'll go through some more questions here.
Cole Medin: You know, what I'm going to try to do is I'm going to try to move a little bit faster through the questions. So, I'll give, like, simple answers.
Cole Medin: And then I'll let you know when your question is going to be answered more as we're building the other phases.
Cole Medin: So, alright. Sean asks, is there a way that we can have our second brain access Dynamis posts?
Cole Medin: Unfortunately not.
Cole Medin: Because the rate limits aren't actually that nice for Circle, so even if I gave an API key to everyone, then it would blow through the rate limits. So, I wish. That would be nice.
Cole Medin: Brandon said, what I've come to conclude is that my AI agent is essentially a coding agent first and foremost. Why wouldn't we use Archon or a coding agent to actually continue to monitor and build themselves out?
Cole Medin: My use case is an AI executive assistant, adding skills, capabilities, I love to just talk to them on Slack and have them code it themselves, rather than going into a terminal to create and maintain code.
Cole Medin: Am I thinking about this right? Yes, Brandon, 100% you are. That's right.
Cole Medin: Yeah, for whatever you're building, you can have it improve itself, because… and that's kind of what we're doing as a second brain, like, it is a coding agent first. Like, that's the whole point, is we're laying out the foundation here so the agent can evolve itself, right? We're kind of just, like… that's why we're using Claude Code as the foundation for our second brain.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, that's… that's very, very good.
Cole Medin: Dom said, one thing I'm missing is a connection to a local server instead of a cloud installation, like, hosting it at home.
Cole Medin: Yeah, if you wanted to run the second brain on your computer, and then you could, like, set up, you know, TwinGate or Tailscale or something so you can access it when it's running on your desktop from other devices on your network, you definitely can do that.
Cole Medin: Oh, I forgot to answer live. Okay, there we go. Answer live, done. Moving on to the next Q&A. Alright.
Cole Medin: Mike said, learning loops. Have you implemented a pattern, anti-pattern detection learning algorithms and systems for updating memory docs?
Cole Medin: Yeah, so… I do have the whole daily reflection. This is how I'm updating the memory over time.
Cole Medin: As far as, other sorts of learning loops.
Cole Medin: I've actually intentionally left it more manual.
Cole Medin: And so, as far as, like, improving our skills automatically, or direct integrations, I want that to be more led by you.
Cole Medin: So, when you figure out that a skill isn't being used quite right, or a direct integration isn't being used quite right, that's your opportunity to just talk to your second brain, and say, hey, I don't think you built the diagram in the right way.
Cole Medin: or this PowerPoint doesn't really have my tone of voice. Like, let's take a look into the AI layer and the skills and see what we can make better, so that going forward, the system has evolved.
Cole Medin: And I like being in the driver's seat there. I don't really want something like Carpathy's Auto Research, where it's kind of just, like, evolving its own skill.md or whatever file.
Cole Medin: Because I think the human in the loop is still really important there. Otherwise, the second brain just kind of goes off the rails, and it's not necessarily aligned with you when it's doing that self-evolution. So you could definitely build that in if you want.
Cole Medin: You could even add that into the whole PRD here. But for me, I want it to evolve its memories, and that's enough. I want to still be the one saying, like, let's change this skill in this way, or help me think about how we would change this skill.
Cole Medin: All right, and then John said, can you please share the exact folder structure to start with, i.e, how do you create the proper folder structure from the repos? I want to start, but don't want to run into the issues I'm seeing from others starting from the wrong repo base. Yeah, John, so I'll put it really simply, all you need to do is take the commands folder.
Cole Medin: And the skills folder.
Cole Medin: And you just copy that into a brand new directory in .clod.
Cole Medin: Right? So, like, what I have here, I have my .cloud folder where I copied over the commands, I copied over the skills, and that's it. Just super simple, you start with nothing else. And in fact, the only skill I started with is the Create Second Brain PRD, so I'll copy in the other ones in Phase 5.
Cole Medin: So, nice and easy. You don't have to start from the other repo. That's what was causing problems for other people, because it was loading in the Cloud Code hooks that I have in my example here, that were blocking, like, reading and writing some files, because of the .env keyword.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool, so it's, in the middle of writing the structure plans here, so we got time for some more questions.
Cole Medin: Danny said, will it be enough with a Claude Pro subscription, or should I have Max? A Pro subscription will be enough. The second brain is not too token heavy. Like, it'll take a decent number of tokens as you're building it and evolving it, but a Pro subscription should be enough.
Cole Medin: Bart said, can you answer this, please, Cole? Is there a starter repo to follow along today? Yeah, so this question was answered a little bit ago, or asked a little bit ago, so I assume that you've seen the answer from me, but I'll link to this in the Zoom chat again.
Cole Medin: And remember that it's linked in the description for our workshop here as well. This has my entire second brain ready for you to reference.
Cole Medin: And also has the skill, the second… the Create Second Brain PRV skill, for you to use as your starting point.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So if we wanted to code along, should we use an empty project? That is right, Eddie. Yep, yep.
Cole Medin: Can I use this locally on my private computer with sensitive data? Lucas, yes, you can. It just depends on how comfortable you are with sharing that information with, like, the Anthropic API, like, through the Frontier models. If you want to run the entire second brain locally.
Cole Medin: You can use something like Olama to power your cloud code, so it's not actually going out to a cloud LLM. It is very realistic to make this entire system run 100% locally, not going out to any APIs, as far as, like, sending out your information.
Cole Medin: So, if you're interested in doing a 100% local implementation, I would just make that very clear when you create your PRD up front, because then as you go through each of the phases here, it'll keep that in mind. Like, let's make sure that for Lucas's second brain, we're not using a frontier model, or we're not sending out API requests with sensitive information.
Cole Medin: So we can still have information come in from the internet through our integrations, but it's just we don't want to send data out, right?
Cole Medin: So you can use something like Olama or LiteLLM to run local models if you want.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Is that the full repo in the description, since it doesn't seem to have a lot in it yet? So it is BART. That's actually because most of what we have here, like, I know it doesn't seem like a lot, but most of what we have is in the .cloud folder. Within scripts specifically, this is where you'll see
Cole Medin: all of the memory scripts and the integration scripts, a lot of it is just stored right within .clon.
Cole Medin: So, there is actually a lot here, trust me. It just doesn't look like it when you look at the root of the repository. So, totally fair observation, but it, yeah, it's all there. Yep.
Cole Medin: Alright, cool, so let's go back.
Cole Medin: Alright, so we've created our plan to add in hooks, and then we also have our Phase 3 plan for our memory search. So, let's take a look at this really quick.
Cole Medin: And again, I'm going to go a little bit quickly through reviewing the plans here, but as you're building the implementation for yourself, feel free to ask as many questions as you need to understand what we're building here. The whole point is to take inspiration from my solution, so you can dive into each part with Claude Code, or whatever coding agent you're using.
Cole Medin: So, with hooks, every cloud session starts cold, or without hooks. So, we have the global rules, but the agent has no automatic access to our core files. That's what we're building for Phase 2. Sold.md, user.md, memory.md, we're gonna read those all in up front.
Cole Medin: And then, we're going to spawn that background Claude Agent SDK session to summarize conversations before we compact and at the end of every session. So, this is exactly what we've already gone over together in the Excalibra diagram. This is looking really good. And I just want to scroll down to the validation in the plan really quick. I'll kind of skim past
Cole Medin: Everything else here.
Cole Medin: We're gonna do our basic checks.
Cole Medin: Security check.
Cole Medin: Okay, honestly, we're not checking too much right here.
Cole Medin: because it's more going to be up to me to start a brand new Cloud Code session. I'll actually, like, show you what it looks like to start a new Cloud Code session after this phase is implemented, and we'll see that it'll, like, automatically have access to the information in these files through the start session hook.
Cole Medin: And then we can even test, like, the end session hook as well.
Cole Medin: So, okay.
Cole Medin: We have our plan here.
Cole Medin: I'm going to start a brand new Cloud Code session to go into the implementation. So I'll copy the path.
Cole Medin: slash execute.
Cole Medin: And there we go. We are off to the races. Alright, so then we'll go on to Phase 3 with memory search. Let's take a look at this structure plan really quickly here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, we're going to be building a chunking, embedding, and search pipeline that enables semantic and keyword search across all Vault Markdown documents. So, even all of our daily logs, this is important.
Cole Medin: Because there… as you use your second brain, when you use it for months and months and months, there are going to be so many files here. We need semantic search, because it's not going to be realistic for our agent to, like, manually read all these files, once there's a lot of them, to find information.
Cole Medin: So we're building our RAG pipeline here. We're keeping it very simple.
Cole Medin: with just a SQLite database right now.
Cole Medin: Alright, and so let's actually see… so it's also going to create the scripts to, you know, bring things into our SQLite database. The indexing is going to create the search script as well, so that's what it's laying out here in the task list right now, like this right here is our, indexing script.
Cole Medin: We don't care about all the underlying details, you can feel free to ask Claude about it if you want.
Cole Medin: But I'm just kind of curious what the validation is going to look like here. So here's our testing strategy. So we're going to do some unit-level validation.
Cole Medin: We're gonna actually try running the script, that's really important. So it's gonna do some indexing, it's gonna actually do some testing.
Cole Medin: We're gonna make sure that it's very thorough here, right? Like, it's gonna run the full index, it's gonna do the hybrid search, it's gonna make sure that, like, you know, how our second brain is going to search and index going forward, right after the implementation, we're gonna test all those things. So we're gonna let the agent test its own work.
Cole Medin: So, very good. Let's go ahead and kick off this implementation as well.
Cole Medin: So, slash execute.
Cole Medin: Give it the path to the Phase 3 plan.
Cole Medin: And we're off to the races. Alright.
Cole Medin: Yep, I want to allow access. Claude Code does this thing sometimes, where even in bypass permission mode, it'll, like, ask me for permission. It's a recent glitch that was added to Claude Code, which is honestly kind of frustrating. I don't know if anyone else has seen this recently themselves.
Cole Medin: But I'll go in YOLO mode, and it still pauses for permission, specifically when it's editing something in its own .cloud folder. Don't really know why it's doing that. So I'll have to kind of check once in a while here, but while we're waiting for these to run, I'll go ahead and answer more of your guys' questions here.
Cole Medin: Will we get access to the chat messages later along with the recording?
Cole Medin: Yep, so, yeah, Pat is… that's correct, the chats are posted as a part of the recording, yes.
Cole Medin: Kaushik said, I saw that. Folks are saying YOLDA mode is going away or deprecated. Yeah, it seems like they're doing something with that, for sure. I don't know… yeah, see, even this one, it did the same thing, like…
Cole Medin: We'll see if it keeps asking me. Let's see, like, this file, it created fine, but then, like, the one before, I don't know, it's kind of weird.
Cole Medin: Yeah, interesting. So I'll just kind of have to, like, keep clicking back and forth, making sure we're good to go. But alright, I'll go on to the next question here.
Cole Medin: Bart said, I use Zulip instead of Slack and run it on DigitalOcean. Very good and easy to set up. That is super cool. I've never actually heard of it before. But yeah, so I guess if you guys want a self-hosted version of Slack, take a look at Zulip, if I'm saying that right. Z-U-L-I-P? Cool.
Cole Medin: Chris said, can we use a local LLM? Would it work just as well as using the agent SDK?
Cole Medin: So, let me be clear, you are allowed to, or not allowed, you can use local models with the Cloud Agent SDK.
Cole Medin: So, here, I'll even, like, do a quick search.
Cole Medin: or actually, no. Sorry, I don't… I can't… I can't go and do that right now, but if you just, like, do a quick search for Ask an LLM, like, how do I use Olama or any kind of local LLM with the Cloud Agent SDK, it can walk you through that. Very easy to set that up. You can make this entire system local, Chris.
Cole Medin: So, Evo said, in the Archon repo, you have a .agents slash .clawed architecture, but Claude expects it at the root of the tree.
Cole Medin: You do this in the second brain repo. How does it work for Archon? No, so they're not nested. They just live side by side.
Cole Medin: So anything that I want Cloud code to load automatically, it has in the .cloud folder. The .agents is just for me to organize other parts of my AI layer that I'm not, like, integrating directly in the Cloud code, like files that I would specifically tell it to reference or something. So they're not nested, like, you can see they're at the same level here.
Cole Medin: If there is actually anything where there is a .clawed in a dot agent, that is a mistake. So, I don't know if that actually is how I have it in Archon, but I don't think so, because I would have had a lot of problems if that was the case.
Cole Medin: When did the .agent appear? Dom, it created this automatically when it built the PRD. That's just a part of the PRD skill, where it… this is, like, the default location, so it just makes those folders automatically.
Cole Medin: Yep.
Cole Medin: Karsten, that's exactly right. So you just have to set the Anthropic base URL to point it to Ollama instead of Clod, and that's how you use local AI with both the Claude Agent SDK and Claude Code CLI itself.
Cole Medin: Very easy. You just have to… you have to set up that, and then there's, like, another environment variable to set that defines the model ID, because you have to specify the model in the new provider as well. Just two environment variables, and if you ask Claude or, like, Google, it'll come up really quick.
Cole Medin: Yup.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, let's take a look here. So, it actually already built
Cole Medin: the hooks here. So phase two is done, and we can even test this now. So I'm gonna open up a new session. So it built the 3 hooks.
Cole Medin: And it did some validation here, looks really good.
Cole Medin: Okay, well, hold on, it said I need to include the Anthropic API key, this isn't quite right.
Cole Medin: So, I actually want to use UV for package management. So, let's do UV instead. I want you to install the requirements, and then the Cloud Agent SDK, I want to just use my Anthropic subscription. So, I want you to search the web for that. We can use that just like we do with Claude code. I don't need to set my Anthropic API key.
Cole Medin: So I want you to take care of all this for me, and then make a commit.
Cole Medin: Alright, so I'm doing quite a bit here, but yeah, so sometimes Claude doesn't realize with the Claude Agent SDK, we don't have to set our Anthropic API key, so you might have to correct that yourself. That's why we're building live together here, so you can see some of the gotchas as they happen, and we can address them together.
Cole Medin: So I'll just make sure that gets things set up right, and then I'll test in a new Cloud code session here. So we'll test a couple of the hooks to make sure they're good. Obviously, I recommend testing every single phase before you move on to the next one, or test the ones you did in parallel before you move on to the next one. So, looks like Phase 3 is still in the middle of building here, so…
Cole Medin: Let's go to a couple more questions now.
Cole Medin: Alright, Dave said, is there a specific Obsidian Vault layout or architecture that I recommend or use?
Cole Medin: Yeah, so let me go to my primary, vault here.
Cole Medin: Because, if you want to take a screenshot of this really quick.
Cole Medin: you can definitely feel free. I mean, some of these are very specific to me, like the two coarse ones at the top.
Cole Medin: But the way I like to operate is I have my content ideation folder.
Cole Medin: This is where I just, like, dump a ton of ideas per day, and then I just, like, have a process that automatically, like, archives them every so often.
Cole Medin: So I… I ideate my content here, so that when I'm, like, creating YouTube scripts and things like that, I have a folder for my daily notes that I take, a folder for my diagrams, and then I have meeting notes. I have all the memory, this is what's for my second brain.
Cole Medin: I have permanent notes, so these are just, like, any notes I'm taking as, you know, like, reading books or anything like that. Reference notes, this is specifically for…
Cole Medin: any, like, external information that I want to bring into my vault. I don't use it that often, but this is a part of, like, the Zettelkasten technique, if you've ever heard of that. It's just a technique for organizing your knowledge for your second brain in Obsidian, or even, like, in physi… Zettelkasten was around before the digital age, even.
Cole Medin: Those are the main ones, and so it's really, like, these that are all the main ones. They're, like, storing, like, recordings as well. Personal, I just have, like.
Cole Medin: couple little things in there, so… I don't have it, like, perfectly organized, so it's mostly, like, what I'd recommend is content ideation, daily notes, storing diagrams if you have them, meeting notes, permanent notes, and reference notes.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Jeffrey asks, does the folder organization method in .cloud also apply to other coding environments like VS Code or Cursor, especially if you're using tools besides Cloud code?
Cole Medin: So, you can organize it like .cloud, but it'd probably be… I mean, like, it's not going to be used automatically like it is the Cloud code, so you can kind of just call it, like.agents or whatever you want. When I'm working with other coding agents that don't have the concept of, like, a .cloud folder, then I'm usually just calling it .agent or .agents.
Cole Medin: And I'm just putting all of my, like, second brain AI layer stuff right in there.
Cole Medin: I use speech-to-text for coding. Can you do this on your phone or tablet? So, I just use what's built into my phone. It's not as good as Aquavoice, but it definitely suffices. So, when I talk to my second brain in Slack, I'll just use what's built into my phone, so…
Cole Medin: I don't think Aquavoice has a mobile tool. Maybe they do, actually. I would be interested in using that if they did.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool, so…
Cole Medin: Let's see, how are we looking now? So, it's still in the middle of Phase 2, and… okay, Phase 3 is actually done.
Cole Medin: So let's see if we can validate Phase 3 really quickly.
Cole Medin: Alright, okay, so here are the completed tasks.
Cole Medin: Set up the requirements.
Cole Medin: Embedding wrapper… wait, hold on. I actually switched to UV for package management. I did that in Phase 2, I was doing in parallel. Let's make sure that we update that. Okay, I just… I just realized that it did step on the toes of Phase 2, so I'm just fixing that really quick. But anyway, we have the embeddings.
Cole Medin: the database abstractions, this is where we connect to SQLite, and then we have the indexing and the memory search.
Cole Medin: It had to fix some things in the middle of implementation as it was validating, but take a look at this. It actually did a full index, so it already indexed my memory files into my database, and then
Cole Medin: it did some searching here. So, it ran everything that the second brain would usually do in order to search. And so, we could go into another conversation, though.
Cole Medin: And we could ask it to search through our memories. Like, we already have the index and everything set up. I know that it feels like we're doing it kind of quickly, but we're using the PRD to guide our implementation, so we're able to move pretty fast.
Cole Medin: Okay, and so, let me go to bypass permission mode again.
Cole Medin: Carson asked, what are my Aquavoice stats? Here, I'll show ya.
Cole Medin: Almost at 900,000 words.
Cole Medin: 27-day streak, time saved, almost 11 days. Yeah, I use it a lot. So Aquavoice DOM is not free. It is $10 a month, but it is, like, the best $10 a month I've ever spent.
Cole Medin: But I know there are some free and open source options out there, like Epicenter Whispering, that are pretty good, but this is, like, the best I've seen.
Cole Medin: Whisper Flow is really, really good, too.
Cole Medin: Ivo said, there are AquaVoice mobile apps. Okay, I need to get on that, for sure. Okay.
Cole Medin: Alright, so how does my second brain know about the searching capabilities when I first start a Cloud Code session?
Cole Medin: Does it have access to that through my clod.md? Like, do you have the indexing and search functions documented there?
Cole Medin: Because one thing that I'm asking about here very intentionally is, like, how does our second brain know about the capability that we just built? This is a good, like, golden nugget for you guys. As you are building your second brain.
Cole Medin: and you're adding in the different phases, you need to make sure that the second brain understands that it has that capability, right? And that's, typically… that'll go in something like a clod.md.
Cole Medin: So you can see right here that, like, the built-in commands, I'm documenting this. Like, we don't have things for the heartbeat yet, but we just implemented Phase 3, so we have the ability to search.
Cole Medin: So we have that documented, and so, yeah, now I can go into a brand new Cloud Code session.
Cole Medin: And, wait, is Phase 2? Okay, Phase 2's done as well, so we could actually test this here.
Cole Medin: Okay, so we're gonna test a couple of things.
Cole Medin: We just built Phase 2, which means we have the start session hook, and so now I can say, without reading the soul.md, because you should have it injected through the start session hook, I want you to summarize your role based on the soul.md file.
Cole Medin: Alright, so what we should see here is it shouldn't have to make a tool called a read a file. It should just automatically know about it. So this is the moment of truth. This is our first test for phase number 2.
Cole Medin: There we go. Alright, so no tool call. Based on what got injected at session start, here's my summary. My role is Cole's AI second brain. So, boom. There we go. The session hook is working here.
Cole Medin: And if you want to look at this, we can see the settings.json, these are the three hooks that it built for us here. Nice and simple, just using UV to run these Python scripts, and then we also have the whole memory flush process when we end a session.
Cole Medin: And so, for example, I can say, I want you to search through my memories to find out some information about me. I'll just do, like, a really generic question here. So this is now testing phase number 3, because what we should see here
Cole Medin: is, just search anything. I want to demonstrate the memory searching that we just built.
Cole Medin: So, I'm just gonna give it kind of a generic request here, just so we can see the tool call for it using the memory search script. Take a look at that. So, the clod.md, our global rules, describes how to invoke our memory search.
Cole Medin: And then it specifies a parameter, like, my background and interest. We can see that it got the vector search score, so it's performing RAG with semantic search under the hood.
Cole Medin: And then everything that we see.
Cole Medin: And the logs here are the chunks that we got back from our, you know, vector database through SQLite.
Cole Medin: So there we go.
Cole Medin: Got some information from each of them, there we go, very cool.
Cole Medin: Looking very good. So there's Phase 3. Nice.
Cole Medin: And now, the other test that I want to do for Phase 2 is I want to test what happens when I end a session. Because remember, we need our daily logs to update with a summary of every single conversation. We want our agent to be able to learn from every single conversation. So, if we look in the daily logs folder right now.
Cole Medin: We have one for today.
Cole Medin: And it's pretty sparse right now. We just have, you know, like, our bootstrap completed, we established the pillars for our habits, right? Captured sauna project ID, we built phase one, right? Like, super basic right now. We haven't captured much yet.
Cole Medin: But, if I close the session.
Cole Medin: Take a look at this. I exited the session. I don't know if you guys saw that. You had to watch, like, really closely, but there was a terminal that popped up for just a split second, because that is invoking the underlying Claude Agent SDK session to summarize the conversation, and then update our log file here.
Cole Medin: So it's not updated yet, because we're invoking Claude, right? It's gonna take a little bit of time for that to run, and then for us to update this file. But the goal here is when we end a session, or whenever we do a memory compaction, it's going to automatically reason about, like, what part of this conversation do I care about?
Cole Medin: Saving, like, let's create a summary of it, and then we'll put it in the daily logs. And then later, remember, when we get to phase, the next, or the daily reflection phase, this is, supposed to be phase 6, not 3.
Cole Medin: That's when we're going to have the process set up to run every day and do, essentially, the Cloud Code dreaming. So we'll take all of the raw summaries of conversations and figure out what important lessons we want to distill down into our memory.md. So we'll come to this later, but we have the infrastructure set up now with our hooks and the whole memory flushing process, like I described.
Cole Medin: So, let's go back, and let's see if it is done. So I'm gonna go…
Cole Medin: Open the file again… hold on… Let me go
Cole Medin: Okay, so it's still not updated. Maybe something's actually broken here.
Cole Medin: And it's not… it's not fair to expect that we're gonna, like, build everything perfectly right away. There might legitimately be a problem.
Cole Medin: So, it does feel like it should have been done by now.
Cole Medin: So, I'm actually gonna ask it here.
Cole Medin: So I'm gonna go back to the session where I implemented Phase 2, and I'm just gonna say, hey, I ended a conversation, and I'm not seeing anything updated in my daily log. I'm not confident that the whole memory flush process is actually working. So I want you to look into this and try to see if you can, like, run it, and
Cole Medin: do a dry run to see if you can get it to work, or figure out what the error is, if it is not working. That was not a very eloquent prompt, but it's good enough for what we need here. So, let me check. Yeah, so the file's still not updated. I mean, maybe it actually is still running. Maybe I'm being a little impatient, but I think it might be broken, but it's okay.
Cole Medin: Because we're just going to, let it rip.
Cole Medin: And let it figure it out.
Cole Medin: Okay.
Cole Medin: So, in the meantime, while we work through the problem in Phase 2,
Cole Medin: I'm not going to focus on this too much, because you guys get the idea of, like, when you encounter a problem, you just let it know.
Cole Medin: In the same session where you're building that phase.
Cole Medin: Right. And so, what I'm gonna do here…
Cole Medin: is I'm just gonna move on.
Cole Medin: And I'm going to start the planning process for phases number 4 and 5. So I'm going to open up 2 more Cloud Code sessions here.
Cole Medin: We're gonna make sure, I'm gonna make sure that we build everything, that we need for the next hour here.
Cole Medin: Okay.
Cole Medin: Oops, I need to do that. Alright, so I'm gonna go here, I'm gonna run the prime again twice, so I'm just gonna keep setting that context up front.
Cole Medin: And, these two phases are actually gonna go pretty quick. They don't take that long. So we're gonna add in the direct integrations.
Cole Medin: And the reason this is gonna be really fast is because we have a standard template.
Cole Medin: for our integrations. I'll actually show you guys this really quick here. It's pretty cool. One of the big resources that I built for you guys. So, within the repository, and the PRD creation process actually references this.
Cole Medin: If we go into Dot Claude.
Cole Medin: And we go into scripts and Integrations, we have this integration template.
Cole Medin: So we're going to use this as a starting point to build any of the integrations, the arms, for our second brain. So, if you want to ever build a new integration, you can just point your Cloud code to this file. I'll put a link to… it's not, like, ultra important, but in case you're interested, like, I'll put a link to this in the Zoom chat as well.
Cole Medin: But this is, like, a good starting point for how I always set up my integrations. And so, that's gonna make it really easy for us
Cole Medin: that, like, it's gonna be very easy to build these integrations, each one of them, because they're going to follow a very similar format. And then the other thing that we're doing in parallel here is just adding in the skills. And this is so easy, because we're just going to copy all of them in the reference repo that I have for you guys.
Cole Medin: like, the Excalibraw diagram skill, and the whole, like, PowerPoint skill, and social media skills. We're just mostly, like, that's why I'm gonna rip through this really fast.
Cole Medin: Just some hint that the video recording is gonna stop soon. Oh, that's just from one of the note takers, Dom. I appreciate you mentioning that, but we're good here for the main recording in the workshop.
Cole Medin: Alright, so let's go back.
Cole Medin: I want to… oops… I want to quickly check on, the Cascade, and all the… okay.
Cole Medin: The memory flush pipeline is working correctly. I ran two tests. Why you didn't see anything from your previous session? The hooks were just created during this session. Your prior session ending didn't have them registered yet. I don't think that is true, actually.
Cole Medin: Because… I had started a new session.
Cole Medin: No, actually, I had started a new session, after the hooks were made, so there is something that is wrong here. Don't get lazy on me! I need you to figure out why the hook didn't fire correctly, or why the hook didn't run right.
Cole Medin: It got lazy on me here. It told me that it was just because I needed to restart Claude, but we obviously saw the start session hook work, so we know that we loaded in all of the hooks after we built them, so…
Cole Medin: We'll work through that. Yeah, fair enough, let me actually dig into this properly. Multiple potential failure points to check. Alright, so we'll let it work through that.
Cole Medin: Let's go into Phase 4 and 5 now.
Cole Medin: Alright, so, right now, it gave us an overview through the Prime. Next up is phase number 4. So we're gonna add in our integrations. For you, this could be way different, but for me, it's going to be Gmail, Asana, Slack, Calendar, and Circle. Alright.
Cole Medin: So, let's go ahead and start planning for phase number 4. So, based on the PRD, let me know what we're going to implement. And then also, now that we're going to get into some environment variables for our platforms, tell me what you need for environment variables, because I actually want to just set this up front for you, so we can go right into the implementation and validation.
Cole Medin: This is, another golden nugget for you guys here.
Cole Medin: is whenever you're about to go into something that you know needs API keys, like, we're gonna integrate with Gmail, and Asana, and Google Calendar.
Cole Medin: we want to get the environment variables set up ahead of time, so that way, once we go into implementation, the agent can write the code and do the validation in one shot. We don't want it to write the code
Cole Medin: And then, like, try to, you know, sort of, like, half-validate things, but it doesn't… it can't actually, like, interact with our services yet.
Cole Medin: And so, it's much more efficient to just set up the environment variable right away. So it tells us what we need for Asana, and Slack, and Gmail.
Cole Medin: So this part, this part is, like, really custom to me, so you can just follow the instructions that it gives you for yourself, but actually what I'm going to do is I'm going to copy over the .env.
Cole Medin: that I have from… my,
Cole Medin: other repository. So I'm gonna copy this file. I'm gonna do this off-camera really quick.
Cole Medin: I'm gonna paste this here.
Cole Medin: Alright. And then I'm gonna also copy my Google token.
Cole Medin: So give me a second to do that.
Cole Medin: And for whatever integrations you're setting up, remember, just ask Cloudco whatever you need to do.
Cole Medin: So I'm gonna copy my Google… So, credential… Paste that…
Cole Medin: And then also my token, copy, paste… Okay.
Cole Medin: There we go.
Cole Medin: So, I copied over these files, my master environment variables from my main second brain,
Cole Medin: Well, actually, maybe I shouldn't do that one, hold on.
Cole Medin: I'm gonna do it from the dry run that I did yesterday. That actually is gonna be much better.
Cole Medin: Let me actually find that… okay.
Cole Medin: Okay, let me go off-camera again really quick. Sorry, guys, I knew this was gonna be one of those, like, annoying things I have to do off-camera, but I'll make it really quick.
Cole Medin: Copy the .env, copy… put that into .claw, paste it… okay, there we go.
Cole Medin: So here's what I got. I got my .env.
Cole Medin: I have my Google credentials, and then the token that we generate here. This is just specifically how I have to connect to my Google services.
Cole Medin: Okay.
Cole Medin: So, I'm gonna tell it that now.
Cole Medin: I'm gonna say, copy path. I don't want it to read this file.
Cole Medin: But I wanted to know that, like, this is where I have the environment variable set. So, I have these end bars set in this file. Don't read it, but you can use this.
Cole Medin: So, I'm gonna paste in… so I have the Asana access token.
Cole Medin: I have the Slack bot token, Slack app token. You can ask your coding agent for help for setting up all of these. I have the circle admin token just for all my integrations. I went through the process before this, obviously, to…
Cole Medin: Get all these things set up.
Cole Medin: Boom, circle, community, URL…
Cole Medin: Heartbeat Slack channel, what else do I have here? Just whatever it tells me it needs, right?
Cole Medin: Github token…
Cole Medin: And then, I also have… and then I'm gonna give it the path to the Google credentials.
Cole Medin: And the token here.
Cole Medin: Copy… Copy relative path, paste it.
Cole Medin: Use this for Google.
Cole Medin: Services auth. Alright, there we go.
Cole Medin: So, Justin said, why don't you just let it read the tokens? It has access to the entire file system, so it already has access to the keys, no?
Cole Medin: So it's not actually… Justin, that's a good question, but it's not reading the environment variables by default.
Cole Medin: And we can also block it from ever reading the environment variables, and so, no, we… I don't want it to ever read it. I'm just gonna tell it, like, hey, you have these environment variables in the .env, so you can set up the integration scripts to use these environment variables, but I never want to actually send them into the context window of my agent, because it's going out to a cloud model, and
Cole Medin: Just for security, it's pretty critical, yeah.
Cole Medin: So, alright.
Cole Medin: Very good. And then we did a prime for Phase 5, so I'm gonna say I'm working on Phase 4 in parallel, so now for Phase 5, let's work on the skills here. So according to the PRD, just like we've been doing before, let me know what we should do for Phase 5, and I can even give you some skills, to copy over.
Cole Medin: Because basically, for Phase 5, when we add in the skills.
Cole Medin: It's just gonna be bringing in all the ones that I have for you guys in the reference repo. So this is gonna be very simple to knock out in parallel.
Cole Medin: So while these two are running here, I'm gonna check really quickly on what we were doing for Phase 2, because remember, we were having some issues with Phase 2, where the session end hook was not working. So, wow, it's actually still debugging this here.
Cole Medin: Okay, so it found a bug in the settings.json, and then…
Cole Medin: Okay, so I think it fixed it, actually. Let's take a look. So if we go into our memory here…
Cole Medin: Okay, so… so you're saying, if I start a new conversation.
Cole Medin: and then I talk to Cloud Code, and then I exit the session. Now we're gonna see an update to the daily log folder for today.
Cole Medin: Let's see what it says. I want to make sure we're actually good here.
Cole Medin: Because one thing that's kind of weird is the fact that it didn't actually change anything to this file.
Cole Medin: Let's see, or maybe, I guess maybe it just reverted it because, it was just testing. Let's see, let's see what happens.
Cole Medin: Yes, that's the expectation. Okay, let's try this out.
Cole Medin: So, I'm gonna go into… Another Cloud Code session here.
Cole Medin: And we'll have a little conversation with Claude.
Cole Medin: Wait, hold on.
Cole Medin: Oh.
Cole Medin: It has another error here.
Cole Medin: getting this error when I start a Claude code session. Alright, so we're not quite there yet. We're not quite there yet.
Cole Medin: Well, that's okay. I mean, when I was building the second brain myself, there were definitely a couple of phases that it had to knock out correctly, or that it had to iterate on to knock out correctly. So… okay. The only actual change I made is adding matcher to session end, since the error said hooks was undefined, which means schema requires it. Okay, well, I don't really know how much I trust that here.
Cole Medin: So, we'll try. We'll have a brief conversation with Claude.
Cole Medin: Alright, I want you to search the web for the latest on the Cloud Code leaks.
Cole Medin: Right, so we're just doing, like, a little bit of something here. I want, like, some substance here that would need to be, like, captured as a summary within our…
Cole Medin: daily logs, so let's let it do that, and then we'll end the session, and we'll give it some time for the memory flush to run, and we'll make sure that this file actually gets updated. This is a core part of our second brand, so I want to make sure this is looking good.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: And then, we're still in the planning phase for phase number 4.
Cole Medin: Okay, so plan feature.
Cole Medin: Okay, I'm gonna give you a path to a bunch of skills I want you to bring in. Let's just go ahead and copy in all those skills, instead of creating new custom ones.
Cole Medin: So, one thing that your PRD might do is, like, give you a couple of options for skills based on how you described you want the second brain to work for you. For my case, though, because I'm, like, kind of just showing you guys how I built my exact second brain, I am just going to…
Cole Medin: Copy over the exact skills.
Cole Medin: that I use myself.
Cole Medin: So, I'm gonna say… Look in this path.
Cole Medin: And I want you to bring in all of these skills. The only ones that we're really gonna have to customize here is the, memory search and obsidian Vault Structure skills. All of the other ones are general enough where, like, I can just bring it right here and use it immediately.
Cole Medin: Right? So, I know I'm kind of, like, trumping its planning, and I'm just kind of saying, like, alright, here you go, this is what I want to build right now. And sometimes that's what you gotta do with Cloud Code. Like, you know what you're looking for, and you're like, you know what, like, I appreciate your ideas, but no thank you. Like, these maybe are cool skills, like this one to help me capture and, like, manage my meeting notes. Like, that's actually pretty cool. Maybe you want to build that from the PRD.
Cole Medin: But definitely for the sake of my demonstration here, I just want to bring in the skills
Cole Medin: That I have, in my own, like, second brain that I, like, actually am using.
Cole Medin: Alright, cool. So we'll let that go.
Cole Medin: And, alright, so we did some web research, so we're back to validating Phase 2, so I'm gonna end the session here.
Cole Medin: There we go, so we started… we started… okay, this is actually working now, I think, because now the terminal is kept alive. If you guys remember from earlier, when I ended the session last time, when it didn't work, the terminal popped up, but then it, like, immediately closed down. So now… there we go! Okay, there we go.
Cole Medin: Now we got it. So this is the summary from the conversation we just had, because we asked Claude Code to research recent Cloud Code source code leaks.
Cole Medin: now this has ended up… and the cool part is, we don't just dump the entire conversation, right? Like, we have that background memory flush cloud agent SDK summarize things. So…
Cole Medin: Yes, we still want to do that promotion process to the memory.mb that we'll get to in just a little bit here, but we still want our daily logs to not be, like, super convoluted. Like, just dumping tokens after tokens of tool calls and
Cole Medin: and questions that we're asking it and everything, so it's good that we have something relatively concise. But even… even this is, like, gonna get pretty unruly over time, as you have a lot of Claude Code sessions every single day, so that's why we still need to
Cole Medin: you know, eventually promote the really important stuff to our memory.md file. So that's what we're going to get into in just a second here, after we are done with Phases 4 and 5.
Cole Medin: So…
Cole Medin: Alright, this is working perfectly right now, so go ahead and make a commit. After we're done, we always want to make a commit.
Cole Medin: It's another reason we split things up into phases from the PRB. We want focused work, and we want to commit at each stage, so if anything goes wrong, we can revert to what we had when things were working.
Cole Medin: Cool.
Cole Medin: Alright, so we're still planning Phase 4.
Cole Medin: And then, we are also planning…
Cole Medin: Phase 5, alright. So let's see what questions we got here now.
Cole Medin: Let's see… Tristan asks, is it easy to adjust the proactivity level after more trust is built? Yes, it is. Yep, and this is something I've done myself, where, just going back to our diagram here for the integrations. Like, with my email integration, for example.
Cole Medin: I started by only giving my second brain the ability to read emails. It was not allowed to do any kind of even drafting.
Cole Medin: But then, once I got comfortable with its, like, how it was handling my inbox, I'm like, okay, it really, like, gets me now. I think I can actually trust it to draft emails. All I had to do was tell my second brain, like.
Cole Medin: hey, you're doing a good job with my email, how about you go ahead and make it so that you are able to draft emails as well? So edit the integration so that we add new capability to the email integration.
Cole Medin: And then also change the heartbeat so that every 30 minutes, it drafts emails to anything new that landed in my inbox that doesn't already have a reply or a draft.
Cole Medin: And then also, we can change the sold out MD, because we're kind of giving it that next level of proactivity, right? So we want to, like, describe, like, in its identity, it's gone from being an observer to, like, actually being an advisor, as I put it in the template for the PRD.
Cole Medin: So whenever you want to add that next level proactivity, it's generally, like, you change things in your integration, you change something in your soul.md, and then if it's something that it's kind of, like, doing autonomously, then you'll probably have to change the heartbeat as well.
Cole Medin: Yeah, awesome question.
Cole Medin: Tom asked, do you use any speech-to-text when you talk to your second brain on your phone? I know you like Aquavoice on your Windows machine. So, yeah, I guess I already answered this because someone else asked it, but I'll just say it really quickly again. I just use what's built into my phone, but we… I did just finally hear that,
Cole Medin: Aquavoice has a mobile app, so I will be using that on my phone going forward.
Cole Medin: Smokedad said, I'm assuming we're building the second brain using the piv loop methodology? 100%, we are. Yep, that's what we're seeing here. So, a lot of these questions were asked earlier on, because I kind of have a backlog of questions, so yeah, some of them, I think, have already kind of been answered here.
Cole Medin: But, yeah, alright, so let's go back here, because we now have our plan.
Cole Medin: for both Phase 4 and 5.
Cole Medin: So,
Cole Medin: Cloud Code did this other annoying thing just now, that it sometimes does, where it will go right into plan mode instead of going through my piv loop, where it creates the plan as a markdown document.
Cole Medin: So it's kind of annoying.
Cole Medin: But, you know, I'm just gonna roll with it right now. I could, like, retry and have it, like, write out to a markdown, but whatever. I'm just gonna let it go with this. So, it's going to create…
Cole Medin: The foundations for our integrations here.
Cole Medin: So, Google, Gmail, Asana, Slack, Circle, looking good. The important thing I want to make sure it understands here is that we have the environment variables already set up.
Cole Medin: Okay, it actually knows that, yep. So we have the .cloud slash .env with all credentials already set up.
Cole Medin: So yeah, I'm gonna go ahead and send it off to implementation here.
Cole Medin: I would probably want to iterate on this a little bit more.
Cole Medin: I'm a little bit short on time here.
Cole Medin: Yeah, environment variable… I want to make sure it knows all the environment variables that it has access to. Actually, you know what, I'm gonna iterate once on this. I'm gonna say…
Cole Medin: Okay, you need to call out in this plan ex… the… all of the environment variables it has access to, not just a shortened list, where you have etc. at the end, right? Like, we can't have that.
Cole Medin: Okay, so we'll iterate once, and then we'll go into implementation. I just want to be really careful, because this is something that, coding agents in general just mess up on, is they don't quite…
Cole Medin: they don't do the best with configuration and environment variables, so I want to make sure that's very explicit here.
Cole Medin: Okay.
Cole Medin: And then for Phase 5, adding in our skills, we're copying all 17 skills from the… my other second brain. So, all of these skills, they are available to you guys in the repo that I linked to.
Cole Medin: In the description. So.clawed skills, I'm just gonna bring in all of these. Like, it's super simple, there's not much work that I have to do for this phase, because I'm just gonna bring in all the capabilities that I already use, right? I'm building my full second brain for you guys here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So here are all of our different skills, and then I'm specifying that for these two, specifically, I'm gonna have to customize, right? Like, my memory search that I just built from scratch in Phase 3, that might look a little bit different. So the skill that, you know.
Cole Medin: really tells Claude Code how to search through my memories, and how I want it to, that might need to be different, because the script is built differently.
Cole Medin: And then also for it to understand my Obsidian vault structure, because the name of the vault itself is different. And then the way that you organize your Obsidian Vault might be different as well, so…
Cole Medin: This is actually one of the most important skills for my second brain, because it essentially describes, like, when you're gonna start looking through my Obsidian vault, here's an index of it. Here are the core folders, and how I usually organize my information.
Cole Medin: Alright, cool. Sean said, just getting started with Phase 1. Oh man, I'm sorry that Claude is going slower for you guys, that's a bummer. But yeah, I mean, luckily, this is all recorded for you to go back through it at your own pace. So I totally understand that for a lot of you guys, you might have to do that. But yeah, whatever it takes for you guys to…
Cole Medin: To get through it, the important thing is.
Cole Medin: even if you have to invest quite a bit of time up front building your second brain, it pays dividends so incredibly quickly. Like, I was spending, like, 20, 30 hours a week back in January or February when I just was getting started with it, and it was definitely taking me more time to build it than it actually saved me, but now it is definitely flipped. Like, it's saving me so much time.
Cole Medin: And I am able to…
Cole Medin: To evolve it, like, really quickly now. Like I said, like, what we go through in this workshop, it'll take some time, but we're building the foundation so you can pretty much one-shot everything you want to build on top of it after.
Cole Medin: So, okay, let's go in, and I'm going to start a brand new Cloud Code session. We can see that the end hook started again, so we're going to update our daily logs from that session.
Cole Medin: I'll do slash execute, and then we will execute phase 5.
Cole Medin: There we go, so let's go ahead and bring in the skills.
Cole Medin: And then for phase number 4, it is calling out all the exact environment variables in the .env. And remember, it didn't read it, I just listed it out explicitly in this conversation.
Cole Medin: So, we are good now.
Cole Medin: to, move into creating our integrations. And this will be cool, because after Phase 4 is done, we can have it run these queries. Like, it can search through my recent emails, it can go through my Asana tasks, we'll do a little bit of testing here. Hopefully it doesn't reveal anything too sensitive.
Cole Medin: But, yeah, we'll have it ripped through this as well.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Carson, instead of still waiting for my limit to reset, oh boy, that's a bummer.
Cole Medin: Alright, Claude's doing its stupid glitch again. There we go, bypass permission mode.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool, cool.
Cole Medin: We are off to the races. So… Alright, we got…
Cole Medin: Oh, that's great. Why does it,
Cole Medin: Oh, and this is my old Zapier thing.
Cole Medin: I don't care about this.
Cole Medin: I don't care about… So this key is obviously not in use anymore. I don't care about Zapier.
Cole Medin: get rid of that. I don't know why it's doing… found a real API key. Well, it thinks it's a real API. Well, I mean, I guess it was at one point. Sure, whatever, just get rid of that. I'm not using that anymore.
Cole Medin: I did actually play around with using Zapier as a way to connect to my services at one point.
Cole Medin: And so, I was using this for real at one point, but I just started building my own integrations, like I'm teaching with you guys here. So, yeah, luckily this isn't something I'm actually using. I don't know where that even came from, but I guess that's checked into source control. But it's an exam… or a deleted key, so that's funny, though.
Cole Medin: Alright. Okay, so while this is running here…
Cole Medin: David asks, do you, self-improve skills?
Cole Medin: So, the thing is, David, I don't have my coding agent improve its own skills.
Cole Medin: I go through the process myself.
Cole Medin: Right, like, I talk to Claude, and I say, like, hey, this skill didn't do as good as I wanted to, like, let's have a conversation here about how we can make it better.
Cole Medin: And, then I have it maybe adjust the skill after I, like, approve the change, right? Like, I want to be in the driver's seat when I evolve my skills. You definitely could create a process, like in the daily reflection or something, where it would figure out how to make the skills better, but I don't really have that level of trust yet, you know?
Cole Medin: So, yeah, that's a good question.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Let's see, so next question here…
Cole Medin: Evo asked, how did you generate the ExcalDraw diagram you are showing? It's so elaborate, but well-structured.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so I really just used the Excalodraw diagram skill.
Cole Medin: That I have shared with you guys. Now, obviously, for something as elaborate as this, it took a lot of prompting, and a lot of iteration, so it didn't even close to one-shot this. It took quite a bit of work, but…
Cole Medin: The beauty of the ExcalDraw diagram skill that I have shared with you guys is it also has this whole, like, process of being able to render the diagram, view the PNG, and then, like, figure out discrepancies and iterate on it autonomously.
Cole Medin: And so it is able to, like, improve itself over time. Or, like, evolve the diagram before it comes back to you for feedback.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool, so let me go back to the logs here…
Cole Medin: See where we're at. Oh, it already finished that, wow.
Cole Medin: Okay So, oh yeah, because this is the skills one.
Cole Medin: Yeah, alright, well, those are our skills. I mean, that's phase number 5. It's really, really quick.
Cole Medin: Because we're just bringing in all of our skills here, so now we have everything that you guys can bring in. I mean, I don't really even have to do that much testing for this, because I… I've covered all these… a lot of these skills already, like, we can create PDFs now, we can create remote videos.
Cole Medin: Very cool.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, now we're just on Phase 4 here. Alright, so let me continue with Phase 4.
Cole Medin: Excuse me.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Let me go back to the chat…
Cole Medin: Jeffrey said, I set it up using cursor, and I think it's working now. Thanks so much. Okay, awesome. Glad it's working for you, Jeffrey. Very cool.
Cole Medin: Let's see, SmokeDev said, do you utilize Archon to delegate coding to the second brain?
Cole Medin: it's kind of the opposite, right? Like, I have my second brain delegate the coding to Archon.
Cole Medin: So, in my second brain, I'll show you guys, like, the actual repository.
Cole Medin: It's a little bit of a mess. You'll have to bear with me, because this is the belly of the beast here. This is where I'm working. Let me close out of this here. This is my, like, full repo for my second brain. And,
Cole Medin: within my .cloud skills, I just copied over the Archon skill. So it knows how Archon works, it knows how to invoke workflows.
Cole Medin: And it will, when I want it to, like, you know, handle a GitHub issue or review a pull request, it knows automatically to load the Archon skill and then invoke an Archon workflow. So it's delegating all of the coding tasks to Archon, which is, you know, also using the Cloud Agent SDK, but it has the whole Archon system built around it.
Cole Medin: Alright, very cool. So, yeah, we can see here that Phase 4 is in the middle of implementing, and it's actually testing, like, take a look at that. We are navigating our inbox, so we're able to query our inbox now. Very cool. So now we're just building the Asana integration as well. So it's knocking it out step by step, and it's testing all the integrations as it builds them. Super cool.
Cole Medin: Mike asked, are there any first brain dependencies for the second brain to work?
Cole Medin: You gotta have some comfortability with Claude code, that's about it, honestly. For your first brain.
Cole Medin: And you have to, like, already have, you know, things to integrate with, right? But I assume you already have, like, some kind of task management software, some kind of place to store knowledge.
Cole Medin: I assume that you are asking mostly as a joke, but that is funny, Mike. I wanted to give some kind of answer, though, still.
Cole Medin: Okay, cool. So, by the way, guys, we are done with Phase 5 now.
Cole Medin: Because, there was not much work that had to be done here. Like, obviously, we had to do a little bit of customization for the Obsidian vault structure, so we have the Dynamist workshop slash memory, and then it just outlines, like, here are all the core files that we have here. And if you guys are using Obsidian to do a lot more than just the second brain memory.
Cole Medin: like I showed with my vault, there's a lot of other things I'm storing for
Cole Medin: content ideation and my diagrams and everything, well, then you can have your second brain update the Obsidian Vault. Like, every once in a while, what I'll do is I'll tell my second brain to analyze all the folders in my vault.
Cole Medin: and then make sure that this skill is up to date, right? So, sometimes you'll just have a task every once in a while where you just want to, like, make sure that the system is up to date. That's just one example of that.
Cole Medin: Cool.
Cole Medin: Rasmus said, my brain just, slain… I don't know what slain… I assume that's a typo. Labeled 2,000 unread emails in my personal email, and unsubscribed to 100 plus newsletters. I hope that was intentional, Rasmus, but if it was, that's very cool.
Cole Medin: Oh, wow.
Cole Medin: 2.30am here in Thailand, my brain has stopped working. That is pretty late, or early, I should say.
Cole Medin: Jay said, you said Obsidian is private, but isn't open source, which seems, oxymoronic. Any actual open source recommendations versus Obsidian?
Cole Medin: Yeah, I don't know of… I mean, there are quite a few things out there, but it slips my mind specific names of them right now.
Cole Medin: But there are a lot of, like, actual open source options. But when you install and run Obsidian, like, it is 100% local. It's just, like, the source code isn't on GitHub, you know?
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So yeah, anyway, let's, open back up, see where we're at with module, or with phase number 4.
Cole Medin: We're almost there, so we're just building the circle integration, then we have to document things like our claw.md, because remember, our global rules is where I store commands, right? Like, here's how we search, here's how we index our memory into our database.
Cole Medin: Okay.
Cole Medin: Oh yeah, it has to figure out… okay, this is something that I've noticed before. It doesn't realize that Circle has migrated to a version 2.
Cole Medin: Let's see, yeah. So, Circle has actually migrated to a V2. I know my API keys are valid, so this is just a problem. You have to figure out the right, documentation for Circle.
Cole Medin: So it's just, like, a little blip there, but anyway, I'm gonna start the other Cloud Code sessions to get ready for our next builds here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Yeah, Jay, I thought that Obsidian was open source, but I found out pretty recently that it's not actually.
Cole Medin: I did think it was, though, too.
Cole Medin: Okay, so what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna prime.
Cole Medin: I'm gonna get everything primed, ready to, go into the next phases. So, we'll… we got… we got time still, so I'm gonna let it… I'm gonna let it finish the phase 4.
Cole Medin: And we'll do a little bit of validation as well. So we've got the skills done already.
Cole Medin: We've done everything with our core memory layer and hooks and our memory search pipelines, so we're making really good progress. We're in the middle of adding in our direct integrations. That is almost done now. And we'll just do, like, a little bit of validation to make sure I can, like, find my tasks in Asana and things like that.
Cole Medin: We'll make sure that everything's documented so our second brain knows how to leverage these things when we want it to. You know, like, what tasks do I have? That question should directly translate it to doing a search in Asana, so we'll make sure that's the case as well.
Cole Medin: And then we will get into the heartbeat, daily reflection, and the Slack chat interface. So we'll try to knock all of this out.
Cole Medin: In parallel here, because both the daily reflection and heartbeat is actually Module 6, so there's just, like, a little bit of a mislabeling in the diagram here. I'll have to correct that, but yeah, alright.
Cole Medin: So, we're doing a prime here… okay, so, good. Yeah, while this keeps running, I'm gonna go ahead and answer some more questions here.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so 30 minutes left. We're gonna be on grind time here for the last part of this. I might have to go a little bit over, just because I want to make sure I have time for you guys' questions, and we'll have to make sure that we don't rush too fast with these things.
Cole Medin: But, definitely when I have the edited version of the course out, like, it's gonna… I'm gonna be able to cut out quite a bit and make it really nice and concise, because we'll cut out, like, when we're waiting for the agent to finish coding and things like that.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Bob said, Claude says that vector tied to Obsidian speeds things up a lot. That's why we're doing it. Yep, everything local Markdown in Obsidian with the SQLite vector database, it is blazing fast.
Cole Medin: Let's see, Sean said…
Cole Medin: since you are using Obsidian, can you suggest how we can diverge and use Agentic reg? I thought I already answered that, Sean. I already answered that question earlier, so for the sake of time, I'll move on here, because I talked about Agentic Reg and how we're doing hybrid search.
Cole Medin: I answered your question specifically, and then… Oh, I haven't, okay.
Cole Medin: Boy, that's so weird, I don't know why this is popping up now, because I've already answered all these questions.
Cole Medin: Yeah, okay, so all three of those, Shauna, have already answered, so I assume that you just sent that earlier on or something, I'm not really sure what happened.
Cole Medin: Okay.
Cole Medin: Let's see, so Pat said, how would you approach this if we had started with the second brain from some of the previous trainings and want to improve it?
Cole Medin: Yeah, that's a good question, Pat. So, if you already have something built off of other workshops that we've done in Dynamis, or you're following along with OpenClaw running that or something, and you want to improve what you have, then all I would recommend doing
Cole Medin: Is pointing your coding agent, or your second brain, to this repository.
Cole Medin: The one that I have linked in the description. Just point it there, and say, hey, I want you to spin up sub-agents to research this codebase, and also research my second brain, and see if there's any good ideas that we could pick out from Cole's second brain.
Cole Medin: So you can let the coding agent guide that entire conversation.
Cole Medin: Yep.
Cole Medin: Cool.
Cole Medin: So, alright, let me go back…
Cole Medin: See how far we are… okay.
Cole Medin: Phase 4 is complete. We have Gmail, Asana, Slack, and Circle.
Cole Medin: All the integration files that it created.
Cole Medin: Okay, very good, good, good. So let's go ahead and test this now. So I'm gonna open up a new conversation.
Cole Medin: I'll actually just do it right here.
Cole Medin: So I'll open up a brand new conversation, and I'll say…
Cole Medin: What tasks do I have in Asana? Or, okay, here, actually, I'm gonna redo that, because I'm not even going to say Asana. I want to prove to you that it already has the understanding that, like, when I'm saying tasks, I am talking about Asana.
Cole Medin: What tasks do I have due next week?
Cole Medin: Right? Like, super simple question. Like, we want to be able to just ask basic questions to our second brain, and it should automatically know, like, here are the integrations, here's the process, here are the commands that I run. Like, this should just all be super automatic. That's the goal of the second brain. It needs to feel like it knows us.
Cole Medin: And, like, that's a cool demonstration of this. It's pretty sweet. Like, even though we've just got started building our second brain, this is already a nice and simple example of, like, it gets us, right? Like, it knows how to search, it knows I'm using Asana, I didn't have to say anything.
Cole Medin: So now it's just, ripping through a ton of different tasks here. I guess I'm giving you guys, like, a little bit insight into what I got going on here, because it's just showing everything. But that's why I picked Asana, because I don't really mind that. I mean, it might be a little bit weirder if I did, like, my inbox or something.
Cole Medin: But this is definitely good, so…
Cole Medin: Unfortunately, your taunt tasks don't appear to have explicit due dates. Well, yeah, I mean, that's just how I have things set up here, but…
Cole Medin: Anyway, you can see here, like, for example, I got my Archon video going out on Wednesday, so…
Cole Medin: There we go, that's what's going on. So just a quick little example there, and then if I were to, you know, close my session here, now we've got the Cloud Agent SDK.
Cole Medin: popped up doing the summarization to put into our daily logs. So every single conversation, all of the different components of our second brain are coming together very, very nicely here.
Cole Medin: So, let's go ahead and close this out.
Cole Medin: And, now we are ready to move on to our next phases here.
Cole Medin: Karsten said, wait, something clicked. Aha! I can also integrate the company Jira to my second brain and use that as to-dos as well. And yes, that is 100% right, Karsten. Love that. Yeah, yeah. So I don't use Jira myself, but you definitely could, like, I mean, I just use Asana instead, right? But yeah, certainly a company Jira would be fantastic.
Cole Medin: Do you have your second brain help you manage the things that are due for you there?
Cole Medin: Yeah, alright.
Cole Medin: Cool. So, we have primed, we have now finished with our integrations.
Cole Medin: And our skills.
Cole Medin: And we are now blazing on over to our heartbeat.
Cole Medin: Daily Reflection and chat interface.
Cole Medin: So, here's what we're gonna do. I'm gonna try to go through this pretty quickly, so we can end decently on time here. So, I'm gonna say…
Cole Medin: Alright, let's go on to Phase 6. Let's create the proactive systems with the heartbeat and reflection. So, take a look at the PRD, and let me know what we need to build based on what's laid out there. Alright, again, maybe not the most elaborate prompt, but it's all good. Alright, and then for the next one here.
Cole Medin: I'm actually building Phase 6 in parallel in a separate session, so I want to move on to Phase Number 7. We're going to create Slack as my way to talk remotely to my second brain. So I want you to analyze the PRD, let me know what we should build for my second brain.
Cole Medin: Also, keep in mind that, in my, environment variable, so I'm gonna give you the path to the .env again.
Cole Medin: I'll copy this path.
Cole Medin: And send that into the prompt as well.
Cole Medin: I already have… the environment variables set up for my Slack bot that I have created.
Cole Medin: And so I have, the two environment variable names that I'll paste at the start of the prompt. I have these set up already, so we're good to go. We have the bot already set up.
Cole Medin: And, it's already installed in my Slack workspace as well.
Cole Medin: So, it's actually quite nice that I already have this set up, because that way I don't have to spend time doing all of that. Just know that, like, setting up Slack in particular is a little bit tricky sometimes, but Claude Code knows how to walk you through it exactly.
Cole Medin: Like, I had to do no research myself, I just said, like, hey, let me know the permissions, let me know how I can enable socket mode for security and things like that, and it just, like, walked me through it all. It was so good. And also, it's good that I don't have to go through that, because…
Cole Medin: you guys might not be using Slack anyway, right? Like, a different platform, so I don't want to spend too much time setting up a very specific platform that might not be a part of your second brain, so…
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So here we go, this is what we're going to be building for Phase 6, our proactive system. So we have the heartbeat, this is what's going to run every 30 minutes during our active hours. That's going to use no large language models. So for token efficiency's sake, we're going to gather data from our different APIs.
Cole Medin: So this is where we are connecting the integrations with our heartbeat. So we're talking about this step right here. Gather information, then send it into the Claude Agent SDK.
Cole Medin: So the agent SDK reasons, and then we, can optionally send a Slack channel post. And this is where I typically am reviewing my notifications from my second brain that, every half hour when it alerts me of things that need my attention.
Cole Medin: Alright, and then we're preventing it from editing sold on MD. This is a file that I really want to protect. I don't want it to self-evolve this file, so I've actually explicitly… I'm going to be explicitly blocking the heartbeat from editing it by itself.
Cole Medin: So, just an example of how we want to have certain parts of the brain protected from the agent changing. So, I know we've talked a lot about having the agent self-evolve itself and its skills. You can add that if you want, but a lot of those things, I'll, like, purposely prevent it from changing.
Cole Medin: Alright, so, yeah, this is looking good to me, so I'm gonna, of course, just do my plan feature.
Cole Medin: This all looks great, let's go ahead and create the structure plan for Phase 6.
Cole Medin: And boom, there we go, send it in.
Cole Medin: And let's see what we got here. Alright, good, so…
Cole Medin: Here's a full picture for Phase 7 with our chat interface.
Cole Medin: We are creating our bot. This is the adapter, so this is where you receive messages from Slack.
Cole Medin: And, then we're using socket mode, so there's no public URL. This is actually something very important that I've set up for Slack.
Cole Medin: The bot connects Outpound to Slack via webhooks, so there is nothing that… there's no public URL that can be attacked. That's one of the big things that we've seen with OpenClaw.
Cole Medin: It's gonna listen for direct messages, and whenever we mention the bot in a channel, each Slack thread, this is important, each Slack thread maps to one agent SDK conversation. The key of the conversation is the Slack thread ID, so that way we have conversation history in each of our Slack threads.
Cole Medin: So we can continue the conversation, and the kicker is, even have parallel conversations with our second brain remotely, because we can have multiple threads going on at the exact same time.
Cole Medin: kind of like I showed you guys at the start of our workshop here, like, this is our… this is my actual Slack channel where I talk to my second brain. I have all these conversations going on in parallel, or at least I can. I mean, this is just, like.
Cole Medin: Kind of an archive, but you get the idea there.
Cole Medin: Alright, so…
Cole Medin: I think this is actually great. So I'm gonna do… go ahead and do… alright, this is good, let's go ahead and create the structure plan for Phase 7.
Cole Medin: And send that off.
Cole Medin: All right. Renata said, I'm loving it, but I have to tell you, it is not easy to do that from a 20-minute YouTube video. I know, I understand, the YouTube video is just an overview. Good that we have this kind of workshop. The Dynamis membership is really worth on value. I appreciate it a lot, Renata. Yeah, I'm glad you guys are getting a lot out of this workshop, and
Cole Medin: One other thing that I wanted to say is, I just want to acknowledge again, like, I understand, like, even for 4 hours, this is a lot that we're doing here.
Cole Medin: So you guys are totally good. If there's… if there's still questions coming up in your mind, I… I really want, honestly, like, the whole month of April to be focused on, like.
Cole Medin: let's get questions from you guys. Like, I want you to DM me, I want you to make posts in our community, attend office hour sessions, like, ask away for anything that's not super clear to you here.
Cole Medin: Any questions you have around building it more for yourself and how to customize it more, like, I'm open to all of your guys' questions.
Cole Medin: And so, I have full expectation that, like, there's gonna be a barrage of questions. Like, I'm ready for it, guys. I wanna help you build your second brain. Like, I'm really passionate about this because it's crazy how much time it saves me.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, I'm there for you guys, and I hope that this, like, even though I'm going, like, kind of quick here, even for 4 hours.
Cole Medin: I hope that you're getting a lot of golden nuggets out of this, and of course, like I said, I'll edit this down into the course material that'll be quicker to go through, and you can pause along the way, so even if it's, like, you're here absorbing things as much as possible, and then you refine your understanding with the course after, I think that'd be a great way to do it as well.
Cole Medin: Yeah, Renata said, I cannot do it now, I'll have to do it on my own time, start little by little, and that's totally fair, I love that, yeah. This is something we can even do for customers. Consultation for customers that want this kind of work. Oh yeah, let me tell you, in the next 5-10 years, there is no way that most companies
Cole Medin: won't have something like this for all their employees, because it would just be way too much of a loss if they don't.
Cole Medin: Yeah.
Cole Medin: Pat said we're gonna need a couple of second-brain AMA sessions. You know what? I might do that. So, last week, I dedicated a couple of our Dynamis sessions to…
Cole Medin: Archon AMA sessions.
Cole Medin: So, doing the exact same thing next week for our second brain, I actually really like that idea. So, thank you for bringing that up, Pat.
Cole Medin: Because, yeah, like I said, I totally expect you guys to have a lot of questions, because I'm breaking things down as nice and simply as I possibly can, but there's still a lot. I totally… I'm totally acknowledging that.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so Will's asked, is there a special section to ask these questions in the community?
Cole Medin: So, you know, there isn't right now, but that is also a really good suggestion.
Cole Medin: So I could create, specifically, like, a second brain section of the community, and then also do some AMA sessions next week, and maybe even the week after as well, because I want to give a lot of time for you guys to ask what you need.
Cole Medin: So yeah, okay, yeah, thank you guys for the suggestions. I'm definitely gonna, well, I mean, my workday is pretty much gonna be done after this. I mean, this is also a lot for me, but yeah, tomorrow I'd love to get that set up, and I'll get some AMAs scheduled here.
Cole Medin: Omar said, Microsoft will probably add a second brain copilot feature that will miss the mark on everything it should actually be.
Cole Medin: It needs to achieve the first brains, Jay said, that's hilarious. You guys are too funny. I mean, I'm not disagreeing.
Cole Medin: Well, I mean, the problem is, anything that produces a… like, any kind of platform that builds a second brain, it's never going to be everything you quite need. Like, open claw, or like Claude Code, building all these features in that, like, kind of makes it a second brain. It's always going to be more powerful to build it yourself, and that's why we're covering it in this workshop.
Cole Medin: David said, a demo of you using the second brain. That could be a good session as well. Yeah, like, kind of getting into the nitty-gritty of, like, how I'm actually using it on the day-to-day. Yeah, yeah, okay, wow, you guys are giving really good, suggestions now, thank you.
Cole Medin: Pat said, would you be so kind to update the diagrams as the ones you were showing are slightly different from what is in the repo? I didn't actually know that. I'll take a look. Yeah, yeah. Okay.
Cole Medin: Alright, cool, so…
Cole Medin: Alright, it's writing the plan for Phase 6, and then it is, yeah, okay, writing the plan for Phase 7 as well. Okay, so we're almost there for the implementation for Phases 6 and 7.
Cole Medin: Okay. Actually, yeah, plan for Phase 7 is done.
Cole Medin: Good, good. So let's take a look at this.
Cole Medin: I want to build a Slack bot, so I can talk to it in Slack, DM, or at mention. Looks good.
Cole Medin: So, okay, see, this is another cool thing. It's easier for the second brain to build on itself over time, because we can look at the memory flush.
Cole Medin: to have an example of how we're already using the Agent SDK. We have a tried and true usage of the agent SDK already, so now we can build on top of it. This is a clear example.
Cole Medin: of one of the most important things I'm sharing with you guys today, every single time we build on top of the second brain, it's easier than the last, because we can reference existing implementations.
Cole Medin: We got our environment variables all good to go.
Cole Medin: And, we got the task list here, everything we're gonna implement. We have our testing strategy as well.
Cole Medin: Okay, so we're gonna make sure the bot can reply to itself.
Cole Medin: Or no, that it probably doesn't. Yes, we don't want it to reply to itself. We're testing all the edge cases here. Okay, that looks good. Good, good. Cool. So, I'm gonna go into a brand new session here.
Cole Medin: And then we'll do slash execute, give it the path to the plan… alright, there we go. So we're off to the races, setting up Slack.
Cole Medin: Dom, Phase 4 was implemented. We took care of Phase 4 with the integrations, because remember, I gave the example where I searched through my Asana tasks, so we're able to connect to all of our services now, and then the heartbeat is going to take advantage… so actually, Phase 6 is reliant on
Cole Medin: Phase 4, because our heartbeat is going to pull data from our email in Asana and things like that.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool. So, Phase 6 is done as well, so let's take a look at the plan for this.
Cole Medin: Let's see, so proactive system, heartbeat and reflection. So we're gonna have scheduled proactive systems that monitor our integrations, that's why I just said it's, dependent on Phase 4 being done. Generate draft replies, track habits, curate memory, notify Cole of urgent items in Slack.
Cole Medin: So, advisor mode, right? Like, that's the core of our sold on MD. Draft but never send.
Cole Medin: Alright, very good.
Cole Medin: And then we also have the memory reflection, so this is… we read yesterday's daily log, promote key items to the memory.md, and trim if it's over 200 lines. So this is the whole promotion process, which… I don't want you to forget that, because that… this is, like, just one part of our Phase 6, but this is one of the most important parts of the system. So I want to call it out that that's what we're working on right here.
Cole Medin: the whole promotion process that I covered, in this part of our diagram right here. This is the daily reflection that we run once a day. So, alright, this is all looking really good. So, we got our implementation plan.
Cole Medin: For our self-validation here.
Cole Medin: And by the way, usually I would iterate on these plans more. Like, the self-validation isn't, like, the most ideal from what I've seen in some of the prior phases, but it's good enough for what we need for a demo right now. Like, obviously, everything's been building pretty good. We only had that one hiccup in Phase 2.
Cole Medin: So, we're gonna validate our hooks, we're gonna do a dry run of the heartbeat, so this is really important. Hopefully your PRD understands that we want to build a dry run for the heartbeat and the memory reflects, so that way we can quickly test things without having to run, like, the entire process.
Cole Medin: Or, like, post notifications to Slack. So, we're also… but, like, in this case, because we're just building it for the first time, we're also going to do a full run. So we're going to promote things to our memory.md and run the heartbeat.
Cole Medin: And so, let's actually go in our Obsidian Vault really quickly here, because I want to show… I wanna show that once we implement this, we're gonna see the memory.md grow for the first time.
Cole Medin: So we have our key decisions, important facts, like, okay, take a look at this. Take, like, a snapshot in your mind of what our memory.md looks like right now.
Cole Medin: Because we're gonna see it get decently longer after we implement Phase 6, because it's gonna actually, like, take a look at our logs, so…
Cole Medin: We have our daily logs, and by the way, this is growing quite a bit, because we've been building on top of our second brain over time, right? It's remembering all these things from past sessions, here are the lessons that we've learned, so this is good, but now we need to take only the most important stuff from this and put it in the memory.md, so we'll see it added here after.
Cole Medin: So, I'm gonna go ahead and start a new session here.
Cole Medin: And then I will do slash execute, and then give it the path to phase 6.
Cole Medin: And there we go, we're off to the races!
Cole Medin: And, oh, dang. Well, of course, it asked for permission, so we haven't moved too far in Phase 7 either, but we'll let these implement at the same time here.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, we're definitely gonna go a little bit over for the workshop.
Cole Medin: I totally understand if, like, if you guys blocked out just 4 hours of your day and you have to drop, but I do want to make sure that I get through everything here. So, luckily, we're gonna be pretty much wrapped up with, Phases 6 and 7 by the 4-hour mark, so it's really gonna only be, like, the last module.
Cole Medin: That I'm gonna have to go over with. And then again, once I have the edited version for the course, it's… it's gonna be way less than 4 hours, actually. So, if you want to review things after, go through the recording, or wait for the edited version of the course.
Cole Medin: To go through the last modules if you don't have time now, you definitely can. So, the only thing that I'm gonna go over time to…
Cole Medin: You see my Google credentials in green, don't push them to GitHub. Yeah, thanks, Dragos. I will make sure that that is get ignored.
Cole Medin: Yes. Well, this whole repo, I'm gonna actually, like, not push.
Cole Medin: Or I'll just wipe the history before I push.
Cole Medin: But yeah, thank you. Make sure that we have that covered there. So yeah, make sure before you push anything, if you have any kind of credential files like this, it should be in the gitignore. Not okay to push that ever.
Cole Medin: It's all… it's all testing accounts anyway, so it's not a big deal.
Cole Medin: John said, one more try, is this the starting point?
Cole Medin: John, that looks like a really good starting point.
Cole Medin: Yep, you got all the commands, you have the skill… yeah, yeah, that's perfect. Yep.
Cole Medin: Beautiful. I'll give a nice heart on that there, looks good, or a party popper emoji. Alright, cool, yeah, so one thing I was going back to saying here.
Cole Medin: We will have literally everything in this diagram implemented today in the 4 hours, except for the last part here with the security layer and infrastructure. So this is the one thing that I'll go a little bit over time to make sure we cover here.
Cole Medin: And it'll be the last module for the course. But, pretty soon here, we'll have the daily reflection, Heartbeat, and chat interface done, and we can validate it after.
Cole Medin: Let's see, how far has it come along now? Oh, it's almost done! Okay, so we get to test Slack pretty soon here.
Cole Medin: And then for the heartbeat system, it's lagging a little bit behind. So we'll test out Slack, and then hopefully that gives it time for this to finish, and then we can test out our daily reflection and heartbeat.
Cole Medin: And luckily, it'll be pretty easy to test, because we'll just see.
Cole Medin: like, what happens, when the memory.md grows. Like, we should watch this grow in the middle of it doing its own validation, and that'll be kind of the confidence that we need. Okay, so very good. So it created the Slack adapter, it's saying that all we have to do is start the bot, and then we can DM it.
Cole Medin: So, actually, what I'm gonna do is say, I actually want you to run the bot yourself. So run it for me, and then I'll go ahead and test it.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: It's gonna be pretty cool to see, like, how quickly this comes together. We're already gonna be able to talk to it in Slack, so it's gonna run it as a background task.
Cole Medin: Bot is starting out, let me check initial output, make sure connected. Okay, yeah, bot is live and connected in Slack, go ahead and test it and send a DM or mention it in a channel.
Cole Medin: Alright, so here we go, moment of truth.
Cole Medin: So, I am using the same Slack bot that I used in my dry run. So, what you're looking at right here, all of this, like, log output.
Cole Medin: This is just from some testing that I was doing earlier.
Cole Medin: But, I had this running on a DigitalOcean instance that I tore down. So now the only instance of our bot running is what we just started with Claude. So now we're gonna see if our current implementation
Cole Medin: is working. So I'm gonna send in a message.
Cole Medin: Let's see, alright, I said hi. Hey, there we go, look at that!
Cole Medin: So, it says that it's currently thinking, and there we go. Hey, Cole, what's up? How can I help you today? So, what else can we do? I could say, give me the… or…
Cole Medin: What is the latest post in the community?
Cole Medin: Right? And then we can even do, like, another message, like, what is the next task that I have?
Cole Medin: Oh, whoops, I forgot to mention it. So, when you're not DMing it, you have to mention it, or, like, that's how it's set up in my PRD, so I'll say, what is the latest post in the community?
Cole Medin: And then we can test, like, the parallel nature of it right now as well. So I can, in another… I can start another thread here and say, you know, what is the next task that I have due, right? So we can see that they'll both operate at the exact same time here. We can switch between threads, and I can do everything from my phone as well.
Cole Medin: So there we go.
Cole Medin: Alright, the latest post in the community is Code Deep Wiring Reference. Let's see if that's actually true. So, I'll go over here, go to the feed for Dynamis, and there we go! John posted code deep wiring reference. Awesome! Alright, so good, we got our circle integration tested, all from Slack as well. We can continue the conversation, so I can say, like, for example, you know, what did I just say, so we can make sure that
Cole Medin: conversation history with the Cloud Agent SDK is really being managed properly.
Cole Medin: On the thread level. We can check our other response as well. My next task due is, you know, the one that I'm working on right now. Second brain for our workshop, very cool.
Cole Medin: And then we'll get our response here. You just asked, what is the latest post in the community? I pulled circle posts and showed you the top 5.
Cole Medin: With, the code, deep wiring reference, and take a look at this, we even have links to all of them as well, so it even pulls the full links that it got from the API as well. So, now everything is, like, really starting to come together, because we've got the session hook.
Cole Medin: loading it up with information so it knows how to use my integrations. We're able to use the integration, do it remotely, I could talk to it from my phone as well. Like, you can start to see how it's like, every single time I talk to it, I'm demoing, like, everything that we got here.
Cole Medin: So, pretty cool. All right. Let's go back and see where we're at with phase number 6 now.
Cole Medin: So, Slack is done. Like, we validated that already. Oh, of course it got stuck again.
Cole Medin: All right, well yeah, so Phase 7 is done. I mean, that's all we need, right? And the other thing I'll say is that I'm not running the bot on Slack on my computer, I'm hosting that in the VPS. That's one of the last things I'll show with you guys with the little bit of overtime that I want to give for our workshop here.
Cole Medin: I'm just, like, right now, looking on my phone at the alerts that I'm getting from my real second brain that I actually have running. Cool. Alright, so we'll let this go.
Cole Medin: maybe what we'll do here, I'll tell it to, like.
Cole Medin: Alright, Slack is working great, go ahead and make a commit.
Cole Medin: And, yeah, the other thing is, like, I'm gonna leave this session up, because it's running the Slack bot, so I'll just let that go.
Cole Medin: So, let's go ahead and start a couple of the new Cloud Code sessions, so we can get ready to implement the security and the VPS deployment stuff. That's all we're gonna need. So, I'll run the Prime twice here.
Cole Medin: To get things ready for that. Alright, let's see where we're at with, okay.
Cole Medin: So it's, building the heartbeat right now for phase number 6.
Cole Medin: Friends don't let devs push secrets and keys. GitLeaks detect secrets or truffle hog. It's funny, Mike.
Cole Medin: Alright, cool, so while we wait for this to run, I'm gonna go through some of your guys' questions here.
Cole Medin: Okay, so Locke said, how can we capture and organize knowledge into a second brain system as a natural byproduct of working on a software project? How can we keep a second brain and codebase project in sync, feeding each other continuously?
Cole Medin: Yeah, lock. So, my recommendation there is, when you're doing coding, and you want your second brain to remember the work that you're doing, I would just open up your Cloud code in your second brain repo.
Cole Medin: So, you would actually use your second brain to work on the codebase. So, you talk to your second brain, but you give it the path.
Cole Medin: or the GitHub repo for your codebase. And then you just tell it to, you know, work on it there.
Cole Medin: So that way, as it's making changes, you know, we have this whole, like, memory flush system that I've been demoing for you guys, where we've seen the daily log build over time. It'll remember the things that you're doing in the Cloud code sessions working on your codebase, so it's gonna remember how you're building your codebase over time.
Cole Medin: And then, when we… let me pull up the vault again.
Cole Medin: Then when, when you, you know, promote things into your memory.md, with the whole thing that we're building right now with Phase 6, then all the key decisions around, like, the, big things that you're building into your codebase, and the issues that you're fixing, like, all of that really important stuff will be logged here to the memory.md.
Cole Medin: So your second brain is going to constantly remember how your codebase is evolving over time. So that'd be… that'd be how you'd kind of keep them in sync.
Cole Medin: Renato said, wow, just awesome, I appreciate it. Jeffrey said, this is awesome. I think we need to… I need to rewatch this. Yeah, I totally understand. I'm glad you like it, and I appreciate you being willing to, like, go through this again to really digest everything, because I know there is a good amount that we got here, but yeah, just… I want to give it all away to you guys. That's what I'm doing here.
Cole Medin: Yeah, sounds good, David.
Cole Medin: Alright, Chris said, so init git is not a good idea for privacy.
Cole Medin: So the important thing is, Chris, there is a difference between Git and GitHub. GitHub is your cloud hosting of your repo, but Git is just all local, so you can initialize a Git repo, even if you want it to be 100% local, because that just runs on your system.
Cole Medin: So I did initialize it as a Git repo.
Cole Medin: Alright, Benjamin said, on to Phase 5? I mean, you're getting there. Like, I'm going decently fast because I have to, but, like, getting up to Phase 5 already is pretty awesome.
Cole Medin: Would local AI be capable to do it? You can definitely use local AI for the second brain. It's not going to be quite as good as using something like Opus. Like, I use Opus for my second brain.
Cole Medin: But certainly, like, if you're using a more powerful local model, like, at least 32 billion parameters, I'd say, like the new Gemma 431B would probably be my recommendation if you want a smaller model to run for your second brain. It'll still be impressive.
Cole Medin: Yeah. And, Carson, I won't skip Vault Sync, that'll be, when I'm doing the infrastructure part of the last phase.
Cole Medin: Alright. Cool.
Cole Medin: So, let's go back here. Okay, it says the heartbeat is run.
Cole Medin: Very good. Okay, alright, we're done with Phase 6. Let's make sure it's good.
Cole Medin: Okay, so it made sure the soul.md edit was blocked, and… we…
Cole Medin: Okay, so did you actually run a full heartbeat and reflection, not just the dry run? Or is the dry run all we need to do here to validate everything? Because it says that it ran the heartbeat, it gathered 68 items across Gmail, Asana, Slack, and Circle.
Cole Medin: And then, so that, like, that's actually good, like, we sent that in to the Cloud Agent SDK, that's actually great.
Cole Medin: And then for the reflection, it found today's log.
Cole Medin: Wow. Look at… just during our workshop, it got up to almost 8,000 characters.
Cole Medin: The dry run only validates data gathering basic flow. Oh, okay, they skipped the agent SDK reasoning. Got it, got it. Okay, so yeah, we need to make sure we actually run these end-to-end. So, and it even found a bug when it did that. So, actually, Claude Code got a little bit lazy with the validation here.
Cole Medin: Because we specifically told it to run the entire thing.
Cole Medin: Oh, no, never mind, that is my bad. It says manual here, so I didn't catch this. I probably should have updated the plan to say, like, no, you can actually do it yourself, but that's all good, because now we're doing it. Now we're running it.
Cole Medin: Okay.
Cole Medin: So we'll let it continue to rip through this here. And so, in a little bit here, we should see the full reflection. We'll see the update to our memory.md, so it'll capture all the important stuff from our conversations with it today.
Cole Medin: Alright, so David asks, do we open a specific folder as a vault in Obsidian? Is it the root of our second brain, or the subfolder? Yeah, good question. It will be the subfolder. So if you go through the full PRD process, like I'm doing in our workshop here, it'll be, like, this folder that has the memory one within it.
Cole Medin: Like, I… in my template, I specifically called it dynamis-workshop. Whatever name you gave, you'll have that subfolder. This is where you'll open, the folder as an Obsidian vault. And then it'll automatically create the .obsidian file here, that's… or folder, that's how you know that you have it set up as an Obsidian vault.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Yeah, okay, so it's, running the heartbeat from scratch, this is good. Alright, good, good.
Cole Medin: Scott said, doesn't need to be there. I mean, if you're not using Obsidian, it doesn't have to be there.
Cole Medin: Or, oh, sorry, no, okay, even if you are using Obsidian, you could have it go somewhere else on your computer. Like, you could point… as long as, your second brain has the full path to it.
Cole Medin: like, it's just kind of convenient to have the vault right here within my, second brain repository, but if you want to have it somewhere else in the claw.md, say, like, you know, like, here's the full path to the Obsidian vault, or you could even put that in, like, your soul.md or user.md, you can definitely do that as well. Yeah, yeah, it's totally good.
Cole Medin: Obsidian does not seem to like WSL paths, we'll have to install it to WSL. Oh, that's good to know, I didn't… I didn't know that. Rather than browsing into WSL from Windows, yeah, exactly, yep.
Cole Medin: Right, of course, yeah, exactly, Scott. So if you already have Obsidian Vault stored somewhere else, and you want your second brain one to be there as well, that works 100%. Yeah, this is just a convenience thing for me, to have it here.
Cole Medin: Oh, Erasmus says, this works beautifully, Cole, awesome, now a brain believer. I appreciate it, Rasmus. Yeah, and also that reminds me, I saw your question from above, which, by the way, guys, like, there's so many awesome questions you guys have, I wish I had time to go through everything.
Cole Medin: Yeah, Rasmus, your question of if you could skip rag, you definitely can. I mean, I find it's pretty effective, but if you want to just do, like, regular expression, blob, keyword search for your daily logs, you certainly could.
Cole Medin: But, I found… I found it to be very effective, and it's simple to set up. So I would… I would recommend Phase 3, like, I have it here for a reason.
Cole Medin: But if you're not a believer in RAG, you just want Cloud Code to search how Claude Code searches, it's not… or sorry, not this whole thing, just this part, this part with the memory search pipeline is optional if you really don't want to have RAG, but I find it effective.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool. Regarding Obsidian, how do you integrate the Vault?
Cole Medin: So, that's the beauty… I keep saying the beauty of this workshop. That's the beauty of Obsidian, is you don't really have to have an integration.
Cole Medin: Because your vault is just markdown documents in your file system.
Cole Medin: And so that's… that's how Claude Code works natively as well. So, this is my vault. Just open up in my BS code right here. That's all it is. There isn't any kind of MCP server that I need. It can just access the files directly.
Cole Medin: There are Obsidian MCP servers that give it more fancy search capabilities, but we're building that ourself anyway, so there's no integration that I'm really doing.
Cole Medin: My current vault width context?
Cole Medin: So, I mean, maybe more what you're getting at is I have this skill.
Cole Medin: That describes the structure of my vault, so that way it knows, kind of, like, how to search, and it has, like, context of my specific vault.
Cole Medin: I guess that's kind of the only, like, integration that I have, is, like, here's the skill to read when you want to understand how to go through the structure and, like, search through my vault.
Cole Medin: Yeah, Jeffrey said, okay, I appreciate this, Jeffrey, because maybe that's the confusion. Don't be confused by the term Vault, it's simply the name of the folder structure in Obsidian. It's just a way to organize your files, not a password-protected file.
Cole Medin: John said, no, I have my own vault, I want to use it. Oh, okay, got it, got it. Yeah, John, if you want to use your own vault.
Cole Medin: Like, let me… Open this up here. Like.
Cole Medin: I had an Obsidian Vault before I added my second brain.
Cole Medin: So my second brain is really… it's, like, really only the memory folder that I added in. Everything else I've been using before I even created a second brain, because I've been using Obsidian since last year, and I've only been building my second brain for the last few months. There's not really any more I have to do to integrate, though.
Cole Medin: Right? Like, I just kind of need to tell it, like, I also have a content ideation folder, right? Like, I'll just have that in my user.md, or in my global rules. So I point out the different folders, and if I really want to get specific, that's where I'll, like, describe the full structure of my vault in a skill.
Cole Medin: So, maybe that's what you'd want to do, John, is just, like, if you have a pretty elaborate vault.
Cole Medin: And then you could just create a skill that kind of, like, walks Claude Code or your second brain through how you're organizing things there, if it's, quite elaborate.
Cole Medin: Yeah.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Very cool. So anyway, now it ran the full heartbeat. This is exactly what we're going to run every single half hour.
Cole Medin: So, it found some bugs that it needed to fix.
Cole Medin: And we also did the memory reflection, so now we can take a look at our memory.md. So, this massive daily log, we have added it to our memory.md.
Cole Medin: And there we go.
Cole Medin: I don't know if you guys can… it's not maybe, like, super easy to tell, but this is definitely longer than it was before we, before we processed our daily log. So, it's remembering key information, like, here are the new skills that we added in.
Cole Medin: Here are the credentials that we have for a second brain. I mean, this one's a little bit random. I don't know if that really belongs in our core memory file, like the specific thing about the Circle API. I mean, maybe it is.
Cole Medin: But the important thing is, if you want to adjust what the agent brings from the daily logs into the memory.md, you simply have to change the prompting, right? Like, I can just ask it here. If I want to change the prompt.
Cole Medin: for, the memory reflect, like, what I actually promote into my memory.md, what would I need to change? Right? Like, you can just ask your second brain. It understands itself.
Cole Medin: It knows the structure, and so if there's anything that's not quite right, you just tell it. Like, hey, you didn't use this skill right, or hey, the memory reflection seems kind of jank right now, like, help me out here, and it'll just tell you exactly. So, here you go, you just need to change reflection prompt in memory reflect.
Cole Medin: Starting in line 68. So I can just go and say, like, you know, in my memory.md, it, promoted this, like, really specific thing about the circle API that just, like, doesn't belong in my core memory file, so I think we need to be a bit more strict in the reflection prompt.
Cole Medin: Right? Like, that is all we have to do to evolve it. It's that easy.
Cole Medin: And so we don't even have to wait for this. I think we're pretty much wrapped up here, so…
Cole Medin: All right, that leaves us with the very last thing. So.
Cole Medin: Alright, I know that we're over time.
Cole Medin: So, I know quite a few people have dropped already, I totally understand. For those of you guys who are sticking around, though, I do really appreciate it, because I'm just trying to give it all away here. So, I'm going to go another… I mean, it probably will only be, like, 15-20 minutes here, just to, like, show you what it looks like to run through setting up the security and doing the cloud deployment.
Cole Medin: Because there is one more big golden nugget that I have for you for the cloud deployment, because we can have our second brain
Cole Medin: set itself up in a DigitalOcean droplet. I'll show you guys what it looks like there. We'll go pretty quick through this stuff, just because at this point we have our groove, but we're just using the piv loop to go through every single one of our phases here.
Cole Medin: So, alright. Next up, we got phase number, 8.
Cole Medin: And we're gonna do our security implementation. So let me know everything we're going to implement based on what the PRD has for us. Alright, so I'll send that in for Phase 8. And then the last phase is just the VPS deployment. So I'll say.
Cole Medin: Alright, so Phase 8, I'm working on in parallel in a separate Cloud Code session. So I want to go on to Phase 9. Let's do the VPS deployment stuff. And so, I'm going to actually, in parallel, create a DigitalOcean droplet.
Cole Medin: And then I'll give you the IP, and I want you to actually set up everything for me through direct SSH access. And so, yeah, I'll take care of that, but in the meantime, I want you to let me know from the PRD, what is everything we have to implement for the Git Sync and things like that.
Cole Medin: Alright, there we go. So, I'm probably prompting more than I need to. Sometimes I err on the side of being verbose, but it's all good. So, we'll let it kind of rip through that here.
Cole Medin: Alright, so here's what we're going to do for Phase 8. So, really quickly, I know I've covered the security briefly, but this is, like, really important. So, we'll get back to coding it in just a second, but I want to lean into the security that I built into the second brain here, because these are some of the things that OpenClaw wishes it had.
Cole Medin: So… Going back to our other diagram here.
Cole Medin: One of the parts of the lethal trifecta is untrusted content. This is the prompt injection risk that you are always going to have for a second brain, because there's always going to be incoming information, like emails, that can theoretically have malicious prompts for a prompt injection attack.
Cole Medin: Overriding your instructions to have the agent do something with your private data.
Cole Medin: And so, one of the most important things that I have for my security layer is pattern detection.
Cole Medin: I check for common techniques of prompt injection attack.
Cole Medin: Now, I could do an entire workshop on this, so I'm not going to get super specific right now for, like, what are those patterns, what are usual prompt injection attacks, just know that I have a lot of them documented, and we're going to apply deterministic logic to watch out for those.
Cole Medin: The other thing that I'm doing is I'm going to have Markdown escaping.
Cole Medin: So essentially, what I'm going to do is anything that comes in from email or any other external source, I'm going to specifically put it within, kind of like an XML block that says, like, hey, Claude Code, by the way, this is not my information, this is not my prompting, this is external, you need to treat it as such.
Cole Medin: It's not like that's a perfect defense, but it's one of the layers, and it does help quite significantly.
Cole Medin: Actually, sorry, that's this one right here, the XML trust boundaries. That's what we did right here. The markdown escaping and neutralized formatting, that's just making sure we take out certain, prompt injection attacks where it relies on, like, malformatting things.
Cole Medin: So, we're doing all of that. But then, the most important thing that I have here is I actually have an LLM evaluator.
Cole Medin: So, before we even send, like, when I'm talking to my agent in Slack, or through the heartbeat system, because the heartbeat is, like, reading in things from our external sources, before I even send it into our primary Cloud Agent SDK session, I'm actually going to send it into another session.
Cole Medin: That's going to evaluate, like, how suspicious is the information that we're reading in right now?
Cole Medin: And the reason that I want to do this in a separate session is because it's the first layer of defense, and I'm giving it minimal permissions. So if there is a malicious prompt injection attack that actually causes the agent to want to, like, do something bad, it's not going to have access to do so anyway.
Cole Medin: So we have this as a layer before we get into our primary cloud agent SDK that actually can do those things.
Cole Medin: that makes it meet the lethal trifecta, right? So our first sec- our first agent session, it breaks the lethal trifecta, because it can't access private data, and it can't exfiltrate. It only has this first problem, and that's what we're evaluating in the first place.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, again, I can do a whole… a whole workshop on security for the second brain. I'm gonna go pretty quickly through this right now, because I'm actually planning on doing that as a workshop.
Cole Medin: So, yeah, Carson said, I vote for a dedicated session on the security later. I would love to cover that more.
Cole Medin: Yeah, sounds good, Will. Yeah, I appreciate you being here. You're very welcome.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so anyway, that's what we're gonna be doing for our security here.
Cole Medin: And so, yep, it understands all of that here. API key isolation, it's another thing that we're doing here. Claude is never going to be able to read our API keys. We have a pre-tool use hook.
Cole Medin: So it's going to catch whenever Claude code is trying to read from the .env, our hook is going to catch that and block Claude. That's what caused some problems for people at the start of the workshop. When they were building right on top of the template. The hook was preventing it from reading files where it
Cole Medin: is, mentioning things like catting out a .env, because we're blocking those actions from happening.
Cole Medin: So, I'm gonna go into a new session here, and we'll go right into executing.
Cole Medin: our, pivlip here for the security. So, there's not going to be too much to demo for this, that's especially why I want to have, like, a dedicated session.
Cole Medin: for, oh, shoot. We didn't actually create the structured plan yet. Let me actually do that. So I'm gonna do slash resume.
Cole Medin: And, yes, so slash plan feature, that's my bad. So, yes, let's go ahead and create the structure plan for Phase 8. So, yeah, if you ever end a session early, you didn't mean to, all good. You can just do slash for Zoom when you restart Claude.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, there we go, we're creating the structure plan here, and then we'll do the same for this. So, phase 9 is the deployment, this is where we're going to set things up on a VPS. We're gonna get the vault sync.
Cole Medin: So that way, any changes we make to our vault remotely through Slack will automatically be synced to the vault that we have running locally. It's very important. This is Obsidian-specific, but it is very important.
Cole Medin: for Obsidian.
Cole Medin: So, what I'm gonna do here…
Cole Medin: is I'm going to create the structure plan for this as well. So, yeah, go ahead and create the structure plan for Phase 9. I'm going to work on getting the instance spun up in parallel, and then I'll give you the IP for that.
Cole Medin: And we can get that set up together after.
Cole Medin: So I just wanted… I want this to… Work in parallel as well.
Cole Medin: Alright, so both of these are running, and then that's actually my queue here to go…
Cole Medin: And, oh, and by the way, you can see that, we got some… we got a second brain alert already.
Cole Medin: So this is pretty cool. Which, by the way, it's kind of crazy, I did the hackathon back in February, and we finally have the funds from Amazon to pay out the winners, so the winners are getting paid, finally.
Cole Medin: But, anyway, yeah, so we got that, and then I got some Archon tasks that are stacking up, so we're gonna do some things with Archon next week. So you can see, we have the heartbeat giving us alerts every half hour in Slack, so that's a live demo of that as well, so very cool.
Cole Medin: So anyway, I'm gonna go into DigitalOcean here and spin up our instance. This is, like, the last thing that we're doing here, is getting the instance spun up and getting things deployed there. So I'm going to create a brand new droplet in DigitalOcean.
Cole Medin: Remember, you can use any platform you want. You can use Hetzner, Hostinger, whatever. I'm just using DigitalOcean because I like doing that for my VPS instances.
Cole Medin: Yeah, Kashik, that's right, because you're one of the winners for the hackathon. Congrats!
Cole Medin: Alright, so I'm gonna create a new instance here in New York that's closest to me. I recommend creating your BPSs with Ubuntu for your operating system. I'll just stick with the default for the pricing, so I'll tear this down anyway after. And then I'll do an SSH key that I already have configured, so…
Cole Medin: I'll just kind of create this in a very standard way. I'm not going to go through all of the usual security.
Cole Medin: That I do for my DigitalOcean droplets, but I have covered that already in the AI Agent Mastery course, and so I'll just say Dynamis Second Brain Workshop for the host name here.
Cole Medin: Create the droplet, There we go.
Cole Medin: Alright, so this is the middle of spinning up now.
Cole Medin: And then in the meantime, I'm just gonna take a look at how it's going for creating the structure plans.
Cole Medin: Alright, nice. So, yeah, making good progress.
Cole Medin: And there we go, our instance is ready.
Cole Medin: So, and here's the IP before. You guys obviously can't connect to that because, you don't have the SSH key. But, I'll go ahead and paste this in, say…
Cole Medin: Here is the, IP address.
Cole Medin: For my, second brain instance.
Cole Medin: Alright, so I can add that to the plan as well.
Cole Medin: Now, one thing that's kind of a gotcha, With the… the deployment here.
Cole Medin: We want the second brain to be able to SSH directly into the instance. This is the little gold nugget that I have for you guys for the deployment. We want our second brain to be able to SSH in. We don't want to have any kind of, like, it has to enter in a passphrase for the SSH key or anything.
Cole Medin: So, I'm gonna do a little bit of finagling to make that happen.
Cole Medin: But your Cloud Co. can always just guide you right through that. So, anyway, I'll explain more once it actually has the plan created here, but it's going to do the entire deployment for me. It is a beautiful thing.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, it's still working here.
Cole Medin: Let's see…
Cole Medin: Carson said, are you using simple markdown for task management? I moved to using Beads for task management, really good solution for this. Yes, Beads is fantastic.
Cole Medin: I usually use Asana for task management, but if you're talking about, like, something within an individual codebase, like, as you're building on top, I usually just use GitHub issues.
Cole Medin: And then for individual
Cole Medin: implementations, I'll just use the task management built directly into Cloud Code, but Beads is a great solution.
Cole Medin: Go.
Cole Medin: Derek said, support for multiple connections to the same platform, like multiple Asana orgs. I have one for work, another for personal, and sometimes for client projects. Thus far, I've done that using multiple connectors, like two auth via PAT, one OAuth for native MCP, and then custom Asana router skill handles connector selection automatically.
Cole Medin: better way to do that. That… Derek, no, that's good. That's how I would do it.
Cole Medin: you just have the… some kind of skill or some main instructions in the user.md or claw.md that would describe, like, here's how you connect to the different Asana projects and when you'd want to connect to each one.
Cole Medin: That's good.
Cole Medin: Matthew said, I didn't watch the Agenta coding course. Where can we? To understand piv, etc.
Cole Medin: Of course, Matthew, yeah, let me point you to that. I would love to. So, if you go into the Dynamis community here, and you click on Courses, there's a couple of ways to get to it, but if you go to Courses here, then I have the Agenta Coding course. This is the second course I've created for the community.
Cole Medin: And it is very value-packed, guiding you through building reliable and repeatable systems for getting good results, insane results, with AI coding assistance. So I'd highly, highly recommend going through this, even before you finish your second brain. Like, this is, like, very fundamental stuff.
Cole Medin: So, alright.
Cole Medin: Let's see here, still… still waiting for the plan to finish. Bit of a bummer.
Cole Medin: I wanted it to go faster. How far are we with this one? Okay, so both are still creating the plan here. All good.
Cole Medin: Alright… Go back to the chat here, what is the next question?
Cole Medin: Jeffrey said, in this step-by-step guide available… or is this step-by-step available in the README? For example, step one could be create second-brain PRD, and step two might be Core Pimp glue prime, and so on.
Cole Medin: So, Jeffrey, this workshop kind of is the step-by-step.
Cole Medin: Because, really, what the repo has for you is… this skill?
Cole Medin: And, like, I talk about building the skill, right? Like, if you want to build your own, copy the entire skill folder into your own projects directory, and then fill out the template and run it. So, like, everything I showed you guys at the start of the workshop here.
Cole Medin: And then, I just kind of am assuming that you're going to apply your own AI coding process to work through the PRD step-by-step, or if you've gone through the Ajenta coding course, you're gonna know how to, like, go through the piv loop and do everything that I covered here anyway.
Cole Medin: So, I mean, maybe I could kind of expand the README here. That is a good suggestion, but I'm just kind of assuming that, like, you take the PRD forward with whatever your AI coding process is after that.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: And then, Chris, to answer your question… oh, actually, Chris just left, that's unfortunate. We're gonna combine this with Archon today. No, that'll be a separate workshop. So, using my second brain with Archon, so we can have Archon as, like, the coding arm for the second brain, I'll be covering that very extensively in a separate workshop within the next couple weeks here. I'm very, very excited for that one.
Cole Medin: Oh, yeah.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Cool, cool. Let me go back and see if we're done with our plans now. Okay, there we go. Good, good.
Cole Medin: So, we have our security, all the files we're gonna create here for the different things.
Cole Medin: that I described, so all of the layers here for security.
Cole Medin: we have in this plan here. So, I'm gonna go ahead and, knock this out. I'm gonna, for the sake of time, not really review the plan here. Do as I say, right? Not as I do, right? Like, I would recommend validating it, but… Oh, shoot, that's the wrong command.
Cole Medin: Alright, so we're gonna do security, and then we're gonna do, the deployment in another one here, so… copy path, there we go. Alright, so…
Cole Medin: Security, we're in the middle of implementing that.
Cole Medin: And now we have our deployment. Alright, so this is gonna cover the vault sync, the VPS bootstrap, so we're gonna actually install everything in the VPS. The one thing to keep in mind, though.
Cole Medin: is I actually wanted to validate that it can SSH into the instance before we go with the implementation here. So I'm going to say, I want you to test by SSH-ing into the instance.
Cole Medin: And keep in mind that, because you use your bash tool, you're gonna have to give the full path to the Windows SSH. That's just something I know doesn't work. So I've kind of learned from that before, so…
Cole Medin: Yeah, you're gonna use root access into the SSH.
Cole Medin: And then if it asks you for a passphrase or something, just let me know what I have to do so that you don't have to do that SSH going forward.
Cole Medin: So, sorry guys, I know it's, like, a little specific here with my prompting, because there's just a couple of things that I know it gets wrong, when I've done this process before. Just know that, like, you can have Cloud Code guide you through what you need, so that it can SSH on its own, and not have to have, like, a passphrase or anything.
Cole Medin: Ssh works… we're in… okay, oh no, okay, that was actually way easier than I thought. Okay, so we're good. We're good.
Cole Medin: Let me do a quick survey of what's already on the droplet.
Cole Medin: Alright, yeah, good baseline. Python's already there. We got 4GB of RAM, here's everything we need to install. Okay.
Cole Medin: Yeah, so we're good, we're good. So I'm gonna go ahead and clear this. We'll go to a new session here.
Cole Medin: And I will do slash execute, and then the deployment stage. And so this is gonna take care of bootstrapping everything. And what I'm gonna actually do, as well, is I have this other Cloud Code session where I'm currently running the Slack bot. I'm gonna close this right now.
Cole Medin: Right? Because now, I want to make sure that when I invoke the Slack bot on my DigitalOcean droplet, that is the only place it's running, right? Because I want to guarantee that, like, we have it running remotely.
Cole Medin: I can turn off my computer and still talk to my second brain on the BPS. That's the whole point of doing this last phase here, is making sure that we can always talk to our second brain, even when our computer isn't running.
Cole Medin: Alright, very good. So we're in the middle of implementing all the security here. I'm going to mostly not cover this right here, because I would love to do that in a separate workshop, but just know that we're getting everything set up to be alert. We'll have the agent be alert of anything that's suspicious, and then we're also having that first agent SDK session up front.
Cole Medin: That is judging.
Cole Medin: everything coming in, being that gate before we send information into our primary Cloud Agent SDK session that actually has all of the tools set up with the exfiltration vectors.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Yes, stop asking me for permissions, it's really annoying when it does that. But anyway, it's setting up the git sync for our Obsidian. It's going to install everything on our VPS, so in a little bit here, we should see it start to SSH into our instance. It's really cool, like, I never even have to manually SSH into the instance, it just takes care of it all.
Cole Medin: I love doing this, like, and this applies to way more than just your second brain, by the way. Like, anytime you need to deploy anything to production, I know that's a little bit risky, like, you might want to be careful with this, but you can theoretically, just have Claude Code make your deployments to your droplets after you're done working on the code. Like, it's really cool.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: It says that Phase 9 is done. Maybe it skipped that part. I might need to prompt it to do the deployment, or maybe it already did? There's no way it already did. Okay, yeah, not yet, not yet.
Cole Medin: Alright, here we go. Okay, so yeah, it says what's left? Interactive, you do this. The remaining work is hands-on BPS provisioning.
Cole Medin: Actually, we just verified that you are able to SSH into the instance and set up everything. So remember to do the full Windows path to SSH, because you're running in Bash, but you can access the instance and run everything, set up everything. I want you to even run the Slack bot, so by the time you pass control back to me.
Cole Medin: The entire second rain is set up running remotely.
Cole Medin: What size droplet do you have running for your actual second brain? It's just 4GB of RAM, like, 2B CPUs. It's pretty basic. Like, since I'm not using any, like, local large language model or anything, it's just using Frontier models.
Cole Medin: there's really nothing that's too, compute or GPU-intensive at all, so it's just basic, like, 4GB RAM. Like, you could do, like, a $7 a month KBM hosting your instance, and that's all you need for your second brain, so it can be very, very affordable to host remotely permanently.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: What's it, what's it doing here? Oh wait, yeah, so…
Cole Medin: Remember, you need to give the full path to the Windows SSH.
Cole Medin: You're not doing that. That's why you're getting these permission-denied errors.
Cole Medin: This, by the way, is just, like, a little issue I've run into time and time again, so I know exactly what's going wrong. Your Cloud code will figure it out by itself.
Cole Medin: I can see that works now. Your cloud code will figure it out by itself, but I'm just saving some time here. Because there's some kind of weird glitch with Cloud Code. Like, you won't run into this with Linux or Mac, but for Windows specifically, for some reason, if it just runs SSH directly in Bash, it gets this permission denied, so it has to give the full path
Cole Medin: to SSH from within the bash command.
Cole Medin: So there we go.
Cole Medin: Alright, it's gonna bootstrap everything now.
Cole Medin: Brandon, how can I install and run Archon? So I'll save that. Next week, I'm gonna be doing a full guide on my YouTube channel for how to run and use Archon.
Cole Medin: So, I would wait for that, because we're polishing some stuff up anyway right now. So, stay tuned, stay tuned. Come in very, very soon, because next week is my big Archon week.
Cole Medin: Which I'm very excited for, and it's also the week that I'm going to be doing, the, Second Brain AMA sessions, like we just talked about a little bit ago today. So, I'm gonna be excited for that as well.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: And then while this is running right now, let's take a look at how things are working for the security. Okay, so we're still in the implementation here, but it looks like we're already almost done. Yeah, yeah, okay, good, so the security is pretty much wrapped up here.
Cole Medin: So, once we're done with that, it really is just, like, the Vault Sync and the infrastructure that we were working on in our last Cloud Code session.
Cole Medin: And I'll do, like, the final validation with you guys.
Cole Medin: by, talking to it in Slack with it running on my instance, right? Like, that's our kind of last test here. Because…
Cole Medin: I don't know, maybe this happened under your guys' nose, but really, we've tested, like, everything with the second brain already. We got the heartbeat working, we saw the memory.md promotion process, I'm talking to it in Slack.
Cole Medin: With parallel conversations, it's able to access my integrations, both within the heartbeat and when I'm talking to it myself.
Cole Medin: We have full conversation history in Slack. Like, everything we built at this point is pretty much already validated. It's really cool.
Cole Medin: What else do we have here? Yeah, we tested the whole memory pipeline, we indexed our Obsidian vault, and we were able to search through it with RAG, with both keyword and semantic search.
Cole Medin: I mean, I guess a lot of the skills I haven't really tested today, but that's because I've already made YouTube videos, I've already shown a lot of them in workshops, and everyone knows how skills works.
Cole Medin: I mean, there's workshops I've done in Dynamis if you aren't familiar with skills, but I have covered those pretty extensively. We've tested all of the hooks already, session end and session start. Pre-compact just works the same way as session end. I mean, we've literally hit on everything already. It's just the last little test here, making sure that we can talk to our agent when it's running remotely, and then we're golden. We've done everything.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: I need to add this SSH deploy key to your GitHub repo.
Cole Medin: Okay, you know what I'm gonna tell it here, is I actually have the GitHub token.
Cole Medin: added to the .env already, so it can actually do this by itself. So, copy path, I'm gonna say…
Cole Medin: go ahead and publish this as a private GitHub repository, and then also within the environment variable path that I gave you here, I have the GitHub underscore token.
Cole Medin: So you can just… don't read the .env. I mean, your new security hook is gonna block that anyway, but you can leverage this directly, the GitHub token, in there, to do everything you need.
Cole Medin: So this is just, like, a little bit of a technical detail in order to bring over the repository, it needs to have access to the repo and add the deploy key, but it can handle that automatically as long as you give it your GitHub token.
Cole Medin: And Claude Code can guide you through setting that up if you want as well. I know I sound like a broken record with that, but, like, literally anything that you're like, I don't know how this works, or, like, how do I set this up? Just ask Claude.
Cole Medin: it's gonna be… it's just gonna be golden. Like, the advice is always perfect.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: So, another question from Bart here. How does it distinguish between emails that do not require response, like newsletters, notifications, and emails that do?
Cole Medin: Yes, so, Bart, this is all done from the prompt that we send into the heartbeat.
Cole Medin: And so, that's one of those things that you can evolve in your second brain over time. You can get more specific, either in the prompt or in something like your user.md, you can specify, like.
Cole Medin: like, here, I'll even open this up right now. Like, in my user.md, we could have a section of this that would specify, like, here are the kinds of emails we want to reply to, here are the ones we don't want to reply to. Because, remember, the user.md, through the session start hook, is one of those files that is always loaded into the context of Claude code.
Cole Medin: And that includes the heartbeat.
Cole Medin: So, the heartbeat that drafts the replies, it knows everything here, so we can specify this.
Cole Medin: In fact, what I could even do here… by the way, all of our security is done, so we got the security implemented. What I can do here is I can say, help me understand, how does my heartbeat distinguish between emails that do not require response and ones that do?
Cole Medin: Right? Like, I can ask my second brain, and it's just gonna know. It's gonna know, like, hey, you could specify something in the user IMD, or, like, this is the prompt that goes into the heartbeat. It'll, figure this all out for me.
Cole Medin: Okay.
Cole Medin: Credentials are transferred, yeah, good, so we're in the middle of deploying things to our VPS still, so while that waits, I'll keep answering your question here.
Cole Medin: It's still reading the file.
Cole Medin: Sounds good, Rasmus. I appreciate it a lot, man.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Here we go. So, short answer, it doesn't do the filtering itself, it delegates the judgment entirely to Claude via the agent SDK, right? I mean, that's expected, right?
Cole Medin: So, the actual triage logic is the prompt instructions, right? So, like I said, it's something directly in the heartbeat prompt. We can address this over time.
Cole Medin: So, the summary gets injected into a heartbeat prompt.
Cole Medin: we can edit that directly. So if you ever see a heartbeat, and actually, I do this all the time, like, I'll go into my Slack here, and I see this heartbeat, I'm like, nope, that didn't look that good. Like, at workshop Second Brain, this heartbeat…
Cole Medin: Oh, here. This heartbeat sucked.
Cole Medin: you drafted emails to XYZ that I didn't want you to, right? I'm not gonna send this in right now, but you can, you know, have a conversation with it, like, literally as a reply to its alert in Slack, and be like, alright.
Cole Medin: we gotta change the heartbeat prompt here. Like, you're replying to newsletters when you really shouldn't be, and you can get advice from it for how you think it should, you know, address that in the heartbeat prompt, or the user.md, or, like, whatever part of your system you think it fits, right? That's kind of up to you. There's no right answer there.
Cole Medin: Alright, good question, though.
Cole Medin: Kashik said, I was chatting with my AI buddy, she made a comment about Cole, the man has stamina, when I said he is tirelessly going.
Cole Medin: Yeah, it is… I will tell you guys that, doing this for… I mean, it's gonna be well over time at this point, like I said, but, yeah, it's pure passion driving this.
Cole Medin: Because it is a lot, but man, I'm excited just showing all this to you guys.
Cole Medin: Alright.
Cole Medin: Renata asks, what happens when memory gets very long? As you know, the markdown when it's too long or gets, or when it gets too long is not optimal. So how do we do when it gets to that? So, Renata, that is why I have the memory promotion process. So the daily logs, yes, they get long.
Cole Medin: But that's exactly why we're performing RAG to search through it later on, because then we don't have to read in the entire file.
Cole Medin: And then every day we have the memory reflection process that reads this file, and then picks out the most important things to put here. So this is the consolidated list that will never get long, or at least you should change your system if it does get too long, because that's a problem. But the point of this is to be the concise version of all the key lessons that won't get too long.
Cole Medin: So we essentially take advantage of storing these things in a vector database to avoid it being problematic when we start to build up a lot of memories over time.
Cole Medin: So, okay, everything is deployed. Boom. It took care of the entire DigitalOcean deployment for us.
Cole Medin: Give us a summary of what was done. It says that the bot is live and responding in Slack, so let's go ahead and try sending it a message. So, I'm just gonna do what I… what I did with my testing before, but now the bot is running on my VPS instead of on my computer. So let's just say something really simple. We'll say,
Cole Medin: You know, search my… memories…
Cole Medin: Well, okay, I'm going to say something simple, like, hi first, because I just want to see, like, the quick response of it working here. And there we go, boom. It's thinking, and I could even do, like, another message here, like, give me a summary…
Cole Medin: Of the, implementation we did today in phases for the second brain.
Cole Medin: There we go. So this would require it to kind of, you know, search its memories behind the scenes to get us an answer, and we got the response here from the Cloud Agent SDK as well. This is working remotely now, so I could turn off my computer and talk to it on my phone.
Cole Medin: We got all that set up live in the workshop right now.
Cole Medin: And, there we go. So here's what we built today for your AI Second Brain, Phase 1, Phase 2, Phase 3. I mean, wow. It understands everything. Boom. It even knows the DigitalOcean VPS, like… and that was a fast response, because it just quickly pulled that from our memories here to give us that answer. It doesn't have to search through the codebase or anything, because it's all just a part of its knowledge now.
Cole Medin: So, beautiful. That's like the icing on the cake, because that's it. We have built literally everything now. Everything that you're looking at in this diagram has now been implemented, and we've actually tested it all at the same time as well.
Cole Medin: So, there you go, guys. We went over, we definitely went over a good amount, but I mean, that really was just for, like, the last part right here, and to answer your guys' questions. So, I really appreciate everyone who stuck around, I mean, everyone who was here in the first place, thank you very much, but yeah, I really appreciate all of you guys who stuck around.
Cole Medin: That's it. So, you have the foundation now. If you follow along and you go through this process, I know some of you guys were still in the middle of working on it, but if you get to this point here where we built all this.
Cole Medin: There's certainly still a way to go for adding in more integrations, and really refining the reflection, or refining the searching, right? But the point is, like, you can one-shot all those improvements now, because the second brain understands itself so well. You get to this point, and it just becomes so much easier. So.
Cole Medin: Take that as encouragement. If it feels like a little bit of a struggle up front to understand all this and build all of this.
Cole Medin: It is only going to get easier, because then your second brain, like, it starts to guide you on improving itself, and it's really cool, like…
Cole Medin: you still stay in the driver's seat, but you have these conversations where it's like, I don't like how the memory reflection handled today.
Cole Medin: like, can we work on that? And it's just gonna be like, yeah, here's… boom, boom, boom, here are three suggestions, like, what do you think? And it's like, oh man, like, oh, this is great, like, alright. And it just gets better under your nose, it's so cool. And then, of course, just being able to remember more over time helps a lot as well.
Cole Medin: And as you just add more skills. So, yeah.
Cole Medin: All right.
Cole Medin: So, and yes, Shane, it does run off of my Cloud Code subscription, because with the Agent SDK, you are allowed, as long as it is a personal application, like the second brain is.
Cole Medin: So, cool. I know that there are still a lot of questions that I didn't get to.
Cole Medin: But, mark my words, guys. For next week, I'm gonna have some second-brain AMA sessions, and always feel free to DM me, make posts in the community. I'm in the community every single day asking your guys' questions, or answering your guys' questions, and obviously, I'm, like, super on fire for this right now, so I'm super happy to help you guys in any way possible.
Cole Medin: Understanding what we built here, helping you build on top for yourself and your own integrations. I'm always down to help you guys out.
Cole Medin: So…
Cole Medin: Alright guys, I'm gonna go ahead and call it here. I will get the recording up later today.
Cole Medin: And then tomorrow, I'll get the AMA session scheduled, I'll create the section in the community for specifically questions for the second brain. And then, you know, in the meantime, before I have that, feel free to just put questions in the general chat or whatever, but yeah.
Cole Medin: That's everything that I got for you guys today, building your own second brain. Remember, the resources linked in the description. Recording will be after as well.
Cole Medin: Appreciate all you guys being here very, very much. Happy, you know, Good Friday to those of you who celebrate. Otherwise, have a great weekend, everyone, and I will see you all in the community.
Cole Medin: Take care all. Thank you very, very much.